GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WELCOME TO THE US
SENATE.
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE --
TODAY WERE HAVING AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING REGARDING
THE PGA ANY CHAPTER ELEVEN
REORGANIZATION BANKRUPTCY.
AND HOW THIS IMPLICATES
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIANS
REPAIRS.
EVERYONE INVOLVED.
OF AS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW P.
JENNY IS ONE OF THE LARGEST.
PROVIDERS OF ENERGY IN OUR STATE --
THEY ENCOMPASS THE LARGEST YOUR
GRAPHICAL AREA OF ANY UTILITY.
AND THEIR OPERATION IN PROVIDING.
ENERGY TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IS IT ESSENTIAL. TO
OUR HEALTH ECONOMY [inaudible]
WELL BEEN [inaudible]
OF AND OF THAT THE CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES FACING THEIR BUT
BANKRUPTCY HAS BEEN --
IN MANY CASES OF UNEXPECTED FIVE
BY MANY OF PEOPLE THE PUBLIC.
ON JANUARY TWENTY NINTH --
P. GINNY.
IN ESSENCE VOLUNTARILY FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY PROTECTION UNDER
CHAPTER.
ELEVEN ALSO KNOWN --
TO EVERYONE AS A REORGANIZATIONS
WITHIN THE U. S. BANKRUPTCY CODE.
AS THE COMPANY STATED IN ITS -
OF FILENE'S.
IN THE ACTUAL DOCUMENTATION.
A P. GENIES DECISION TO SEEK
RELIEF UNDER CHAPTER.
ELEVEN WAS NECESSITATED BY A
CONFLUENCE OF FACTORS ROOF
RESULTING FROM THE CATASTROPHIC
CONTRACT PROJECT WILD FIRES.
THAT OCCURRED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND P. GENIES A
POTENTIAL LIFE LIABILITIES
RISING.
FROM THERE IN MANY CASES THOSE
FILING SUGGESTS THAT THE
POTENTIAL LIABILITY OF THE
UTILITY.
RELATED TO THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN FIRES COULD EXCEED
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS.
P. GINNY'S DECISION. TO
VOLUNTARILY FIRE FOR BANKERS WHO
BIRD PROTECTION HAS RAISED.
NUMEROUS QUESTIONS SAYS RACIST
CONCERNS [inaudible]
ABOUT -- TO
SEE AN OR ELECTED IN TO GO --
THE RE.
PROCESS.
AND OF COURSE THERE ARE NUMEROUS
IMPLICATIONS --
TO ALL THE VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS
A COULD BE AFFECTED INCLUDING
WILDFIRE VICTIMS --
THE CUSTOMERS THE RATE PAYERS
THE UTILITY WORK FORCE.
OF CONTRACTORS ENERGY AND OTHER
SUPPLIERS LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
MANY OTHERS THIS PRETTY MUCH
WRAPS UP.
EVERY STAKEHOLDER IN OUR STATE
IN THIS PROCESS.
TODAY'S HEARING.
IS AN ATTEMPT TO HELP ANSWER
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN -- A
RESULT OF OF THIS BANKRUPTCY
FILING.
AND OF COURSE OF ARE.
OUR INTEREST IS TO PROVIDE OUR
OR TRY US ATTEMPT TO PROVIDE.
SOME --
ANSWERS TO THE PUBLIC AND TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SHOULD OF ANY ACTION BE REQUIRED.
MAYBE THAT WOULD COME OUT OF
THIS AND MAYBE BUT WE'RE GOING
TO DO OUR BEST. TO TRY TO INFORM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
IN ORDER TO ASSIST AND AND
FURTHER IN OUR UNDERSTANDING WE
OF LAW ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR.
JERRY ALLIANCE TO CLARIFY THE
CHAPTER ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY
PROCESS.
INCLUDING UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS
ENTAILED RELATED.
TO TIMING ROLES KEY PHASES AND
THE PROCESS TO DEVELOP AN
APPROVED.
A REORGANIZATION PLAN.
FOLLOWING PROFESSOR LICE'S
PRESENTATION WE WILL HEAR FROM
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
WHO WILL HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CHAPTER?
ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY FILING --
AS AS IT AFFECTS.
OF REGULATED UTILITY.
I HAVE ASKED THE CPUC TO SHARE
INFORMATION CONCERNING THE
STATE'S STANDING.
AND THE STATE'S REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT OF THE UTILITY DURING
THE BANKRUPTCY PROCESS.
IN ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE ALL --
WE ALL ON TO MORE THOROUGHLY AND
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE BANKRUPTCY.
ON GAS AND ELECTRIC SERVICE AND
SAFETY.
WILDFIRE GAS INCLUDING NUCLEAR.
FOR THAT MATTER.
SINCE WE STILL POSSESSED CENTER
STATE.
WITH THIS BEING P. JEANNIE
SECOND --
CHAPTER ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY FILING
A LESSON TWENTY YEARS.
I'VE ALSO ASKED THE CPUC TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT.
CONCERNING THE PREVIOUS
BANKRUPTCY CASE IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE AND WHAT IS THE
RELEVANCE IN THIS CASE --
IF ANY [inaudible]
GRANTED --
OR I'LL BE AT THE CONCERT --
CIRCUMSTANCES LEADING UP TO THE
A BANKRUPTCY FILING ARE ARE VERY
DIFFERENT.
BUT OTHER MAY BE --
SOME HELPFUL TAKEAWAYS FROM THE
TWO THOUSAND ONE BANKRUPTCY IN
TERMS OF HOW IT WAS DEALT AND
HOW THIS ONE COULD BE DEALT.
A AND AND IF IF WE CAN BETTER
INFORM OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THESE ISSUES.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
THIS.
ARE THE FINAL PANEL OF THE
HEARING A INCLUDE SIX WITNESSES
TO SPEAK TO THE POTENIAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THE P. JEANNIE
BANKRUPTCY FILING FOR WILD FIRE
VICTIMS --
THAT INCLUDES RATEPAYERS UTILITY
WORK FORCE AND OTHERS.
AND I YOU KNOW I WANT TO BE
CLEAR IN IN IN THIS THAT UNDER
NO CIRCUMSTANCES ARE WE
PRESUMING.
THESE SIX WITNESSES REPRESENT
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO MAY BE
AFFECTED BY THE BANKRUPTCY.
BUT RATHER THEY ARE SIMPLY --
pSLICE OF THE PIE.
A REPRESENTING ALL OF OF OF THE
MS -- IN IN
A IN A VERY SMALL WAY --
INDEED DID THE A TENT.
THE INTENT IN THIS IS.
PROVIDE MANNER MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND THE PUBLIC A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WIDE
RANGING ISSUES.
THAT ARE OF CONCERN AND HOW THEY
MAY AFFECT PEOPLE AND ARE
AFFECTING PEOPLE CURRENTLY.
A NOTICEABLY NOT INCLUDED
TODAY'S AGENDA OF COURSE IS A
REPRESENT AND REPRESENTATIVES
FROM BG ANY.
THERE MAY BE A MORE APPROPRIATE
TIME IN THE FUTURE --
TO DISCUSS.
THIS BANKRUPTCY WITH MEMBERS OF
P. GINNY BUT THE THE OBJECTIVES
TODAY IS --
TO GAIN A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE PROCESS.
OF THIS PARTICULAR BANKRUPTCY
CASE.
AS WELL AS TO HELP SERVICE SOME
OF THE IMPLICATIONS TO
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS.
THE COMMITTEE DOES NOT INTEND TO
HAVE TODAY'S HEARING RESOLVE THE
ISSUES WITHIN THE BY A
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS OR OR TO BE.
THE VENUE BY WHICH WITNESSES
LITIGATE THEIR CLAIMS OR REYES.
THEIR CLAIMS.
WITH THIS IN MIND THE COMMITTEE
HAS CHOSEN TO FOCUS --
COMMENTS FROM OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS.
IN THIS PROCESS AT THIS TIME.
LASTLY I ALSO WANT TO PROVIDE A
CAUTION THAT WE ARE ALL VERY
MINDFUL TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
CAPITAL MARKETS TO ANY ACTION
THAT WE TAKE.
ON THESE RELATED ISSUES ANYTHING
WE SAY.
WHETHER IT'S TRUE OR NOT CAN
HAVE.
A CAN BE POTENTIALLY TO ON OUR
UTILITIES AND THIR ABILITY TO
SERVE THE PROP PUBLIC.
I WOULD LIKE --
TO YOU KNOW UNDERSCORE THIS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE THAT THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
THIS IS ENTERED INTENDED TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THE
PUBLIC.
AND TO OUR THE THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE WE WILL NOT BE
VOTING ON ANY PROPOSALS TODAY OR
TAKING ACTION NOR IS THIS --
A A A GONNA LEAD TO ACTION IN
PARTICULAR.
A WILL IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE I WANT TO MAKE
THAT VERY CLEAR BECAUSE OF
COURSE.
MANY PEOPLE THEY ME LISTENING TO
AND WE HOPE THE WRONG MESSAGE IS
NOT TRANSMITTED.
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO THIRTY SIX
DISCUSSION WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN.
WITH OUR FIRST SPEAKER TODAY.
AND I'D LIKE TO AND I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY --
INVITING IN --
JERRY LAI S. THE ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW GOOD
MORNING.
WELCOME DON'T BE AFRAID WE DON'T
BITE HARD --
SO --
SHERMAN WHO HUESO IN HONOR OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TODAY TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT CHAPTER
ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY --
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND I AM AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF LAW AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAWN SAN
FRANCISCO IN MY RESEARCH AND
TEACHING FOCUSES ON BANKRUPTCY
LOSS OF THIS IS VERY MUCH A
SITUATION THAT.
IS RIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE OF WHAT
I TEACH IN RESEARCH ABOUT --
I WAS ASKED TODAY TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH SOME BACKGROUND IN CHAPTER --
ELEVEN AS YOU CONSIDER YOUR
REGULATORY SPONSOR ABILITIES IN
OPTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO P.
JEANNIE.
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
CONFUSION IN THE PRESS AND EVEN
AMONG MANY LAWYERS WHO DON'T
SPECIALIZE IN BANKRUPTCY ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT CHAPTER ELEVEN
BANKRUPTCY IS --
WHAT IT CAN DO FOR DISTRESSED
COMPANY HELP CLEAR UP SOME OF
THAT CONFUSION FOR YOU AND
PROVIDE YOU WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND THE WILL HELP INFORM
THE CHOICES?
THAT LINE FRONT OF YOU --
IN WHAT IS SHAPING UP TO BE ONE
OF THE MOST COMPLICATED AND
DIFFICULT CHAPTER ELEVEN CASES
OF ALL TIME.
ON IN GENERAL BANKRUPTCY LAW CAN
BE THOUGHT OF AS SOLVING THE
PROBLEMS THE FINANCIAL DISTRESS
CREATES IMAGINE THE SOMEBODY
WERE TO BORROW A HUNDRED DOLLARS
FROM A BANK TO START A STORE --
TO BE SENT TO THE STORE DOESN'T
WORK YOU KNOW WE THEN HAVE A
SERIES OF POLICY CHOICES ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY DO WE DO WITH THIS
PERSON SHOULD THIS PERSON BE
FORCED TO WORK FOR THE REST OF
THEIR IFE TO TRY TO MAKE THAT
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO THEY CAN PAY.
BACK THE BANK ON IT SHOULD THE
LOS SOMEHOW GIVE THIS PERSON A
FRESH START --
SO LONG AS THERE ARE SOME
BASELINE PROTECTIONS FOR
CREDITORS ON THE POLICY CHOICE
THE FEDERAL BANKRUPTCY Là MAKES
IS THAT IF YOU MAKE TOO MANY
PROMISES THAT YOU CAN'T KEEP.
YOU CAN FILE FOR CHAPTER ELEVEN
BANKRUPTCY RELIEF FOR OTHER
FORMS OF BANKRUPTCY RELIEF --
AND GET A CHANCE TO START OVER
GO ON WITH YOUR LIFE AND
CREDITORS ARE ENTITLED TO SOME
BASELINE --
TREATMENTS THAT IS PROVIDED BY
THE BANKRUPTCY CODE THIS IS WHY
OFTEN TEACH MY STUDENTS THE
BANKRUPTCY LAW IS THE LAW OF
BREAKING --
PROMISES --
PROMISES THAT YOU MAKE THE
CREDITORS AS WELL AS PROMISES
THAT YOU IMPLICITLY MAKE TO
PEOPLE WHO FOR EXAMPLE COME ON
OUR LAND AND ARE IMPLICITLY
ENTITLED TO BE MADE WHOLE IF
THEY WERE TO TRIP AND FALL OR TO
SUSTAIN SOME OTHER DAMAGES --
AND OBVIOUSLY PROMISES THAT YOU
MAKE TO GOVERNMENTS GOVERNMENTAL
REGULATORS IAN'S TWO QUARTS --
IMPORTANTLY BANKRUPTCY LAW
PROVIDES FOR TWO KINDS OF
TREATMENTS FOR DISTRESSED
COMPANIES ON THE FIRST IS THE
MOST FAMOUS ONE YOU HEAR
MENTIONED IN THE PRESS A LOT
CHAPTER.
ELEVEN I'M CHAPTER ELEVEN IS A
STATUTES OF BANKRUPTCY LAW.
AT A HIGH LEVEL WHEN A FIRM
FILED FOR CHAPTER --
ELEVEN THEY HAVE AN OPERATING
BUSINESS THAT IS GENERALLY A
GOOD BUSINESS THAT IS PRODUCING
PROFIT PERHAPS TOO LITTLE PROFIT
TO PAY FOR THE DEBTS ON THAT
THEY BORROWED IN THE PAST.
ON TO CHAPTER ELEVEN PROVIDES A
FIRM LIKE SOME OF THE DEATHS
THAT THEY BORROWED --
INTO PROTECT CREDITORS WHILE THE
SAME TIME GETTING RID OF UNDER
PERFORMING ASSETS AND I'M
SHUTTING BAD CONTRACTS.
IN SOME CASES FIRMS COULD
INSTEAD APPLY FOR WHAT WE CALL A
CHAPTER SEVEN LIQUIDATION IN A
CHAPTER SEVEN A FIRM IS
GENERALLY THROWING UP HIS HANDS
AND SAYING WE CAN'T FIGURE OUT
HOW TO USE WHATEVER ASSETS WE
HAVE IN A PROFITABLE WAY.
WE'RE JUST GONNA HAVE THE
EQUIVALENT OF A GARAGE SALE
THAT'S NOT WHAT P. GENIES AT P.
JEANNIE FILED FOR CHAPTER ELEVEN
BANKRUPTCY ON IN GENERAL
BANKRUPTCY LAW HAS BECOME SO
SOPHISTICATED IN BANKRUPTCY
PROFESSIONAL SO SOPHISTICATED --
THAT FOR THE MOST PART ON
CONSUMERS AND CREDITORS OF P.
JEANNIE WHO DO BUSINESS WITH P.
JEANNIE AS PART OF THEIR DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS WON'T EVEN NOTICE
THE DIFFERENCE --
NEXT I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
USEFUL TO SUMMARIZE Y. P. GENIE
IS BETTER OFF BECAUSE THEY FOUND
FOR BANKRUPTCY.
FIRST P. JEANNIE HAS ABOUT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IN BANK
THAT AND MOST THE BOND ACT WELL
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A LOT IT
ACTUALLY ISN'T IN THE GRAND
SCHEME OF P. JEANNIE BECAUSE P.
GENIE IS SO MASSIVE.
AND CREATES SO MUCH REVENUE ON
THIS MEANS P. JEANNIE HAS A VERY
DIFFERENT PROFILE THAN YOUR
AVERAGE CHAPTER ELEVEN CORPORATE
DEBTOR WHEN GENERAL MOTORS FOR
EXAMPLE FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY THEY
FILED BECAUSE THEY HAD CARS THE
PEOPLE DIDN'T WANT TO BUY IN
NEEDED TO FIX THAT --
P. GENIES CORE PRODUCT YOU KNOW
IT HAS DEMANDED CUSTOMERS WHO
NEED ELECTRICITY IN CALIFORNIA
ON P. JEANNIE FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY INSTEAD BECAUSE OF
THE MASSIVE AMOUNT OF LIABILITY
ASSOCIATE WITH THE VARIOUS WILD
FIRES THAT IT HAS BEEN FOUND
LIABLE FOR MAY BE LIABLE.
FOR ESPECIALLY THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES ON P. JEANNIE
CFO TESTIFIED ON THE FIRST DAY
OF THE BANKRUPTCY CASE THAT THEY
FACE MORE THAN FIFTY SIX HUNDRED
PLAINTIFFS WHO FILED MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY LAWSUITS.
RELATED TO THOSE TWO CASES THISLITIGATION IS INCREDIBLY
COMPLICATED IN A CERTAIN TO DRAW
IN VARIOUS INSURERS --
IN A WHILE IS OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES --
THE BENEFIT TO P. GENIE IS THAT
BANKRUPTCY LAW PROVIDES FOR AN
AUTOMATIC STAY OF THIS
LITIGATION THE AUTOMATIC STAY OF
LITIGATION MEANS THAT ALL OF
THESE COURT CASES INVOLVING P.
JEANNIE WHICH IS AGAIN.
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY LAWSUIT THE COURT --
WHERE THERE IS A CLAIMS PROCESS
CREATED BY FEDERAL LAW SO
OUTSIDE OF BANKRUPTCY --
IF YOU WANTS TO SUE P. JEANNIE
YOU GO TO YOUR STATE COURT TO
FILE A LAWSUIT AND THEN THERE'S
LITIGATION YOU COULD SEE JERRY
YOU COULD SEE A JUDGE INSIDE
BANKRUPTCY THE PROCESS IS VERY
DIFFERENT.
YOU FILE A CLAIM --
THROUGH THE BANKRUPTCY COURTS
CLAIMS PROCESS --
THERE MAY BE AN ESTIMATION
HEARING TO THE EXTENT THAT --
P. JEANNIE WERE TO CONTEST THE
CLAIM -- AND
WHAT COULD TAKE WEEKS OUTSIDE OF
BANKRUPTCY I GET MORE PERHAPS
EVEN MONTHS IN A STATE COURT I'M
CAN BE DEALT WITH BY THE
BANKRUPTCY JUDGE IN AN HOUR --
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
BANKRUPTCY LAW IS OFTEN A
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM OF
DEBTORS WHO HAVE LOTS OF TORT
CLAIMS OUT THERE THEY'RE BEING
SUED BY LOTS F PEOPLE THEY GET
A MORE EFFICIENT ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE --
THE SECOND BENEFIT OF CHAPTER
ELEVEN FOR P. GENIE IS THE
ABILITY TO GET NEW FINANCING --
AS THE CHAIRMAN MENTIONED IN HIS
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS THE ACCESS
TO CAPITAL MARKETS IS KEY FOR AN
ENERGY COMPANY --
GIVEN P. GENIES LIABILITY
SITUATION WHERE THEY HAVE SEEM
TO HAVE ALL OF THIS UNKNOWN ON
ESTIMATED ON LIQUIDATED TORT
LIABILITY ON IN MAY HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR PEACE YOU NEED TO
BORROW ADDITIONAL MONEY.
OUTSIDE OF BANKRUPTCY ON A
FAVORABLE GIVE NEW IN THE FORMAL
WE CALL A DEBTOR IN POSSESSION
LOAN ON A SUPER SENIOR CLAIM SO
A GROUP OF BANKS WHICH IS
CURRENTLY NOW PROMISING TO LAND
A LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY TO P.
JEANNIE --
CAN REST ASSURED THAT THEY'LL BE
PAID IN FULL ONCE THE BANKRUPTCY
JUDGE APPROVED THE BORROWING
WHICH IS ALREADY BEEN APPROVED --
BY THE CPUC.
SO THERE COUPLE OF NOTEWORTHY
THINGS ABOUT THE FIVE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR DIP LOAN THAT I
THOUGHT ARE WORTH EMPHASIZING
BECAUSE THEY POINT TO WHERE THIS
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS IS GOING
[inaudible]
ON FIRST.
THE SHEER SIZE OF THIS OUT OF
THE LOAN THE BANKS ARE WILLING
TO GIVE THE P. JEANNIE FIVE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IS
UNUSUAL THIS IS AN UNUSUALLY
LARGE DIP LOAN --
AND WITH THIS REFLECTS I THINK
IS THE INVESTOR COMMUNITIES
CONFIDENCE ON THE P. JEANNIE HAS
A BRIGHT FUTURE ONCE THEY FIGURE
OUT WHAT TO DO --
WITH THE LIABILITY SITUATION
THEY HAD IN THE PAST AS WELL AS
THE LIABILITY SITUATION THEY
HAVE GOING FORWARD --
ALSO BECAUSE IT'S A LOT OF MONEY
ON IT REFLECTS THE INVESTOR
COMMUNITIES VIEW PERHAPS THE P.
JEANNIE MIGHT BE IN BANKRUPTCY
FOR QUITE A WHILE.
ON THE DIPLOMA ISN'T TO DO THAT
THAT ONE IS THAT IS BEING LUNCH
THE P. JEANNIE UNTIL DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY I'M P. JEANNIE HAS
THE OPTION TO EXTEND IT FOR A
THIRD YEAR IF THEY WANTED TO
DECEMBER THIRTIETH. TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT'S
A VERY LONG TIME IN THE
BANKRUPTCY WORLD --
THE MEDIAN PUBLIC COMPANY TO
FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY BETWEEN AND
I'M SERVICE TWENTY ON ITS DUE
DECEMBER THIRTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND CAN BE EXTENDED
THE TWENTY TWENTY TAIL.
ON THAT THE MEDIAN PUBLIC
COMPANY TO FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY
BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NEEDED ABOUT
FIVE MONTHS TO REORGANIZE IN THE
FACT THAT THE INVESTOR COMMUNITY
IS THINKING A MULTI YEAR
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS.
POINTS TO HOW COMPLICATED THE
REASON WHY P. JEANNIE CAN
BENEFIT FROM BANKRUPTCY IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET OUT OF
UNPROFITABLE CONTRACTS AND TO
SHED UNDERPERFORMING ASSETS I'M
A DEBTOR CHAPTER ELEVEN HAS THE
POWER TO TEAR UP CONTRACTS WHEN
IT MAKES BUSINESS SENSE TO DO SO.
ON THE COUNTER PARTY THAT TO
THAT CONTRACT MIGHT OBJECT IN BE
UPSET -- BUT
OUT -- BUT
IN MOST CASES THEIR ONLY
ENTITLED TO A CLAIM FOR DAMAGES
AND THE CLAIM FOR DAMAGES MIGHT
NOT END UP WORTH VERY MUCH THERE
ARE CERTAIN COMPLICATIONS HERE
BECAUSE P. GENIE IS PARTY. TO
THESE POWER PURCHASING
AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE THIS
FEDERAL REGULATORY OVERLAY --
IN THEIR LOT OF ON QUESTION ON
ON ANSWER QUESTIONS OF LOS
SURROUNDING THAT SO P. JEANNIE
MIGHT HAVE LESS AUTONOMY TO
TERRA BAD CONTRACTS THAN MOST
COMPANIES STILL ON BUT IN
GENERAL THIS IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY COMPANIES FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY --
FINALLY MANY COMPANIES USE
CHAPTER ELEVEN TO IMPROVE THEIR
GOVERNANCE P. JEANNIE SEEMS TO
BE NO EXCEPTION WITH P. JEANNIE
INDICATING THAT HALF THE BOARD
WILL BE REPLACED.
VERY SOON AND DIFFERENT
INVESTORS NOW ADVOCATING TO PUT
THEIR OWN DIRECTORS ON THE BOARD
AND THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY I
THINK FOR P. JEANNIE TO LOOK
LIKE A DIFFERENT COMPANY IN THE
NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE --
BE BEFORE I SPEAK TO SAID
BUCKLEY ON HOW THE P. JEANNIE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS IS LIKELY TO
PLAY OUT I WANTED TO POINT OUT A
COUPLE OF BASIC THINGS ABOUT HOW
BANKRUPTCY LAW WORKS --
FIRST A CREDITOR IN BANKRUPTCY
HAS A CLAIM THAT A SUBJECT TO
WHAT WE CALL DISCHARGE THIS
MEANS THAT THE CREDITORS CLAIM
WILL BE CANCELED AT THE END OF
THE BANKRUPTCY PROCESS.
THE LAW PROVIDES THAT THE
CREDITORS WILL RECEIVE THE SHARE
OF THE DEBTOR'S ASSETS THAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO TO THE
EXTENT THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
ASSETS TO SATISFY CREDITORS --
CREDITORS CAN BE FORCED TO
ACCEPT A PARTIAL PAYMENT THAT
DOES NOT PAY THEM IN FULL --
SECOND TO HEAR FOR THE MOST PART
WILD FIRE VICTIMS AND BOND
HOLDERS ARE IN THE SAME BOAT
THEY HAVE CLAIMS TO HAVE EQUAL
PRIORITY UNDER BANKRUPTCY LAW --
THIS CREATES INCENTIVES FOR
QUALIFY ESTIMATE AT A LOWER
NUMBER THE VARIOUS CLAIMS THAT
ARE STARTED BY THE WILD FIRE
VICTIMS THAT WILL BE ONE OF THE
MAIN ELEMENTS OF THIS BANKRUPTCY
CASE TENSION BETWEEN.
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF UNSECURED
CREDITORS --
AND I EXPECT P. JEANNIE
SHAREHOLDERS MIGHT ALSO GET
INVOLVED TO TRY TO DO WHAT THEY
CAN TO REDUCE THE P. GENIES
ASSERTED WILDFIRE LIABILITY.
THIRD BANKRUPTCY LAW DRAWS A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN P. PRE
BANKRUPTCY CREDITORS AND THOSE
WHO HAVE CLAIMS THAT ARISE AFTER
A BANKRUPTCY PETITION IS FILED.
FOR EXAMPLE A WILDFIRE VICTIM
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN IS A PRE
BANKRUPTCY CREDITOR OR A PRE
PETITION CREDITOR ON THESE
CREDITORS HAVE CLAIMS THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO DISCHARGE THEY CAN BE
FORCED TO ACCEPT A PARTIAL
PAYMENT --
BANKRUPTCY ALSO PROVIDES --
FOR SOMETHING WE CALL
ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMS
ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMS ARISE
AFTER THE BANKRUPTCY CASE --
IS FILED SO P. JEANNIE FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY THE END OF JANUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN TO THE EXTENT
THERE WILD FIRE VICTIMS THIS
SUMMER ON THOSE VICTIMS WILL
THEN HAVE ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMS.
THE DISTINCTION HERE IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THOSE
CLAIMANTS WILL BE ENTITLED TO BE
REPAID IN FULL I'M FOR THE FIRM
TO THE BANKRUPTCY --
WHAT THIS MEANS --
IS THAT IF THERE ARE LARGE
WILDFIRES THIS SUMMER OR LARGE
AMOUNTS OF DAMAGE THE CLEAN
SUFFERED THIS SUMMER COULD SWAMP
WHATEVER ASSETS P. JEANNIE HAS
AND THIS SUMMER'S VICTIMS COULD
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO SATISFY.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHILE FIRE VICTIMS AS
WELL AS THE BOND HOLDERS ON
ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMANTS ARE
ALWAYS PAID A HAD A PRE
BANKRUPTCY CREDITORS.
ON AS WE CONSIDER WHAT P. ARM AS
WE CONSIDER P. GENIES BANKRUPTCY
PROCESS IT'S HELPFUL TO CONSIDER
WHERE WE CURRENTLY ARE IN THE
PROCESS TO SET THE STAGE FOR THE
PROCESS IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE IN
THE FUTURE.
ON AS OF NOW JUDGE MENTALITY HAS
GRANTED SOME PRELIMINARY
REQUESTED P. JEANNIE TO DO BASIC
THINGS LIKE PAY INSURANCE
COVERAGE AND PAY WORKERS ON
THESE ARE TYPICAL AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL HE GENE IS ALSO
POISED TO BORROW THE DIPLOMA IN --
AND THEN TO HAVE THE FUNDS OR
THE WAR CHEST FOR A LONG
BANKRUPTCY CASE ON BANKRUPTCY
LAW HAS A LOT OF PROCEDURES AND
RULES THAT ARE MEANT TO PROD
EVERYONE TO A FULLY NEGOTIATED
RESOLUTION.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
CHAPTER ELEVEN SHE POWER TO
FORCE TO DEAL AND CREDITORS IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES BUT THE
STRONG POLICY PREFERENCE A
BANKRUPTCY LAW IS FOR A FULLY
CONSENSUAL DEAL THAT EVERYBODY
OR ALMOST EVERYBODY SUPPORTS.
ON TO LUBRICATE NEGOTIATIONS
BANKRUPTCY LAW POINTS WHAT WE
CALL OFFICIAL COMMITTEES OF
CREDITORS THESE OFFICIAL
COMMITTEES OF CREDITORS
REPRESENTS SPECIFIC INTEREST IN
THE CASE --
THEY'RE ALSO ENTITLED TO HIRE
LAWYERS ON AND INVESTMENT
BANKERS AND CONSULTANTS WHO MUST
BE PAID FOR BY P. JEANNIE.
I'M HERE WE HAVE MORE OFFICIAL
COMMITTEES OF CREDITORS AND WE
USUALLY DO SPEAKING TO THE
COMPLEXITY OF HIS BANKRUPTCY
CASE THERE'S CURRENTLY AN
OFFICIAL COMMITTEE OF UNSECURED
CREDITORS --
IN DON'T BE FOOLED BY THE NAME
BECAUSE IN THIS CASE THE
OFFICIAL COMMITTEE OF UNSECURED
CREDITORS IS REALLY LIKE AN
OFFICIAL COMMITTEE OF BOND
HOLDERS AND COMPANIES THAT DO
BUSINESS WITH P. JEANNIE.
I'M AS WELL AS SOME
REPRESENTATION FROM UNIONS AND
PENSION CREDITORS ON THERE'S
ALSO NOW A SEPARATE OFFICIAL
COMMITTEE OF TORT VICTIMS --
THAT'S MADE UP OF IT OUR LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE TORT
CLAIMS I'D IMAGINE CHIEFLY
ARISING OUT OF WILD FIRE DAMAGES
AGAINST P. JEANNIE --
THEY'RE ALSO LIKELY SEVERAL AD
HOC COMMITTEES OF BOND HOLDERS
AND SHAREHOLDERS FLOATING AROUND
WE SEE SOME OF THEM SHOWING UP
IN THE PRESS IN COURTS.
ON THEY DON'T HAVE OFFICIAL
STATUS MEANING P. JEANNIE WON'T
PAY FOR THEIR LAWYERS --
BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN TO BE
ACTIVE -- IN
THE BANKRUPTCY PROCESS AND TO
AGITATE TO NEGOTIATE AND TO TRY
TO GET WHAT THEY WANT IN THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
COMMITTEES FLOATING AROUND --
AD HOC COMMITTEES SPEAKS TO THE
INVESTOR COMMITTEE COMMUNITIES
INTEREST IN THIS RESTRUCTURING
ON THERE'S EVEN A MOTION THAT IS
HIGHLY UNUSUAL I'M FILED BY A
VARIETY OF CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
ENTITIES.
IMPACTED BY THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES
SUCH AS THE CITY OF NAPA ON
MENDOCINO COUNTY AND CINEMA
COUNTY AMONG OTHERS SEEKING
COURT PERMISSION FOR THEIR OWN
OFFICIAL COMMITTEE THIS IS A
HIGHLY UNUSUAL.
MOTION -- I
CAN'T THINK OF VERY MANY PER
APPOINT AN OFFICIAL COMMITTEE
AND THEN TO FORCE P. JEANNIE TO
PAY FOR THEIR LAWYERS --
BUT THAT'S SPEAKS TO THE FACT
THAT THEY VIEW THEMSELVES AS
HAVING INTEREST THAT AREN'T
OTHERWISE REPRESENTED IN THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS WHICH IS THEY
ARE REGULATORY ENTITIES TO
PERHAPS HAVE DAMAGES CLAIMS OF
THEIR OWN --
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE AN ONGOING
INTEREST IN WITH THE POST P.
JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ALSO
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF THE UNITED STATES
TRUSTEE.
THE US TRUSTEE'S OFFICE IS
CHARGED WITH ACTING AS A
WATCHDOG ON TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE POWERS OF CHAPTER ELEVEN ARE
NOT ABUSED AND CONGRESSIONAL
PUBLIC POLICIES ARE VINDICATED.
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE IN
PRACTICE WITH THIS MEANS THAT
THEY WILL ADD ON EXAMINE THE
TYPES OF MOTIONS THAT THE DEBTOR
FILES AND THEY WILL CONSULT WITH
THE DEBTOR AND PUSH BACK IF FOR
EXAMPLE P. JEANNIE WERE TO ASK
SOMETHING THAT THEY THOUGHT WAS.
OUT OF LINE WITH PUBLIC HOUSE HE
CONCERNS --
IMPORTANTLY SOME SORT OF PROCESS
WILL BE PUT IN PLACE TO
ESTIMATES THE CLAIMS THE
WILDFIRE VICTIMS THEIR DIFFERENT
WAYS THIS CAN BE DONE IN THE
TIMING OF IT COULD VERY IT COULD
BE DONE WHILE P. GENIE IS STILL
IN BANKRUPTCY --
AND SOME OF THE COULD BE DONE
AFTER P. JEANNIE LEAVES
BANKRUPTCY ON THE BANKRUPTCY
JUDGE IS LIKELY TO BE IN CHARGE
OF IT IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE THAT
SOME SORT OF TRUST COULD BE
CREATED WITH ASSETS.
AND SOME SORT OF ADMINISTRATIVE
CLAIMS RESOLUTION PROCESS ON
INTO THE TERMS AND PROCEDURES
THAT GOVERN THE CLAIMS
ADMINISTRATION PROCESS AND
WHATEVER TRUST IS PUT IN PLACE --
WILL GO A LONG WAY IN DECIDING
WHAT KIND OF BARGAINING POWER
WILD FIRE VICTIMS AND THAT
HAVING IS THE A SIR CLAIMS AND
ARE HEARD BY WHATEVER MECHANISM
THE COURT CREATES WHICH IS MOST
LIKELY GOING TO BE.
JUDGE MENTALITY HIMSELF --
THERE'S ALSO A QUESTION OF
WHETHER FOR THE FEDERAL ON
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION CAN
BLOCK P. JEANNIE FROM TEARING UP
POWER PURCHASING AGREEMENTS.
ON THIS IS AN UNSETTLED QUESTION
OF LAW THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IS ASK THE FEDERAL DISTRICT
COURT TO DECIDE IT --
JUDGMENT TALLY JUST SIGNAL BUT
HE'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO DECIDED
HIMSELF OF POSSIBLE --
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE BIT
OF AN A JUDICIAL TUG OF WAR
THERE THERE WILL BE A DECISION
ON AND THERE IS CERTAIN TO BE AN
APPEAL BY WHICHEVER SIDE IS
LOSING -- I
THINK FOR VIEWS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BASED ON HOW
ACTIVELY THEY'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE BANKRUPTCY CASE SO FAR --
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE SOMETHING
WHICH IS THIS IS A DEEPLY
COMPLICATED BARGAINING
ENVIRONMENT --
FORTUNATELY SOME OF THE BEST
BANKRUPTCY LAWYERS IN THE
COUNTRY ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
IT UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE A LOT
OF THEM --
BUT IT WILL STILL BE VERY VERY
HARD --
FINALLY JUST A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHERE ALL OF THIS
IS GOING ON IN EXACTLY WHAT THE
PROCESS WENT UP LOOKING LIKE P.
JEANNIE HAS EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF
EXCLUSIVITY WHICH MEANS THEY
HAVE THE EXCLUSIVE RIGHT. TO
PROPOSE A PLAN OF REORGANIZATION
THIS AGENDA SETTING POWER PUTS
P. GENIES BOARDING MANAGEMENT
TEAM IN CONTROL OF THE CASE AND
YOU EXPECT THAT THEY'LL TRY TO
FINISH.
THE BANKRUPTCY PROCESS IN THAT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS WITH THAT SAID
THE COMPANY HAS YET TO PORT FOR
A PUBLIC VISION OF WHAT IT'S
GOING TO LOOK LIKE WHEN IT
LEAVES BANKRUPTCY WHICH IS
UNUSUAL AT THIS STAGE.
USUALLY COMPANIES WILL HAVE DONE
THAT IT SPEAKS TO HOW
COMPLICATED THE SAYS --
ENDS THERE ARE A VARIETY OF A
VERY COMPLICATED QUESTIONS IN
FRONT OF US AND MOST IMPORTANTLY --
HOW WILL P. JEANNIE DEAL WITH
FUTURE LIABILITY --
JUDGE MENTALITY CAN ONLY APPROVE
A PLAN TO ALLOW P. GENIE OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY IF P. JEANNIE CAN
ASSERT WHAT WE WOULD CALL.
ON A BOAT WITH A FEASIBLE PLAN
MEANING JUDGMENT HOLLY LOOKS AT
THE PLANETS AS P. GENIES
UNLIKELY TO BE BACK IN
BANKRUPTCY ANYTIME SOON MAYBE
TWENTY YEARS FROM NOW THE STORY
WILL BE DIFFERENT BUT JUDGMENT
HOLLY WILL BE CONCERNED WITH THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS --
THIS MEANS THAT SOMETIME IN THE
NEXT EIGHT WILDFIRE NOT ONLY
THIS SUMMER --
BUT GOING FORWARD HOW IS IT
GOING TO MANAGE THE FACT THAT IT
NOW HAS THESE OPERATIONS THAT
SEEM TO CREATE RISKS --
THAT RESULT IN LIABILITY --
WILL THERE BE SOME SORT OF
RELIEF THAT MAY COME FROM THE
STATE LEGISLATURE ON THAT'S A
QUESTION THAT I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE WONDERING AND WE
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO AN AND
ANOTHER QUESTION THAT WE DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO IS.
WILL THE LEGISLATURE HAVE TO
PROVIDE SOME SORT OF RELIEF FOR
PEACE YOU NEED TO HAVE A WAY OUT
OF BANKRUPTCY --
AND MY SECOND IN SEC MY SECOND
POINT IS THE BANKRUPTCY LAW
REQUIRES A REGULATED ENTITY I'M
TO HAVE THE APPROVAL OF ITS
REGULATOR FOR ANY RATE INCREASE
THAT IS PART OF A PLAN OF
REORGANIZATION.
THIS MEANS THE NOT WITHSTANDING
THE AUTOMATIC STAY IN THE POWERS
OF BANKRUPTCY LAW ON THE C. P.
U. C. WILL HAVE AN IMPORTANT
ROLE TO PLAY I'M IN SHAPING THE
PROCESS SINCE THEY WILL NEED TO
AUTHORIZE A RATE INCREASE TO THE
EXTENT THAT PAGE.
P. JEANNIE NEEDS ONE ON IN
CONCLUSION YOU SHOULD NOW THINK
OF IT P. GENIE IS BEING STOCK IN
THIS KIND OF FEDERALLY CREATED
BARGAINING ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THERE ARE LOTS OF PLAYERS ON ALL
SIDES THAT WILL BE ASSERTING
THEIR OWN INTERESTS.
THERE'S ALSO A FEDERAL
BANKRUPTCY JUDGE OVERSEEING THE
PROCESS WHO IS THE JOB OF
FINDING FACTS MAKING RULES AND
PRODDING THE SIDES TO COME TO A
NEGOTIATED RESOLUTION.
GIVEN THE P. JEANNIE PERHAPS MAY
NEED A RATE INCREASE THERE'S
DEFINITELY A ROLE FOR THE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO PLAY IN SHAPING
THE OUTCOME OF THE BANKRUPTCY.
I'M IN FACT THE STATE GOVERNMENT
MAY NEED TO PLAY A ROLE ON GIVEN
THE GIVEN THE FACT THAT P.
JEANNIE NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
PROPOSE.
A FEASIBLE PLAN OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION THE JUDGE MENTALITY
BELIEVES WON'T BE FOLLOWED BY A
SUBSEQUENT BANKRUPTCY FILING --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
I JUST WANTED --
TO MAKE CLEAR.
WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR INVOLVEMENT
IN THIS? TO WHAT EXTENT HERE ARE
THE VARIOUS ELEMENTS OF THIS
CASES ARE UNFOLDING [inaudible]
OF ACCESSIBLE TO YOU IN TERMS OF
YOUR ABILITY TO GET THAT
INFORMATION AND ANALYZE IT I'M
SURE GREAT QUESTION --
SO MY INVOLVEMENT TO THE IN THIS
CASE HAS BEEN FOLLOWING THE
COURT DOCKETS BECAUSE ALL OF
THESE FILINGS ARE PUBLIC --
I'VE ALSO HAD VARIOUS
CONVERSATIONS ALONG THE WAY WITH
REPORTERS AND ON MEMBERS OF THE
STATE SENATE OR STE STAFF
MEMBERS OF THE STATE SENATE --
I'M NOT PRIVY TO ANY
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION ABOUT
WHERE NEGOTIATIONS ARE AND I
DON'T HAVE ANY KNOWLEDGE OF ANY
KIND OF LEGISLATION AND THAT IS
IN THE WORKS THAT MIGHT PROVIDE
FOR SOME SORT OF REGULATORY
ANYTHING.
COMING OUT OF THIS BANKRUPTCY
CASE SO I AM VERY MUCH AN
OBSERVER --
AND TO THIS FITS VERY MUCH WITH
THE PRACTICE EXPERIENCE THAT I
HAD PRIOR TO BECOMING AN
ACADEMIC OF WORKING ON LARGE
BANKRUPTCY CASES SO THAT'S THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT I BRING TO BEAR
THANK YOU JUST FOR THE RECORD.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US OR MOST
CERTAINLY NOT MYSELF --
OR ARE WE ARE ALSO PRETTY TO CON
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
REGARDING THIS CASE.
I ALSO WANT TO ASK --
IN YOUR ANALYSIS HAVE YOU FOUND
ANY EVIDENCE ASSISTING SUGGEST
THE USE OF P. GINNY IS TRYING TO
GET OUT OF POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS --
THEY HAVE YET TO SIGNAL THAT
THEY WILL --
HOWEVER THEY WOULD IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN MALPRACTICE HAD THEY NOT
SIGNAL THAT THE BEGINNING THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO RESERVE THE
OPTION TO DO SO. ONE OF THE
THINGS THE DEBTORS AND CHAPTER
LET -- TORY
RIGHT TO TERROR CONTRACTS THEY
TRY TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN
THREATEN TO USE THAT RIGHT IN
THE HOPES OF RENEGOTIATING
THINGS.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T --
THREATENED IF THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY.
THE CONTRACTS THAT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THEY HAVE NOT.
THREATEN TO YOU SO BUT THEY ARE --
IN THE PROCESS AND USING
LITIGATION TO ASSERT A PATHWAY
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO DO SO
MOST YOU KNOW PERHAPS AND
SPECULATING --
TO THEN PROVOKE RE NEGOTIATIONS.
AND JUST EXPLAIN WHAT THAT MIGHT
MEAN I I GUESS MONTH MOST OF THE
MEMBERS OF PROBABLY KNOW BUT IN
PREVIOUS YEARS WHEN RATES WERE
HIGHER --
UTILITIES ENTERED INTO CONTRACTS
LONG TERM CONTRACTS --
AND ON OUR ARE TIED.
TO A PROVIDING SUPPLY AT A
LARGER RATE SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
THINKING THAT --
BY THEM --
DISCLOSING THAT THEY MAKE UP ONE
OF GET OUT OF THOSE POWER
PURCHASE AGREEMENTS A COURT
COULD ACTUALLY GRANT.
THEM GETTING OUT OF THAT IF THEY
CAN SHOW THAT THEY CAN ENTER
INTO ANOTHER GREEN TODAY WITH
ANOTHER PROVIDER.
OR EVEN WITH THE SAME PROVIDER
AT A LOWER RATE WHICH WOULD COST
RESULT IN SAVINGS TO THE UTILITY
IN PROVIDING THE ENERGY FOR
EXAMPLE SO I WANT TO CAST.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION --
I WANT TO QUALIFY MAY ANSWER TO
THIS BY SAYING THAT THE LAW IS
ON CERTAIN SO BURKE HAS ASSERTED
THAT THEY CAN'T DO IT --
IN P. GENIE IS URRENTLY SOFT --
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR DECLARATORY JUDGMENT
FROM JUDGE MENTALITY THAT NO
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO DO IT SO
THERE IS THIS LIKE SIDE SHOW --
YOU KNOW THAT ISN'T REALLY
CENTRAL TO P. GENIES BANKRUPTCY
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S GOING
ON WE'RE P. GENIE IS IN
LITIGATION WITH BURKE --
AND WHATEVER HAPPENS IN THAT LED --
TO FOR IS ALSO ASSERTED THAT
SOME OF THOSE AGREEMENTS --
HAVE THE FORCE OF LAW EVEN IF
YOU TORE UP THE CONTRACT THEIR
VARIOUS REGULATIONS THAT WOULD
NOT ALLOW PIECE YOU NEED TO GET
OUT OF ITS BECAUSE THEY'RE PART
OF BROADER.
FROM REGULATORY SCHEMES THAT
EXIST AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL --
BUT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT P.
JEANNIE CAN THE LAW IS UNCERTAIN
AND IT WOULD BE REASONABLE TO
EXPECT T. G. NEED. TO TEST THE
BOUNDARIES OF THAT LAW WHILE
THEY'RE IN BANKRUPTCY BECAUSE IT
COULD HAVE.
A BIG IMPACT IN TERMS OF VALUE
TO A TO THE POTENTIALLY.
FINANCIALLY IT'S UNCLEAR AYE AYE
IT'S UNCLEAR SOME PEOPLE SAY
QUITE ENDS BUT IT QUITE OKAY.
AND AND YOU MENTIONED THAT
THERE'S AN IN THAT THIS
BANKRUPTCY.
CAN EXTEND EIGHTEEN MONTHS OR IS
THAT IS THAT A TERM OF EIGHTEEN
MINDS -- IN
STATUTE IS THAT AN ESTIMATE --
CAN CAN THIS BE RESOLVED PRIOR
TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS OR YOU
EXPECTED THIS WOULD TAKE THE
FULL EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO RESOLVE
THIS BANKRUPTCY.
SO IT'S A STATUS SO THERE'S A
STATUTORY PERIOD WE'RE PEKINGESE
MANAGEMENT TEAM HAS THE
EXCLUSIVE RIGHT TO PROPOSE A
PLAN OF ORGANIZATION AND THAT'S
THAT EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD --
AND IN GENERAL IT WOULD BE
MALPRACTICE ON THE PART OF P.
GENIES LAWYERS IF THEY DIDN'T
TRY THEIR HARDEST TO GET OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY BEFORE THAT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS IS NOT THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF FLEXIBILITY TOWARDS THE
END.
BUT IN GENERAL YOU CAN THINK OF
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TWO YEARS HAS
ABOUT THE PERIOD WE'RE P. GENIES
MANAGEMENT TEAM WILL CONTROL THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS ONCE THAT
PERIOD LAPSES IT'S NOT THE CASE
THE PEKINGESE AND THROWN OUT A
BANKRUPTCY.
INSTEAD --
OTHER PARTY.
GIVEN THE SIZE OF THE BANKRUPTCY
AND THE SOPHISTICATION OF P.
GENIES CREDITORS AND INVESTORS
THAT WOULD CERTAIN.
THAT WOULD BE A PROCESS THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY BECOME A CIRCUS --
WHERE THEY WOULD BE YOU KNOW
MEET TEN FIFTEEN DIFFERENT PLANS
ON THE TABLE --
JUDGMENT HOW HE WOULD FIND THAT
PROCESS VERY CHALLENGING TO
MANAGE AND EVERYONE WILL WORK
VERY HARD TO AVOID THAT
HAPPENING WE CALL THAT IN
BANKRUPTCY SPEAK A COMPETING
PLAN PROCESS.
TEACHING YOU WILL NEED A PLAN OF
ORGANIZATION TO GET OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY --
AND YOU HOPE THAT IT HAPPENS
WITHIN THAT YOU KNOW TWO YEAR OR
SO WINDOW.
MONTHS --
WORK I MEAN OF WORKS
CONCURRENTLY WITH OUR CALENDAR
WE'RE GOING TO BE --
HERE CREATING NEW LAWS OR WORK
WORKING ON DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
MAY AFFECT P. GINNY EITHER
FAVORABLY OR NEGATIVELY --
THROUGH AT LEAST OCTOBER TO
SEPTEMBER --
AND THE GOVERNOR WILL HAVE.
THE PROCESS OF SIGNING IN
BETWEEN BILLS.
COULD OUR ACTION HERE.
ALL CHURCH CHANGE INFLUENCE
WHATEVER'S HAPPENING IN THROUGH
THE JUDICIAL BANKRUPTCY PROCESS
SO.
IF IF WE INTRODUCE A BILL OR
PROPOSE --
SOME KIND OF LEGISLATION WOULD
THAT ALTER THE DYNAMICS OF THE
DISCUSSION IN THE BAT BANKRUPTCY.
I'M ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW SIR PC.
WE NEED BECAUSE OF ITS UNIQUE
STATUS AS A HYBRID PUBLIC
PRIVATE ENTITY --
THE RED IN THE RELATIONSHIP IT
HAS WITH ITS REGULATORS AND LAWS
THAT A PROPOSED HERE --
COULD VERY MUCH IN --
IMPACT ITS TRAJECTORY GOING I
WOULD IMAGINE NOT ONLY THAT YOU
KNOW YOU COULD INFLUENCE THE
BANKRUPTCY CASE BUT ALSO --
IN HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
INVESTORS THERE'S AN EXPECTATION
I THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE WILL LEAD IN
PROVIDING A PATH FOR P. GENIE
OUT OF BANKRUPTCY THIS AT LEAST
WILL MANY PEOPLE SEEM TO THINK.
SO GIVEN YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
OF OF BANKRUPTCIES I MEAN
USUALLY --
BANKRUPTCIES ARE ARE DEALT WITH.
IN IN A IN A CLOSE PROCESS.
WITHIN THE JUDICIAL PROCESS BUT
GIVEN THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN.
CAN INFLUENCE THAT THERE WAS A
ACTION.
DO YOU KNOW OF A PROCESS OF
COMMUNICATING BETWEEN THE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT IN TERMS
OF HOW THAT CAN NEGATIVE IT OR
ADVERSELY AFFECT THAT I MEAN.
BECAUSE THEY'LL BE DIFFERENT
PARTIES PROBABLY SEEKING IN.
SOME ADVANTAGE ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER COME INTO US SAYING CAN
YOU DO THIS CAN YOU DO THAT AND
THE FACT THIS FOR OUR BENEFIT.
AND WE REALLY DON'T HAVE A WAY.
TO TWO YOU KNOW --
DISCUSS THAT THAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF OF OUR ACTIONS
TO THAT NEGOTIATION PROCESS OF
YOU MENTION EVERYTHING YOU'VE
DESCRIBED.
IN TERMS OF HOW HOW [inaudible]
DYNAMIC AND COMPLICATED AND AND
YOU KNOW WITH ALL THESE SO MANY
PARTIES TO THIS.
CLAIM IN PARTICULAR --
BEYOND BONDHOLDERS STOCKHOLDERS --
VICTIMS YOU KNOW THE WHOLE LONG
LIST.
YOU ALSO HAVE LEGISLATIVE
ELEMENT HERE THAT CAN.
MAKE THINGS BETTER OR WORSE --
IS THERE.
A CONNECTION --
IS THE LEGISLATIVE AND PROP --
ALIMENT I THINK INTRODUCES MUCH
MORE UNCERTAINTY IN COMPLEXITY
THAT IS IN THE CASE OF ANY OTHER
LARGE CORPORATE BANKRUPTCY THAT
I'M AWARE OF I THINK THAT THE
CHAIRMAN'S --
INSTINCT IS CORRECT AND YOU ARE
GOING TO START HEARING AND YOU
MAY ALREADY BE HEARING FROM MANY
PARTIES TO P. WHO HAVE AN
INTEREST IN P. JEANNIE --
WHEN I WAS A LAWYER IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE I REPRESENTED CREDITORS
IN THE BANKRUPTCY CASE WHERE WE
TOOK CONCERNS THAT WE HAD TO
FEDERAL REGULATORS ABOUT ASPECTS
OF THAT BANKRUPTCY CASE --
YOU CAN IMAGINE YOU WILL HEAR
FROM LOTS OF PEOPLE THEY WILL
HAVE THEIR OWN PAROCHIAL
INTERESTS THEN SOMETIMES THEY
MAY HAVE THE PUBLIC INTEREST AT
HEART.
BUT YES YOU WILL HEAR FROM ALL
OF THEM THERE IS NO THIS CREATED
BY BANKRUPTCY LAW TO KIND OF
MEDIATE.
THE INTERACTIONS THAT WALKER
BETWEEN I SUPPOSE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
STATE ASSEMBLY IN THE STATE
SENATE AND YOU KNOW CREDITORS
BUT I YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT YOU
KNOW PART OF IT WOULD BE
MALPRACTICE ON THE PART OF
LAWYERS FOR CREDITORS IF THEY
DID NOT CONSIDER.
THE LARGE ROLE THAT REGULATORY
RELIEF MIGHT PLAY IN THIS CASE
AND WHETHER THEY WANT TO TRY TO
SHAPE THAT.
AND GIVEN THAT WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT PARTY OR PRIVY TO THE
INTERNAL --
NEGOTIATIONS HAPPENING WITHIN
THIS BANKRUPTCY HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE.
OUR INVOLVEMENT IN TRYING
[inaudible]
TO IMPROVE.
THE THE THE SITUATION OF THE
BANKRUPTCY HOW DO WE GET
INFORMATION HOW DO WE PROPOSE A
SOLUTION IF WE DON'T KNOW.
NECESSARILY WHAT'S HAPPENING
INTERNALLY.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF NOISE
ARE.
GOING TO HEAR A LOT OF NOISE --
AND BUT I MIGHT HEAR FROM THE
LOUDEST VOICE IS NOT NECESSARILY
THE THE ONES THAT ARE.
REALLY --
THOUGH WOULD THAT NECESSARILY
THE ONES THAT NEED TO BE HEARD I
THINK THAT'S CORRECT --
SO YOU KNOW YOU YOU WOULD HAVE A
NUMBER OF OPTIONS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CONSIDER CREATING SOME
SORT OF CONSOLIDATED PROCESS --
ONE IS YOU COULD HIRE A
BANKRUPTCY LAWYER WHO WILL THEN
BE KNOWN AS A PERSON FOR WHO
PEOPLE CAN TALK TO AND THAT
PERSON CAN ACT AS AN
INTERMEDIARY --
FOR THE COMMITTEE AS A WHOLE --
I YOU COULD TRY TO SET UP SOME
STORM A FORMAL PROCESS PERHAPS.
I DON'T KNOW WITH IT MAKING IT
EASY TO COMMENT ON THE INTERNET
THAT I'M NOT SURE --
WHETHER THAT'S SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IS ALREADY IN PLACE BUT EAT
YEAH I THINK I THINK THE CHAIR
IS CORRECT IN SUGGESTING THAT
YOU'LL WANT TO THINK ABOUT HOW
DO WE MAKE SURETHAT YOU'RE NOT
JUST HEARING FROM THE WEALTHIEST
AND THE LARGEST VOICES.
BUT ALSO YOU'RE HEARING FROM
EVERYONE CONCERNED WITH P.
JEANNIE AND WHAT TO DO ABOUT THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS INFORMATION
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU COULD BE
HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH FOR
EXAMPLE --
CINEMA COUNTY AND YOU KNOW
UNDERSTANDING THEIR CONCERNS ALL
THE SAME TIME THERE NEGOTIATIONS
GOING ON ELSEWHERE --
A SITUATION THAT I THINK YOU
SHOULD BE COGNIZANT OF IS THAT --
YOU KNOW THE PARTIES COULD BUILD
A BANKRUPTCY DE ALL AROUND SOME
EXPECTED CONTRIBUTION OR
LEGISLATION THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO GIVE TEM --
WHICH COULD PUT YOU ON IN A
POSITION WHERE YOU MAY HAVE TO
DECIDE DO WE WANT TO GIVE THIS
TO EVERYONE WHEN YOU KNOW
PERHAPS THE BANKRUPTCY JUDGES IN
FAVOR OF IT AND ALL THE PARTIES
TO THE CASE THAT ARE BIG PARTIES
ARE IN FAVOR OF AN A MINIMUM.
MENTON FOR THAT COULD BUILD.
AND WE MAY BE FAR FROM THAT.
YES SENATOR HILL THANK YOU CHAIR
THANKS FOR THE GOOD QUESTION
LIKE FOR ME I APPRECIATE THAT --
PROFESSOR WELCOME AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR INPUT AND AND I
HAVE TWO QUICK QUESTIONS IF I
COULD.
THE REORGANIZATION PLAN I'M KIND
OF OF WHENEVER IT COMES FORWARD --
IF IT'S PRESENTED THAT'S A BY
PETE P. JEANNIE UP AND THEN
THERE'S THE ISSUE OF WITH
IMPAIRED CLASS IF IT AGREES TO
SUPPORT THAT REORGANIZATION.
THE GENERALLY THAT --
THAT APPROVED THE PLAN AND THAT
SEEMS LIKE A VERY LOW THRESHOLD
IN THAT COULD YOU EXPLAIN HOW
THAT WORKS WE'VE.
SURE HAS SO ON THE WAY THE
BANKRUPTCY LAW WORKS IS AGAIN
THE IDEAL IS A PLAN THAT
EVERYBODY SUPPORTS BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT EVERYBODY DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE PLAN BANKRUPTCY LAW
PROVIDES A ROUTE. FOR A COMPANY
TO GET A PLAN APPROVED WITH OUT
EVERYONE'S BY AND AND THAT'S
PLAN GENERALLY HAS A COP A BUNCH
OF REQUIREMENTS --
ONE THAT SENATOR HELL JUST
MENTIONED IS THE REQUIREMENT OF
AN IMPAIRED ACCEPTING CLASS
MEANING THAT SOME GROUP OF
CREDITORS WHO WILL.
NOT BE MADE WHOLE UNDER THE PLAN --
DECIDE THAT THEY WILLSUPPORT IT
AND BANKRUPTCY LAW VIEWS THIS AS
A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY HAVE TO TAKE
A LOSS IN THERE SAYING WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS LOSS --
AND THEN THERE'S SOME LEVEL OF
MINIMUM TREATMENTS THAT IS
REQUIRED BY LAW FOR EVERYONE
ELSE ON THE TO THE EXTENT OF
THAT DYNAMIC IS THERE THEN THE
PLAN WILL BE APPROVED.
ON HERE I'M IN ORDER FOR THERE
TO BE IMPAIRED ACCEPTING CLASS
THAT'S MOST LIKELY GOING TO BE
THE CLASS OF GENERAL UNSECURED
CREDITORS INCLUDING THE BOND
HOLDERS AND THE WILDFIRE VICTIMS --
THEY COULD BE IN THE SAME CLASS
THE DEPENDING ON WHAT THE SIZE
THE WILDFIRE CLAIMS IS BECAUSE
THAT IF THE WILDFIRE CLAIMS ARE
LARGE ENOUGH THEY COULD HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO BLOCK A YES VOTE FROM THE
CLASS OR PERHAPS TO YOU KNOW
CONTROL THE VOTE OF THE CLASS
ALTOGETHER --
SO THERE ARE SOME SAFEGUARDS
BUILT INTO AND IT THE IT'S NOT
AS EASY AS IT SOUNDS.
I MEAN I THINK THE ROUTES FOR
THE DEBTOR TO GET FROM HERE TO
THERE WILL BE CHALLENGING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CLARIFICATION FINAL QUESTION IS
THE ISSUE OF BANKRUPTCY WHEN --
YOU HAVE --
NUMBER OF ASSETS YOUR NUMBER
LIABILITIES OBVIOUSLY THE
LIABILITY TO SEE THE ASSETS SO
THAT EVERYBODY GETS A LITTLE
HAIR CUT IN THE PROCESS IS
YOU'VE EXPLAINED.
BUT LET'S SAY THE AT THE END OF
THE REORGANIZATION BOND HOLDERS
FIFTY CENTS ON THE DOLLAR
VICTIMS GET FIFTY CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR IS THERE A A POSSIBILITY
IN THAT BANKRUPTCY. TO THEN MAKE
THOSE.
VICTIMS AS A FIRE VICTIMS IN
THIS CASE FULL.
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME AFTER AS
PART OF THE REORGANIZATION --
AFTER THE BANKRUPTCY AND AFTER
THEY COME OUT OF BANKRUPTCY TO
THERE COULD BE A PLAN AIMED
STRUCTURE GOING FORWARD.
THERE COULD BE SO --
THAT WOULD BE A POLICY CHOICE
THE P. JEANNIE WANTS TO MAKE SO
PEACHY WANTED TO IT IS POSSIBLE
TO HAVE A A PLAN WHERE YOU YOU
GIVE PEOPLE PERHAPS P. JEANNIE
AGREES DOWN THE LINE SO WHICH
WOULD GIVE THEM IS.
CASH UP FRONT PLUS A PROMISE TO
PAY THEM MORE OVER THE FUTURE ON
IN THAT COULD BE A PROMISE TO
MAKE THEM WHOLE INCLUDING WITH
INTEREST IF THEY WANT TO TELL.
THAT'S A CHOICE THE P. JEANNIE
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE ON IN
PRACTICE --
CHOICES LIKE THAT ARE RELATIVELY
UNCOMMON CORPORATE BANKRUPTCY
BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE A
PROBLEM WILL BE CALLED THAT
OVERHANG WE'RE P. JEANNIE WOULD
BE SO BUSY IN --
TWENTY TWENTY OUT WE KNOW
THEY'RE OUT OF BANKRUPTCY LET'S
SAY PAYING FOR THE PAST WILD
FIRE VICTIMS THAT MAYBE THEY
DON'T HAVE ROOM THAN TO PAY NEW
WILDFIRE VICTIMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY BECAUSE NEW DAMAGES OR
MAYBE THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
CAPACITY TO INVEST IN SAFETY.
SO -- IT'S
POSSIBLE THEY COULD CHOOSE TO DO
THAT BUT I THINK IN ORDER FOR
JUDGE MENTALITY TO APPROVE THAT
IS A FEASIBLE PLAN THERE WOULD
ALSO HAVE TO BE A PATHWAY FOR
PEACE YOU NEED TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS AND SAFETY --
THAT WE NEED TO AND TO BE ABLE
TO HANDLE FUTURE WILDFIRE
PROBLEMS AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
WILL GO TO CENTER MORE LIKE FULL
OF BY SENATOR STONE AND STERN
THAN REPEAL [inaudible]
THEN HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
PRESSURED ALLIANCE THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE --
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
FEDERAL JUDGE MOUNT HOLLY THIS
IS HIS SECOND.
I AM WITH P. GENIES --
COULD YOU MAYBE GIVE US SOME
COLOR ABOUT THIS JUDGE.
IZZY IS A PREDICTABLE DOES HE
HAVE A STYLE --
I THINK SO JUDGE MONTH HOLLY IS
SOMEBODY WITH WHOM I AM
PERSONALLY ACQUAINTED GIVEN THAT
I YOU KNOW TEACH AT A LAW SCHOOL
THAT IS A BLOCK FROM HIS
COURTHOUSE WE'VE HAD LUNCH
BEFORE --
BUT I DON'T KNOW HIM SUPER WELL
ON I CAN TELL YOU THAT HE IS
HIGHLY REGARDED WITHIN THE
BANKRUPTCY COMMUNITY HE MAY BE
ONE OF THE BEST KNOWN IF NOT THE
BEST KNOWN.
BANKRUPTCY JUDGE YOU KNOW WEST
OF THE MISSISSIPPI UP THAT WOULD
GO TOO FAR THERE'S TEXAS --
A BUT HE MAY BE ONE OF THE BEST
JUDGES IN THE LAST --
HE'S KNOWN AS BEING SOMEBODY WHO
CEREBRAL AND QUITE INTELLIGENT
AND THOUGHTFUL --
IT HE DOES HAVE THIS EXPERIENCE
WITH THE FIRST P. JEANNIE
BANKRUPTCY --
IS SO I I THINK HE HAS A
REPUTATION FOR BEING A CAPABLE
JURIST AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE'SANYONE OUT THERE WHO
DOUBTS THAT HE IS ABLE TO HANDLE
THE MULTITUDE OF COMPLEX ISSUES
THAT LINE FRONT OF HIM.
SO HE'S FAMILIAR WITH THE
BUSINESS MODEL.
AND IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE RIGHT FOR
YOU SELL A PRODUCT THAT.
YOU COULD PAY FOR IT.
AND WHAT IS OUR COST OF GOODS
SOLD WHAT IS ARE.
ARE YOU KNOW BECAUSE FOR
OVERHEAD AND INTERESTING SO SO
WHAT WHAT WITH HIS EXPERIENCE
WILL HE BRING TO SEE OKAY WHAT.
WHAT PART OF THIS [inaudible]
MUNICIPALITY [inaudible]
UTILITY.
IN THE T. WHAT WHAT DOES IT HAVE
TO STOP.
SELLING OR WHAT IS IT HAVE TO
IMPROVE ON HE'LL HE'LL HAVE ALL
THAT.
READY TO GO RIGHT.
WELL I THINK YOU SO TWENTY YEARS
IS QUITE A WHILE IN PT NEEDS
BUSINESS HAS I THINK OF ALL IN
THAT PERIOD SO.
HE WILL HAVE TO YOU KNOW GET UP
TO SPEED I'M SURE THAT HE IS
DOING THAT RIGHT NOW --
ALONG WITH HIS LAW CLERKS AND
PROBABLY HAS ALREADY GOTTEN
THERE AND THE PARTIES TO THE
CASE WILL HELP HIM IF YOU LOOK
AT THE BANKRUPTCY DOCKET WHAT
YOU SEE IS A LOT OF EFFORTS.
ON THE PART OF THE COMPANY AND
BY CREDITORS TO TRY TO EXPLAIN
TO THE JUDGE EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON SO HE HAS THAT PRIOR
KNOWLEDGE TO BRING TO BEAR --
AND THEN RIGHT NOW I'M SURE HE
IS DELVING BACK INTO THE DETAILS --
SO HE'S READY TO ROLL BUT I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYBODY OUT
THERE WHO'S CONCERNS THAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE C<c.cyan> MONTHS TO</c>
RAMP UP AND UNDERSTANDING THIS
IS THE BUSINESS THESE ARE THE
ISSUES.
HERE'S WHAT'S GOING TO MATTER
BECAUSE HE DOES HAVE EXPERIENCE
HAVING PRESIDED AT THE UTILITY --
THE BANKRUPTCY OF A YOU KNOW
PUBLIC PRIVATE UTILITY.
THE MAYBE WHAT'S NEW IN THE
TWENTY YEARS IS RENEWABLES.
AND THOSE CONTRACTS AND SO YOU
YOU.
MENTION THAT HE COULD.
CANCEL ALL THOSE CONTRACTS IS
THAT CORRECT I'M HE MAY HAVE THE
POWER TO DO SO AGAIN IT'S
UNCLEAR AS A MATTER OF LAW
WHETHER HE CAN --
MY GAS IS THAT HIS POSITION I'M
I'M SPECULATING HERE BUT IN
GENERAL WHEN BANKRUPTCY JUDGES
RUN INTO FEDERAL REGULATORS TO
TELL THEM TEY DON'T HAVE THE
POWER TO DO THINGS.
ON THE TREND IS FOR BANKRUPTCY
JUDGES TO ALWAYS SAY NO WE DO
HAVE THE POWER TO DO THINGS
QUESTION I THINK ALL OF US CAN
UNDERSTAND TO SOME EXTENT --
SO I WOULD EXPECT HIM TO TAKE
THAT POSITION AND I WOULD EXPECT
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW THE JUST
RECORDED THE NINTH CIRCUIT TO
HAVE TO RESOLVE THAT QUESTION --
BUT I WOULD EXPECT THAT TO BE
APPEALED AND YES THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THIS CHANGE --
ALSO I THINK THERE'S BEEN GROWTH
AMONG COMMUNITY POWER
AGGREGATORS AND OTHER.
THINGS THAT ARE DIFFERENCE NOW
SO IT'S NOT QUITE THE SAME
BUSINESS THE WORLD HAS CHANGED
AND OBVIOUSLY NOT THE SAME
PREDICATE FACT PATTERN THAT
DROVE THE COMPANY INTO
BANKRUPTCY.
THANK YOU PROFESSOR THANK YOU
MATURE THANK YOU SIR.
THUNDERSTORMS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
SOME IS A IT'S AN HONOR TO SERVE
WITH YOU SIR ON THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FIRST TIME AND WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU SO.
HI AND THANK YOU ONE A ONE A LOT
TO ABSORB --
BUT A FEW QUESTIONS IF I MAY UM.
MY MY MAIN CONCERN IS FOR THE
RATE PAYERS [inaudible]
AND I WANT TO KNOW --
A FEW THINGS ABOUT.
HOW WE CAN ASSURE OUR?
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
WHICH OF THE CURRENT P. JEANNIE
TERRITORY THAT THE ELECTRICITY
IS GONNA CONTINUE BASICALLY SAID
IN CHAPTER.
ELEVEN MOST OF THE CONSUMERS ARE
NOT GOING TO NOTICE --
DIFFERENCE.
BUT AND I ALL I KNOW THAT
THERE'S ALSO A A NEXUS TO THE PC.
SO AS THIS PROCESS GOES FORWARD --
THE PC IS GOING TO BE THE ONES
THAT ARE GOING TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OUT THERE CAN BE ANY
RATE INCREASES SO.
IS THERE AND I JUST WANNA BE G.
P. YOU SEE IS COMING UP NEXT YES
AND ANY QUESTIONS OF PC YOU CAN
ASK THE OTHER YOU YOU'LL GET
THEIR ANSWER.
SO MY QUESTION IS.
CAN.
WE LEGALLY AND AND MY SAY WE MAY
GET THE PC CAN A CAN THEY RAISE
RATES. TO EFFECTUATE --
REVENUE STREAMS TO EFFECTUATE --
A SETTLEMENT.
SO THAT THEY WILL BE IN IT THEY
ALSO WILL AND BILL AND GIVE YOU
A BETTER ANSWER TO THIS THAN I
WELL BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS YES
THAT THEY CAN AND THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT OFTEN HAPPENS IN
UTILITY BANKRUPTCIES THERE ARE.
RATE INCREASES THAT THAT
AFFECTION WITH A SETTLEMENT AT
THE ENDS BECAUSE TO SOME EXTENT
IF YOU THINK OF THE BARGAINING
TABLE AS BEING YOU KNOW THESE
FOUR CHAIRS --
RATEPAYERS AREN'T AT THE TABLE --
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU CAN
LIKE COME UP WITH A PLAN THAT
INVOLVES SOMEBODY ELSE KICKING
IN MONEY TO MAKE EVERYBODY HAPPY
HERE.
I MEAN AS A BANKRUPTCY LAWYER AT
AND I LIKE THAT IDEA TELL THEM.
WHAT?
ABOUT YES.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN IT'D BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF CLAIMS AND I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT.
PROBABLY SOME OF THE LARGEST
PLAINTIFFS --
SUING OUR INSURANCE COMPANIES
THAT --
ATTEMPT TO SUBJUGATE DIDN'T
RECOVER COSTS FOR A NUMBER OF
STRUCTURES THAT HAVE BEEN --
LOST CAM CAN THIS JUDGE YOU'D
LOOK UNILATERALLY CAN HE
DISMISSED CLAIMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT HE CAN PROTECT THE
VIABILITY OF THIS COMPANY --
AT THE EXPENSE OF THESE THESE
INSURANCE COMPANIES NOT FREE HE
MADE WHOLE.
SO ON WOULDN'T JUDGMENT TALLY
WOULDN'T HAVE THE POWER TO
DISMISS A CLAIM IF HE FELT THAT
THE COMPANY NEEDED THIS CLAIM
THIS MESS --
IN PART BECAUSE BANKRUPTCY LAW
DOESN'T REQUIRE THIS SO THE
PEOPLE WITH PRE BANKRUPTCY
CLAIMS THEY'RE JUST FIGHTING
OVER THE POOL OF ASSETS THAT'S
THERE TO THE EXTENT THAT NO
THEIR CLAIMS EXCEED THE POOL OF
ASSETS MEANING THEY WON'T BE
PAID IN FULL.
IT'S REALLY A RELEVANCE TO
WEATHER P. GENIES CAPABLE
REORGANIZING AND SO ON JUDGE
MENTALITY DOES HAVE THE OPTION
OF USING DIFFERENT ESTIMATION
METHODS DETERMINE WHETHER CLAIMS
ARE VIABLE IF HE WANTS TO
ENACTED COLOR.
THE OUTCOMES FOR DIFFERENT
PLAYERS MOVE BECAUSE THIS
COMPANY CAN LEAVE BANKRUPTCY
EVEN IF.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE MADE WHOLE.
SO IT IS IT'S BEEN ALLEGED THAT --
THIS PARTICULAR COMPANY WAS
NEGLIGENT AND AND PROTECTING
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE --
CAUSING SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS.
DOES THE BANKRUPTCY JUDGE --
HAVE AN ABILITY TO TO MANDATE --
THAT THIS COMPANY IF THEY'RE
ABLE TO EMERGE FROM CHAPTER --
ELEVEN MITIGATE ANY FUTURE
DAMAGE BY FOLLOWING STATE LAW
AND MITIGATING CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE IN A
NEW AN ABNORMAL.
THE FIRES ARE EXPECTED TO BE
MORE PREVALENT.
AND THAT THEY NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF PROTECTING
THEMSELVES BECAUSE WE'RE COMING
INTO A VERY RAINY YEAR THIS YEAR
WHICH MEANS WE CAN HAVE A LOT OF
FIRE --
FUELS.
AND WE COULD BE BACK HERE AGAIN
NEXT YEAR GOD FOR BID --
WITH WITH MORE FIRES IF BY THE
UTILITY.
TO MEDICAID FURTHER DAMAGE.
YES SO --
JUDGMENT HOLLY DOES HAVE THAT
POWER IN DIRECTLY NO ONE WAY TO
THINK ABOUT WITH THE BANKRUPTCY
JUDGE RIGHT NOW IS IS THAT HE'S
KIND OF LIKE YOU KNOW THE GOD OF
P. JEANNIE HE HAS ALL POWER OVER
THEM IS LIKE A ONE PERSON
REGULATOR.
WHO CAN DO A LOT OF WHAT HE
WANTS BECAUSE THEY'RE DIFFERENT
PROVISIONS OF THE BANKRUPTCY
CODE THAT WOULD ALLOW HIM TO
MAKE WHATEVER ORDER HE WANTED TO
GO?
SO TO THE EXTENT YOU KNOW WITHIN
REASON OBVIOUSLY SO TO THE
EXTENT OF THAT --
YOU KNOW HE WERE TO DECIDE THE
P. GENIE IS BOB P. JEANNIE WILL
HAVE TO PROMISE TO OBEY STATE
LAWS TO GET A PLAN OF
ORGANIZATION APPROVED OKAY --
INTO THE SENSE THAT YOU KNOW IF
YOU WERE TO SAY WHAT HE NEEDS
NOT FEASIBLE UNLESS THEY MAKE
MONSTER INVESTMENTS AND SAFETY.
YOU KNOW THAT'S A CHOICE YOU CAN
MAKE IN THAT CHOICE PROBABLY
REDIRECTS VALUE FROM PRE
BANKRUPTCY CREDITORS TO P.
JEANNIE SAFETY INVESTMENTS OKAY
MY FINAL QUESTION IS.
EXPLAIN A SCENARIO.
WHERE P. JEANNIE WOULD HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO GO TO CHAPTER
ELEVEN WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN?
FOR THE DELIVERANCE OF
ELECTRICITY AND THE FUTURE OF
PROVIDING UTILITIES ELECTRICAL
UTILITY SERVICES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I MEAN IF THEY WERE TO HAVE TO
GO TO CHAPTER ELEVEN AGAIN NOT
THEY WERE TO GO TO CHAPTERS --
SINCE AFTER SEVEN YEAH WHAT AS
SEVEN TOP TIMING BUT HOW WOULD
PROCEED TO CHAPTER SEVEN COULD
PROCEED TO CHAPTER SEVEN IF A
COULD HOW WITH THAT.
WHAT WOULD IT LOOK LIKE SO --
AS A MATTER OF LAW IT IS
POSSIBLE EITHER A A MOTION COULD
BE FOUND FOR THE JUDGE COULD
ORDER THE CONVERSION OF THE CASE
TO CHAPTER.
SEVEN IN PRACTICE I THINK THAT'S
ALMOST A 100% UNLIKELY IF THAT
WERE TO HAPPEN WHAT YOU WOULD
HAVE WOULD BE SALES OF P. GENIES
ASSETS I WOULD ASSUME THERE LIKE
TRICITY ASSETS.
AND I ASSUME THE BUYERS WOULD BE
OTHER PUBLIC UTILITIES ON IN
PRACTICE I I WOULD HAVE TO
IMAGINE FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE CAN SPEECH ANY CONSUMER AND
I'M A P. JEANNIE CONSUMER.
WE WOULDN'T NOTICE ANY OF THIS
TO BE LIKE IN SOME FAR OFF LANDS
THE OWNERSHIP THE P. JEANNIE
ASSETS WITH CHANGING HANDS AND
EVENTUALLY START GETTING BILL BY
SOMEBODY ELSE --
BUT YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S AND
IT'S HIGHLY UNLIKELY THING TO
HAVE HAPPEN JUDGMENT HOLLY WOULD
BE EXTRAORDINARILY UNLIKELY TO
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN --
BECAUSE IN CHAPTER ELEVEN THERE
ARE CHECKS AND SAFEGUARDS TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO HAVE A MORE
INCLUSIVE PROCESS OF DECISION
MAKING AND TO HELP DECIDE WHAT
WILL HAPPEN WITH THESE ASSETS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU FOR A MINUTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU PROFESSOR FOR BEING
HERE -- WHAT
DID YOU TO DRILL DOWN A COUPLE
POINTS YOU RAISED --
ON THIS JURISDICTIONAL QUESTION --
OF A BANKRUPTCY VERSUS BURKE I
KNOW THERE'S SORT OF SPLIT
CIRCUIT OPINIONS TO SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK WENT ONE
WAY.
IN THE THIRD THE FIFTH ONE
ANOTHER WAY.
NOW THE NINTH.
WILL.
IN THEORY WEIGH IN AT SOME POINT
SOON -- DO
YOU SEE THIS THEN I DON'T KNOW
IF THERES OTHER PENDING CASES
GOING ON AROUND THE COUNTRY BUT
DO YOU SEE THIS GOOD.
JURISDICTION JUST I MEAN THREE
QUARTERS DIRECT JURISDICTION
OVER FEDERAL QUESTION LIKE THIS.
COULD YOU SEE THIS GETTING
APPEALED THERE AND IF SO.
JUST WALK US THROUGH THAT TIME
LINE.
SO IT IS IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
THIS COULD REACH THE SUPREME
COURT'S BECAUSE LIKE YOU SAID
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION.
I'M I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY
CIRCUIT COURT OPINIONS ARE OUT
THERE BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY
NUMBER BANKRUPTCY COURTS AND I
AM THAT HAVE WEIGHED IN ON THIS
BUT THERE'S NOTHING THAT IS
BINDING ON THIS PROCESS --
IN PRACTICE YOU COULD SEE
APPEALS ALL THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT'S NOW YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AN APPEAL PROCESS
THAT TAKES YEARS --
YOU HAVE TO IMAGINE THAT THE
NINETY FINAL WORD ON BECAUSE
PRACTICALLY THE WAY BANKRUPTCY
APPEALS TENDS TO WORK IS --
QUESTIONS CAN BECOME MOOT OR NOT
YOU KNOW THAT AND IT'S LITTLE
MORE COMPLICATED HERE IN THE
NINTH CIRCUIT --
BUT QUESTIONS CAN BECOME MOOT TO
CAN BECOME HARDER TO APPEAL
THINGS --
BUT IT'S RATE RELATIVELY UNUSUAL
pSUPREME COURT THIS COULD HAPPEN --
BUT YET THEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A YEAR YOU KNOW A COUPLE
YEARS OF LITIGATION AND THAT
SEEMS.
LESS LIKELY IT DOESN'T QUITE
SYNC UP WITH THE EXCLUSIVITY
PERIOD EITHER WRITING THEORY
THAT WOULD ECLIPSE THAT THE
EXCLUSIVITY IF IT DID GET.
IT WHAT IT WHERE YOU GOT STATE
LEADERS I MEAN IF THE NINTH
CIRCUIT.
IT WOULDN'T FOOD INTAKE AFFECT
IN OTHER WORDS.
ALSO IMAGINE THAT WHAT P.
JEANNIE WILL DO IS THEY'LL
THREATEN TO TEAR UP CONTRACTS
MAYBE THE FILE MOTIONS TO TEAR
THEM UP AND BUT IF THEY'RE ABLE
TO REACH NEGOTIATED RESOLUTIONS
WITH THE COUNTERPARTIES ON THE
OTHER SIDE MAYBE.
FOR YOU KNOW RIGHT I DON'T KNOW
RIGHT -- SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT OTHER
QUESTION IS ABOUT --
ELABORATING FURTHER ON THE
FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS I KNOW
THERE'S A MULTI FACTOR TEST THE
FEASIBILITY IS ONE OF MANY.
THERE'S ALSO THE BEST INTEREST
TEST WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER YOU'RE.
LOOKING AT THE THE RELATIVE
VALUE PURSES FULL LIQUIDATION OF
WHICH IT JUST WONDERING HOW.
WHAT MAKES YOU BELIEVE THAT FEES
ABILITIES ARE TO REQUIRES A
MULTI YEAR SOLUTION JUST LOOKING
AT PRESIDENT THERE CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THAT?
SO THE WAY THAT REQUIREMENTS HAS
TYPICALLY BEEN INTERPRETED BY
THE COURTS IT'S REQUIRES A
FINDING FROM THE JUDGE THAT --
THIS BANKRUPTCY IS UNLIKE OTHER
BANKRUPTCY AND OBVIOUSLY YOU
CAN'T PREDICT THE FUTURE SO IN A
PREDICTIONS ANY YEAR A MUCH MORE
RELIABLE THAN PREDICTIONS IN.%
TEN YEARS OR SO IT TENDS TO BE
AN ANALYSIS FOR THE JUDGE LOOKS
AT IT AND IT'S ANALYSIS LIKE KILL
HAVE NUMBERS IN FRONT OF HIM.
BUT IT'S A DO I THINK BASED ON
WITH THIS COMPANIES PROPOSING
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO GO BACK
INTO BANKRUPTCY AGAIN AND
RECENTLY YOU'RE SEEING A NUMBER
OF RETAILERS WE'RE GOING INTO
BANKRUPTCY COMING OUT AND FILING
AGAIN IMMEDIATELY.
AND THERE THE JUDGE JUST MADE A
JUDGMENT CLL THAT THIS COMPANY
IS LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO SURVIVE
AND WAS PROVEN NOT TO BE TRUE.
SO IT'S POSSIBLE THAT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT COULD HAPPEN HERE BUT
MY GUESS IS THE JUDGE MENTALITY
WILL CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT
FEASIBILITY AND MAKING SURE THE
P. GENIE IS NOT LIKELY. TO GO
BACK INTO BANKRUPTCY WHICH
REQUIRE SOME SORT OF PLAN FOR
FUTURE WILDFIRE LIABILITY.
IN FINAL QUESTION BECAUSE GOING
TO THAT OTHER FACTOR THAT BEST
INTEREST TEST IS THE IS THE WORK
GOING ON IN THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WHERE THEY'VE SORT OF
PUT OUT THERE --
I FORGET EXACTLY WITH THE FOR IF
IT WAS A AYE AYE OR SOME SOME
SOME ORDER.
ABOUT LOOKING AT SORT OF THE
GOVERNING STRUCTURES --
OPTIONS WITHIN P. JEANNIE ARE
HAVING MULTIPLE SMALLER
UTILITIES POTENTIALLY.
LOOK RETHINKING HOW THE THEY
MANAGE GOVERNANCE A GAS AND
ELECTRICITY DELIVERY AND THE
WHOLESALE SIDE LIKE.
DOES THAT ACTUALLY DOES THAT
AFFECT.
THEN THE BEST INTERESTS TESTER
ANY OF THE SORT OF FACTORS THE
JUDGE WILL BE LOOKING AT
DEPENDING ON WHAT.
HOW MUCH MORE FLESHED OUT THAT
LIQUIDATION SCENARIO LOOKS FROM
OUR REGULATORS REMOVED FROM US?
EVERY WITH EIGHT DO THEY HAVE TO
TAKE SOME OF THAT INTO ACCOUNT
IN IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT WHAT
THE THIRTY COMPARATIVE VALUES.
SO ARE ARE YOU SPEAKING ABOUT A
SITUATION WHERE P. JEANNIE COULD
BE REDUCED INTO SMALLER PARTS
YES YES --
SO A SITUATION LIKE THAT ISN'T
IMPOSSIBLE IT PROBABLY WOULDN'T
BE DONE AS A LIQUIDATION IT
WOULD BE MORE DONE AS AND SALE
OF DIFFERENT ASSETS --
WHICH IS IT BUT I MEAN IT SOUNDS
THE SAME AS A LIQUIDATION BUT A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT --
DO I THINK THAT THE JUDGE WOULD
IS ON THE TABLE I THINK THAT
HE'D HAVE.
TO CENTER RUBIO.
YEAH I'M SORRY YES IN A RUDE.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
INFORMATION US I BELIEVE FIVE
SENATORS DON'T SEND A IT'S A LOT
OF INFORMATION COMING OUT AS
JUST A LITTLE CURIOUS ABOUT THE
AD HOC COMMITTEES I BELIEVE YOU
MENTIONED.
THERE WERE AGITATORS SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS WHO MAKES UP
THESE GROUPS AND DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THEY'RE GONNA BE
TRYING TO WORK THE BUILDING WORK
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD WE BE
LOOKING OUT FOR THESE GROUPS --
SO THE PRACTICE AMONG BANKRUPTCY
LAWYERS IS THAT WHEN A COMPANY
FALLS INTO FINANCIAL DISTRESS
THE CREDITORS ORGANIZE AND THE
PARTIES THE TEND TO ORGANIZE THE
CREDITORS.
ARE LAWYERS SO THERE IS A LAW
FIRM IN NEW YORK FOR EXAMPLE
THAT IS REPRESENTING THE AD HOC
GROUP OF P. JEANNIE BOND HOLDERS
AND I THINK THERE MIGHT BE OTHER
LAW FIRMS REPRESENTING OTHER.
AD HOC GROUPS OF P. JEANNIE BOND
HOLDERS THAT MAYBE HAVE
FACTUALLY DIFFERENT SITUATIONS
MAY BE THEIR SMALLER VERSES ONE
IS A GROUP OF HEDGE FUNDS --
YOU CAN THE SAID THAT IS HOW
THEIR FORMS THEIR FORMED IN THIS
VERY INFORMAL WAY AND LIKE I
SAID THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN AN
AD HOC COMMITTEE AND AN OFFICIAL
ONE IS AN OFFICIAL ONE GETS
THEIR LAWYERS PAID FOR BY P.
JEANNIE.
PURSES AD HOC ONES --
THEY'RE PAYING FOR THEIR LAWYERS
THEMSELVES WHICH IS SOME WAY IS
A SIGNAL OF THEIR COMMITMENT --
WHAT I EXPECT THEM TO COME IN
WORK THE BUILDING I WOULD --
I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF THEY DID
AND I WAS ONCE WORKING ON BE.
YOU KNOW TO TO NOT TO WORK THEN
THE WRONG WORD TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS AND TO TRY TO
EDUCATE --
AND EXPLAIN TO YOU KNOW THE
ETHICAL REGULATORY BODY.
WHY IT IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
THOUGHT SOMETHING SHOULD HAPPEN
OR NOT --
AND YOU KNOW YES I WOULD EXPECT
THAT YOU WILL HEAR FROM THEM
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU SIR HERTZBERG.
DID YOU ATTEND ANY OF THE
HEARINGS IN THIS CASE --
I DID NOT BUT I SENT SOME
STUDENTS ON MY BEHALF WHO TOLD
ME SOME THINGS BUT I KNOW I DID
NOT I I LISTEN TO PARTS OF THEM.
DID AND IF I CAN JUST.
ADD TO WHAT THOSE ARE MORE LIKE
ASKED ABOUT COLOR IN THE CASE OR
ANYTHING --
THAT YOU LEARN FROM THOSE THINGS
THAT COULD BE INSIGHTFUL TO
SHARE WITH THIS COMMITTEE.
IN YOUR JUDGMENT IT WAS REPORTED
TO A YOU LISTEN --
TO MY MY JUDGMENT IS THAT THIS
CASE IS IN A VERY PRELIMINARY
PAY PLACE YOU KNOW THERE IS
THERE ARE MOTIONS ON THE TABLE
TO STABILIZE P. GENIES BUSINESS.
AND THEN THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
ACTION AROUND THE EDGES YOU THE
PPA ISSUES --
YOU HAVE VARIOUS MOTIONS WHICH
WILL CALL THEM IF THEY MOTIONS
THAT ARE BEING FILED --
WHERE VARIOUS PARTIES ARE SAYING
REALLY LATE HOURS GO AHEAD --
AND YOU'RE JUST IN A VERY
PRELIMINARY PLACE WHERE YOU'RE
NOT YET SEEN THE LEADERSHIP OUT
OF P. JEANNIE WHICH WOULD SAY
THIS IS WHERE THIS IS GOING.
YOU'RE IN THE BUSINESS
STABILIZATION PHASE OF THE CASE --
IN JUDGMENT HOLLY IS REALLY
BEING JUDICIOUS IN SAYING YOU
KNOW IF THERE'S A CONTENTIOUS
ISSUE LET'S WAIT A LITTLE WHILE
TO RULE ON IT LET'S SEE WE CAN
COME TO SOME CONCLUSIONS --
OR YOU CAN NEGOTIATED RETEK
REACHES SETTLEMENT I THINK ONE
THING YOU WOULD START TO SEE
FROM JUDGMENT HOLLY IS THE
INSTINCT THAT YOU WOULD.
YOU EXPECT HIM TO SHOW BASED ON
HIS REPUTATION THAT HE IS TRYING
TO PROD PEOPLE TO COME TO A DEAL
OUTSIDE THE COURTROOM AS OPPOSED
TO HIM.
MAKING RULINGS AND EVERYTHING
THAT RING AND IN THAT REGARD --
FROM YOUR OBSERVATIONS AMONG THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT YOU HAVE AND
FRIENDS AND THE LIKE IN AROUND
THE BANKRUPTCY. TO THE
GOVERNOR'S STATE OF THE STATE
WERE INDICATED THAT HE WANTS TO
FOCUS ON SOME SOLUTION IN SIXTY
DAYS HAVE ANY IMPACT ON THE
DISCUSSION FROM YOUR JUDGMENT --
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT IT HAD A
SURPRISINGLY LARGE IMPACT ON
BASED ON WHAT I'VE HEARD --
AGAIN IN INFORMAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH INVESTORS --
IT IS.
AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE LIKE THE
CITY THEN PUBLISHED A RESEARCH
NOTE SAYING ALL IT LOOKS LIKE
ALL INTO THE SKY IS BLUE AND ALL
IS CLEAR THE GOVERNOR'S REALLY
ENGAGED -- I
WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED GIVEN
THAT THERE WERE FOCUSED IT WAS
RESEARCH WAS ASKED REASSURED BY
THAT AS THEY HAVE BEEN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE MARKET PRICES OF P.
GENIES BONDS --
IT'S AT LEAST THE LAST I CHECKED
ON THE MARKET SEEMS TO THINK
THAT THE BOND HOLDERS ARE GOING
TO BE PEYTON FALL SO THAT WOULD
IMPLY THAT EITHER THERE'S LESS
LIVE BLESSED LOUD FIRE LIABILITY
THAN WE THOUGHT MEANING P.
JEANNIE.
WON'T HAVE TO PAY AS MUCH TO
WILD FIRE VICTIMS AS PERHAPS
THEY WORRY --
OR THAT THERE'S AN EXPECTATION
OF SOME SORT OF LEGISLATURE EVER
GUBERNATORIAL INTERVENTION --
BUT YES I THINK THAT THAT WAS A
STATEMENT THAT THE MARKET HEARD
LOUD AND CLEAR AND I THINK
PEOPLE TOOK IT FOR YOU KNOW
HEARING WHAT THEY WANTED TO HEAR
TO SOME EXTENT.
OKAY --
CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU BYE CENTER BROAD.
WHICH IS THE CHAIR AND GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY SIR --
JUST TWO VERY QUICK QUESTIONS
ONE HAS TO DO WITH PRESIDENT IN --
IN PARTICULAR --
DISASTER VICTIMS WHAT TYPE
PRESIDENT CAN YOU POINT TO OR
CAN YOU.
WHERE --
DISASTER VICTIMS.
YOU SEE SOME TYPE OF
COMPENSATION.
DURING ANY TYPE OF BANKRUPTCY OF
UTILITY IS THERE ANYTHING TO BE
ABLE TO POINT TO THAT YOU KNOW.
OF ANY CASE LAW OUT THERE.
SO THERE ARE UTILITY CASES.
WHERE STUFF LIKE THIS HAPPENS
WHAT COMES TO MIND A LITTLE BIT
MORE READILY ARE CASES WHERE YOU
HAVE COMPANIES THAT MANUFACTURE
PRODUCTS THAT HURT PEOPLE
WHETHER THEY CONTAIN ASBESTOS
WHICH IS OUR MANAGER IS OFTEN A
SITUATION --
THERE DEFINITELY A LOTS OF I
DISASTERS WHAT WE'D CALL
MASSPORT SITUATIONS ENDS THERE
ARE PLENTY OF THOSE CASES THAT
PROVIDED IZEABLE OR EVEN
RECOVERIES AND FALL TO THOSE
CREDITORS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN THE SECOND
PIECE IS IN REGARDS TO THE POWER
PURCHASE CONTRACTS --
AND THE ISSUE OF STATE LAW.
SO -- STATE
IS BEEN VERY CLEAR WHERE WE NEED
TO BE ADDED --
THEIR CLIMATE GOALS BOTH WITH
THE TAIL PIPE IS WELL AS ON OUR
PARA PROCUREMENT.
SO THEY WOULDN'T POTENTIALLY
COULD BE ABLE TO CUT THOSE
CONTRACTS THAT ARE PLACE BUT
THEY STILL HAVE.
TO FACE STATE LAW THAT MANDATES.
THEM POTENTIALLY GETTING BACK
INTO THOSE CONTRACTS BUT REALLY
THIS IS MORE POLITICAL AND
TRYING TO BE A DRIVE A CHEAPER
RATE -- IS
THAT ACCURATE.
SO -- A
COUPLE OF THINGS SO FIRST I I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH ALL OF THE
DETAILS OF THE CLEAN ENERGY
MANDATES THAT P. JEANNIE HAS TO
DEAL WITH WHEN P. GENIE COMES
OUT OF BANKRUPTCY THEY DO HAVE
TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
LAW.
MEANING THEY HAVE TO BE ACTING
IN A WAY THAT THE REGULATORY
EXPECTS THEM TO THEY HAVE TO DO
THE THINGS THAT YOU EXPECT THEM
TO DO -- AND
I WOULD ASSUME THAT COLORS THE
DECISIONS THAT BILL MAKING
BANKRUPTCY CASE --
BECAUSE ONE PART OF A FEASIBLE
PLAN WILL BE BEING IN A POSITION
TO COMPLY WITH STATE LAW --
WHETHER THAT MEANS THAT THEY YOU
KNOW LITIGATE WITH YOU KNOW PPA
COUNTERPARTIES RATHER
COUNTERPARTIES AND TRY TO CHANGE
SOME OF THE STRUCTURE ALONG THE
WAY I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THEY DO NEED LIKE THEY NEED
TO OBEY STATE LAW THERE IN
BANKRUPTCY AND AFTERWARDS AND
AND THAT'S WHY --
AS A NON LAWYER I DAY.
OUT WHERE --
TRYING TO BE ABLE TO FIND.
MORE ATTRACTIVE TERMS OF
CONTRACT BUT STILL IT KNOWING
THAT THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET
HALF OF THE POWER SUPPLY FROM A
GREEN.
A CERTIFIED AGREEMENT NOBLE
SOURCE --
AND THAT IS A CENTER THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY PLAY UP I THINK THAT
THAT IS CORRECT BASED ON MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE RENEWABLE
MANDATE SAYS WALLACE PEKINGESE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT WHICH
WILL DISRUPT.
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE INDUSTRY
WHO'VE BEEN COUNTING ON WHAT
THOSE RATES ARE --
AND THAT WILL HAVE A TRICKLE
DOWN EFFECT OBVIOUSLY SO THAT
THAT IS CERTAINLY POSSIBLE.
CENTER BRADFORD THEN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR DODD THANK YOU MISSED
YOUR ON I'M JUST CURIOUS AS IT
COMES TO ASSESSING A LIABILITY
WHETHER IT BE ON P. GINNY WE
KEEP HEARING --
THE NEW NORM IN CLIMATE CHANGE
AND I'M TRYING TO SEE WHAT
DEGREE WILL THAT BE FACTORED IN.
BECAUSE I IF YOU LOOK AT
HISTORICALLY --
UTILITIES OF CALLS NO MORE FIRES
TODAY THAN THEY DID TWENTY
THIRTY YEARS AGO THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IS YOU GOT MORE FUEL
OUT THERE YET.
I DROUGHT SEASON SO WILL YOU
FACTOR WILL TEACH A COURT TO
FACTOR IN.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ON MANAGE
FORCED BY BOTH THANK YOU SIR I
THINK THE ANSWER TO THAT IS THAT.
JUST MONTHS HOW HE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE IT GOES
AGAIN TO THE FEASIBILITY OF ANY
BANKRUPTCY PLAN P. JEANNIE HOUSE.
THEY CAN'T HAVE A PLAN THAT'S
DESIGNED FOR THE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS OR LEVEL OF FUEL THAT
EXISTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
THEY HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN THAT
WORKS WITH THE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS AND THAT YOU KNOW THE
TORT LIABILITY --
ENVIRONMENT THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TODAY SO I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD
STRONGLY EXPECTS JUDGMENTS HOLLY
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
AND I I JUST BE BACK ON THAT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT HARDEN AGREE
I'D AND LYING CLEARING SOMETIMES
LINE CLEARNESS A FACTOR OF?
ACCESS TO PROPERTY STILL WILL
THAT ALSO BE FACTORED IN BECAUSE
A LOT OF TIMES YOU CAN'T ACCESS
SOME PROPERTIES BUDGET THEIR
FEDERAL LANDS ARE PROBABLY ONLY
ANSWER THAT.
THEY WON'T LET HIM WANT TO CLEAR.
SO -- I'M
NOT I'M NOT SUPER DEEPLY AND I'M
FAMILIAR WITH THE WORLD OF
CLEARING TREES FROM FEDERAL AND
STATE LANDS BUT I WILL SAY THAT
THERE TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
CREATES A BARRIER THAT MEANS THE
P. JEANNIE.
CAN'T LEAVE BANKRUPTCY SAYING TO
THE JUDGE JUDGE WE'VE ELIMINATED
ALL OF THE POTENTIAL BECAUSE
WILDFIRES THAT ARE MASSIVELY
DAMAGING IN THE FUTURE.
IN THAT CASE YOU WOULD EXPECT
THE P. JEANNIE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
NEED TO SAY.
YOUR ON YOUR HONOR --
WE HAVE SOME SORT OF INSURANCE
SOLUTION BECAUSE WE AREN'T ABLE
TO LIMIT ALL LIABILITY THAT WE
MIGHT HAVE AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY FACE A REGULATORY
LANDSCAPE.
OF INVERSE CONDEMNATION AND THE
INABILITY TO YOU KNOW TAKE OVER
AROUND POWER LINES AND PUT THEM
UNDERGROUND OR DO OTHER THINGS
YOU NEED TO TO THEN.
BECOME LESS LIKELY THAT THEY'RE
QUICK MEN'S MAY PLAY A ROLE IN
FUTURE FIRES --
YOU WOULD EXPECT THAT THEN
ENSURING STORY THEY'RE TELLING
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE A
PROSPEROUS AND THRIVING COMPANY
IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU SIR SENATOR DOT.
YEAH THANK YOU UP FAST REALIZE
FOR BEING HERE THAT.
THEY'RE VERY GOOD --
PRESENTATION --
OBSERVER WIRE BROUGHT UP ABOUT
PRESIDENT --
FOR VICTIMS.
YOU KNOW I I'M HEARING SOME --
YOU KNOW TALK AROUND THE THE
EDGES SO TO SPEAK AS YOU --
SAID ABOUT --
A MOVE AFOOT TO TRY TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF A QUICK SETTLEMENT.
FOR VICTIMS I'M JUST WONDERING
I'VE I I COULD EVEN IMAGINE HOW
THAT.
PROCESS WOULD WORK --
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT AT
ALL AND HOW THAT COULD HAPPEN.
THE BANKRUPTCY LOS STRONGLY
PROMOTES SETTLEMENT --
AND WITH THIS MEANS THAT ON TO
THE SENSE THAT EVERYBODY READY
GET SET AROUND THE TABLE AND
AGREED JUDGE WE'VE SOLVED ALL OF
OUR PROBLEMS THE JUDGE WITH AND
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO BLAST THAT.
AND SND IT'S ON ITS WAY --
IT CERTAINLY SEEMS UNLIKELY
GIVEN MY KNOWLEDGE OF THE FACTS
THAT NEED TO BE FOUND IN
CONNECTION WITH ALL THE
POTENTIAL WHILE FOR LIABILITY
THAT MIGHT BE OUT THERE --
AND YOU KNOW TO THE EXTENT THE
P. JEANNIE DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY ALL THE ASSERTED
CLAIMS YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE A
CLAIM THAT IS GOOD YOU MAY YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE THE STANDING IN
BANKRUPTCY COURT.
THAN OBJECTS TO SOMEBODY WHO IS
A CLAIM THAT YOU FEEL IS NOT AS
GOOD SO IT CERTAINLY IS POSSIBLE
THAT THERE COULD BE A QUICK
SETTLEMENT TO FLY.
BUT ABSENT THE RESOURCES TO SORT
OF MAKE EVERYBODY HAPPY --
IT'S MUCH MORE LIKELY THAT WE'LL
SEE LITIGATION [inaudible]
THERE'S GONNA.
I'M THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
LEARNED A LOT.
I'M FOLLOWING UP ON ANGLE AROUND
THIS QUESTION OF THE FIRE
VICTIMS CLAIMS.
IF I UNDERSTOOD YOU RIGHT THE
THE CLAIMS THAT ARE RELEVANT IN
THIS BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING ARE
THOSE THAT WERE MADE FREE THE
FILING OF THE BANKRUPTCY DID I
UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECT OR NO SO
THAT IS NOT CORRECT OKAY --
SO -- I'M I
APOLOGIZE FOR MISS SPEAKING SO
TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE WERE
LAWSUITS THAT WERE FILED PRIOR
TO THE BANKRUPTCY THAT'S PART OF
THE STORY OF WHY THEY'RE IN
BANKRUPTCY. TO THE EXTENT THERE
PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED DAMAGES THAT
THEY HAVE YET TO SEE WINE AND
THEY STILL CAN WITHIN THE
APPLICABLE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
THEY'RE WELCOME TO FILE A CLAIM
WITH THE BANKRUPTCY COURTS THEY
WELCOME TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS AND ACTUALLY --
THE WAY BANKRUPTCY ALL WORKS IS
THAT EVEN IF THEY DON'T FILE A
CLAIM --
THEY STILL CAN BE SUBJECT TO SO
IT IS IN THEIR STRONG INTEREST
TO FILE A CLAIM BECAUSE THAT
WILL ALLOW THEM TO RECEIVE
WHATEVER VALUE WAS THERE TO PAY
THEM SO YOU WOULD EXPECT THAT
PART OF WHAT THIS BANKRUPTCY IS
GOING TO BE.
IS TRYING TO PRIDE EVERYONE WHO
HAS A CLEAN FOR LIABILITY TO
ASSERT AT IN THE PROCESS OF A
CERTI IT IS GOING TO BE GOING ON
A FOREMAN FILLING OUT A WE'RE
GOING ON A WEBSITE AND FILL OUT
A FORM.
SO ACTUALLY I WOULD EXPECT LOTS
OF PEOPLE WITH CLAIMS THAT ARE
VERY GOOD TO FILE THOSE CLAIMS I
WOULD ALSO EXPECT THE COMPANY
WILL HAVE A PROCESS.
OF WEEDING THROUGH PEOPLE WHO
YOU KNOW.
A CERTAIN TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF CLAIMS ON YOU KNOW ANON
AN IMPLAUSIBLE FACT PATTERN FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
CLAIMS -- SO
WE FOLLOWING UP ON THAT
[inaudible]
WE THERE ARE CLEARLY SOME OF THE
FIRES FOR WHICH INVESTIGATIONS
HAVE BEEN COMPLETE.
AND SOME LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY
HAS BEEN ASSIGNED.
THERE ARE SUBSEQUENT ONES WHERE
THAT HAS NOT OCCURRED YET.
AND SO HOW HOW DO THOSE FACTORS
IN THIS --
IN THE BANKRUPTCY --
IS SO THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CLAIMED SO.
YOU SHOULD THINK OF EVERYBODY
WAS A CLAIM AS HAVING A BODY OF
EVIDENCE THAT SUPPORTS THAT
CLAIM.
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THERE BEEN
FINDINGS BY CAL FIRE OTHERS THAT
P. GENIE IS LIABLE OR P. GENIES
ADMITTING LIABILITY.
THOSE ARE FACTS THAT ARE HELPFUL
FOR THAT PERSON IN ASSERTING THE
CLAIM YOU COULD YOU COULD ALSO
IMAGINE THOUGH THAT PERHAPS.
YOU KNOW HIGHLY MOTIVATED
SHAREHOLDERS COULD FILED BECAUSE
HIRE THEIR OWN EXPERTS TO TRY TO
DISPUTE WHATEVER THOSE FACTUAL
FINDINGS WERE IF THEY WANTED --
TO SO YOU EXPECTED THE KNOW THAT
TO BE HELPFUL EVIDENCE FOR
WHOEVER IS ASSERTING CLAIMS FOR
DAMAGES -- A
BUT THERE STILL COULD BE A
LITIGATION HAVE CLAIMS THAT WERE
THERE HAVE NOT YET BEEN FINDINGS
FROM ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCIES
FROM CAL FIRE OR FROM OTHERS OR
P. GENIE IS HAS NOT YET ADMITTED
LIABILITY --
THEY JUST HAVE MORE WORK TO DO
AND TRYING TO PROVE TO THE
COURTS THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
BE PAID --
WHATEVER IT IS AND YOU CAN
ASSUME THAT THOSE INVESTIGATIONS
COULD INFORM THE JUDGES FACT
FINDING BUT THE JUDGE MAY ALSO
DECIDE HE'S NOT GOING TO WAIT
FOR ALL OF THAT FACT FINDING.
NO HE WOULD HAVE THAT OPTION IF
YOU WANTED TO SO THEN FINALLY --
GOING BACK --
TO SENATOR GUARDS QUESTION SO --
AS YOU DESCRIBED IT'S YOU KNOW
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS THE JUDGE
ONE TO GET.
WANT TO GET SETTLEMENTS THEY
WANT TO RESOLVE THESE THINGS.
AND YET.
YOU ALSO SPECULATED THAT AROUND
THE FIRE CLAIMS THAT MAY NOT
HAPPEN.
IT MAY NOT HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY IN
A IN A SITUATION LIKE THIS WHERE
THERE ISN'T AN OBVIOUS TO DEAL
TO BE HAD ONE WOULD ASSUME THAT
EVEN IF THE ULTIMATE RESOLUTION
IS SETTLEMENT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
A LOT OF LITIGATION.
SO.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT AND I I AND MY
GUESS IS THAT EVEN IF YOU KNOW
MOST FIRE VICTIMS --
THEIR LAWYERS AND TO THIS
COMPANY WERE TO COME TO
RESOLUTION YOU'RE STILL GOING TO
HAVE PEOPLE WHO FILE CLAIMS
WHERE EVERYONE LOOKS AT AND SAYS
YOU DID NOT SUFFER THESE DAMAGES
OR THESE DAMAGES WERE NOT P.
GENIES FAULT IN THERE WILL STILL
BE LITIGATION.
OVER THOSE CLAIMANTS BUT I WOULD
IMAGINE THE FINAL NUMBER OF
CLAIMS THAT WILL BE FILED WILL
BE EXTRAORDINARILY LARGE.
THANK OU VERY MUCH HE WAS
EXTREMELY EDUCATIONAL.
AND ELIMINATING WE'VE SEEN A LOT
OF EXPERTS AND YOU'RE DEFINITELY
UP THE CATEGORY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER I'VE LEARNED A
LOT OF CHAIR AND RETAKING THE
BAR THIS SUMMER.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT --
AND ALL.
WE HAVE ELLIS STEBBINS WITH THAT
SHE IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. TO GET TOGETHER WITH
OUR ECCLES.
EYELASH --
HE'S THE GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
MATT AND I HOPE YOU STUDIED
UNDER UNDER PROFESSOR ALLIANCE.
AND WE HAVE EDWARD RANDOLPH THE
DEFEAT OF YET EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR ENERGY AND CLIMATE POLICY --
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING HOW ARE YOU.
GREAT THAT WAS REALLY GOOD
[inaudible]
EXCELLENT.
SO TURN HONORABLE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US TODAY --
BAZ -- TERM
MENTION I'M ALICE STEPHENS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. TO MY
RIGHT IS A GRANDDAUGHTER HE'S MY
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF OUR
ENERGY AND POP CLIMATE POLICY.
AND TO MY LEFT IS OUR CLEESE I
AGREE LARA OR CHIEF COUNSELOR
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE PC.
I'M GONNA GO OVER A VERY QUICK
OVERVIEW AND THEN WE HAVE WE
WILL RESPOND TO SEVERAL
QUESTIONS THAT WERE PROVIDED TO
US EARLIER [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU THE
IMPLICATIONS OF P. GENIES
DECISION TO FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY
ARE A VITAL MATTER MATTER FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE OF THE COMMISSION'S
PRIOR EXPERIENCE IN THE ENERGY
CRISIS WE'RE ACUTELY AWARE OF
THE IMPLICATIONS OF UTILITY-BANKRUPTCY FOR THE STATE'S CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAMS.
VULNERABLE LOW INCOME RATE
PAYERS CLEAN TECH BUSINESSES AND
THE ECONOMY.
THE COMMISSION IS COMMITTED TO
FINDING THE BEST POWER FORWARD
TO PROVIDE RATE PAYERS AND SAFE
AND RELIABLE SERVICE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AT THE FOREFRONT OF ALL OF OUR
MINDS OF COURSE IS THE FIRE
VICTIMS.
WE ARE GLAD THE BANKRUPTCY COURT
FOLLOW THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST TO
APPOINT A COMMITTEE CONSISTING
OF REPRESENTATIVES OF WILD FIRE
VICTIMS. TO ENSURE THAT THE
VICTIMS WILL HAVE STRONG
REPRESENTATION IN THE COURT ROOM.
I WANT TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE
EFFORTS OF THE COMMISSION IN
RESPONSE TO P. GENIES BANKRUPTCY.
AS GOVERNOR NEWSOME NOTED IN THE
STATE OF STATE ADDRESS HE HAS
CAN BE IN A TASK FORCE OF
CRITICAL STATE AGENCIES TO
ADDRESS THE MULTIPLE FACETS OF
THE BANKRUPTCY.
THE COMMISSION IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS EFFORT.
THE TASK FORCE BUILD ON THE
COLLABORATION THAT OCCURRED
DURING THE FIFTEEN DAY WINDOW
BETWEEN PGA ANY ANNOUNCING IT
WAS FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY AND
THE ACTUAL FILING.
DURING THIS TIME THE COMMISSION
CAREFULLY MONITOR THE SITUATION
AND WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE CHI SO
TO ENSURE THAT ELECTRIC AND GAS
SERVICE.
WOULD NOT BE INTERRUPTED
THANKFULLY IT WAS NOT.
THE COMMISSION HAS UNIQUE
STANDING TO DEFEND THE INTERESTS
OF CALIFORNIA RATE PAYERS AND
THE INTERESTS OF THE STATE MORE
BROADLY IN THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDINGS.
AS WAS THE CASE IN IN EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS THE COMMISSION AS A
PARTY IN THE PGA ANY BANKRUPTCY.
THIS MEANS THE COMMISSION WAS
THERE ON DAY ONE OF THE
BANKRUPTCY HARIAN AND WE'RE
READY PROTECT THE INTERESTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND RATE PAYERS
MOVING FORWARD.
IN RESPONSE TO THE BANKRUPTCY
FILING THE COMMISSION HAS ALSO
REVIEWED CRITICAL SAFETY AND
PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAMS TO MAKE
SURE THAT P. JEANNIE CAN
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT STATE
PRIORITIES AND POLICIES.
DURING THE BANKRUPTCY.
WHICH PROFESSOR ALLY IS ACTUALLY
REALLY --
EXPANDED ON THE COMMISSION
CONTINUES TO COOPERATE AND
COORDINATE WITH OUR FELLOW
AGENCIES SUCH AS CAL FIRE AND
CAL OR WE US TO PREPARE FOR THE
UPCOMING WILDFIRE SEASON.
YOU RECEIVED A HAND OUT --
JUST KIND OF A JUST GOING OVER
SB NINE NO ONE AND WILD FIRES.
THE COMMISSION IS MOVING QUICKLY
TO IMPLEMENT ALL OVER WILD FAR
RELATED RESPONSIBILITIES
INCLUDING REVIEWING WILDFIRE
MEDICATION PLANS FILED BY
UTILITIES.
REVISITING INDIAN URGES ASIAN
PROTOCOLS OF THE UTILITIES AND
DEVELOPING THE FINANCIAL STRESS
TEST MANDATED BY SB NINE A ONE
WE FULLY INTEND TO MEET THE
STATUTORY DIRECTIVE TO COMPLETE
REVIEW OF THE WILD FOR
MEDICATION PLANS BY THIS MAY.
WE ARE WORKING ON THE RELATED
RISK AND OTHER SAFETY
PROCEEDINGS AND HELPED ORGANIZE
A WILDFIRE TECH.
SUMMIT LATER THIS MONTH WHICH
YOU ARE ALL INVITED TO ATTEND.
WHICH WILL BE FOCUSED ON NEW
SOLUTIONS TO WILD FIRE
MITIGATION.
WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
EXPEDITE OUR PROCESSES
ESPECIALLY TO HANDLE TIME
SENSITIVE MATTER MATTERS.
I HAVE BEEN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR ONE YEAR.
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
NECESSARY CHANGES AT THE P. UC.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL OF YOU [inaudible]
AND ENSURING.
THAT WE HANDLED THINGS
APPROPRIATELY.
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY AND
WITHOUT.
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO OUR
ECCLES WHO HAS SPECIFIC
RESPONSES TO QUESTIONS THAT YOU
ALL POSED.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR HUESO AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS --
I WANTED TO FIRST NEVER.
TOUCH ON SOME --
KIND OF BANKRUPTCY NUANCES IN
CHAPTER ELEVEN RELATED TO THIS
PARTICULAR BANKRUPTCY SOME
UPCOMING KEY.
DATES AND TEACHINGS CHAPTER
ELEVEN CASE AND A DISCUSSION OF
OUR STANDING IN THE BANKRUPTCY
CASE AND THEN I'LL MOVE ON TO
QUESTIONS THAT SHE VAST --
YOU HEARD TESTIMONY THIS MORNING --
FROM PER.
ON FEDERAL YES THAT.
THIS IS VERY COMPLICATED
BANKRUPTCY THIS IS NOT.
WILK RELATION IT'S A CHAPTER
ELEVEN REORGANIZATION.
AND IT TOOK THREE YEARS FOR PGD
TOGETHER BANKRUPTCY THE LAST
TIME AND I WAS INVOLVED IN THE
THE FIRST PGA BANKRUPTCY AND I
CAN SHARE.
MY RESPONSES SOME OF THE
BENEFITS OF THAT EXPERIENCE.
BUT BECAUSE IT'S A REGULATIVE
THE REGULATED ENTITY --
I PRINCIPLE AREA OF CONCERN IS
TO THE EXTENT TO WHICH P.
JEANNIE AS A UTILITY.
AS A DEBTOR IN POSSESSION IN
THIS CHAPTER ELEVEN CASE
ATTEMPTS TO AVOID COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE LAW AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE
HEARD ALREADY THIS MORNING THAT
P. GINNY HAS TAKEN THE POSITION
THAT IT DOESN'T NEED FOR
APPROVAL. TO ABROGATE WHOLESALE
POWER PURCHASE AGREEMENTS ONLY
THE BANKRUPTCY APPROVAL AND I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT LATER ON IN MY COMMENTS.
ACCORDINGLY AS A REGULATOR OF
THE COMMISSION AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES.
NEEDS TO NEED TO BE VIGILANT TO
ENSURE THAT NOTHING CURVES.
IN THIS CHAPTER ELEVEN CASE THAT
CIRCUMVENT STATE LAW.
AND ARE REGULATORY DUTIES AND
AFFORDED IN TEACHING THESE
CHAPTER.
ELEVEN INCLUDE MARCH THIRTEENTH
HEARING THE COMPANY WILL SEEK
FINAL APPROVAL ON ITS DEBTOR IN
FINANCE.
THERE ARE IN POSSESSION
FINANCING IT'S FIVE POINT FIVE
BILLION --
THAT IT'S REQUESTING.
AN AUTHORIZATION TO CONTINUE
CUSTOMER PROGRAMS AND PAY
OPERATIONAL INTEGRITY SUPPLIERS
AMONG OTHER RELIEF.
I'M ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED PRIOR TO FILING FOR
BANKRUPTCY --
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH PEACH
YOU NEED TO IDENTIFY --
PROGRAMS THAT.
ARE PART OF THE CPC AND THE
STATE'S REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
THAT REALLY ARE NOT.
HE JIMMY IS ACTING AS A
FIDUCIARY ABOUT CIRCUMSTANCE IS
A REALLY NOT THERE ARE.
PROGRAMS IS NOT THERE ARE MANY --
AND WE WERE SUCCESSFUL WHAT
GIVING PGT TO IDENTIFY THOSE AND
TAKE THEM OFF THE TABLE.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THOSE COULD BE
PUT AS COLLATERAL FOR THEIR
DEBTOR IN POSSESSION FINANCING.
APRIL TENTH --
THERE'S A HEARING ON P. DIDDY'S
MOTION FOR A PRELIMINARY
INJUNCTION AGAINST FOR
EXERCISING JURISDICTION OVER THE
P. PA'S AGAIN I'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE MORE LATER.
AND MAY TWENTY EIGHTH.
IS CURRENTLY THE LAST EIGHT P.
JEANNIE HAS THE EXCLUSIVE RIGHT
TO FILE CHAPTER ELEVEN PLAN.
AM AT DATES IS SUBJECT TO
EXTENSIONS FOR UP TO AN
ADDITIONAL FOURTEEN MONTHS.
AND THAT'S THAT EXCLUSIVITY
ABOUT THE PROFESSOR WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
AS TO THE CPUC STANDING IN
BANKRUPTCY.
AND ARE ANTICIPATED ROLE --
WE HAVE MULTIPLE ROLES IN THE
CHAPTER ELEVEN CASE.
AS A REGULATOR.
WE CAN BE HEARD ON ANY MATTER
THAT AFFECTS OUR REGULATORY.
FORTY AND THIS IS SIGNIFICANT.
AS ULTIMATELY AND A PLAN THAT
THE BANKRUPTCY COURT CONFIRMS
MUST BE FEASIBLE.
AND THE SEAS CPUC SUPPORT FOR
PLAN.
INCLUDING THE PROPOSING OF ITS
OWN PLAN IF NECESSARY IS
CRITICAL FOR THE CONFIRMATION.
PROCESS OF ANY FEASIBLE PLAN.
THE COMMISSION ALSO HAS VARIOUS
CLAIMS AGAINST P. JEANNIE.
AS A CREDITOR PGD DOES OS MONEY.
THROUGHOUT THE PROCEEDINGS THE
CPUC ACTIVELY ENGAGES WITH P.
JEANNIE TO ENSURE THAT
ANTICIPATED ACTIONS IN THE
CHAPTER ELEVEN CASE ARE
CONSISTENT WITH STATE LAW.
SO THAT UNNECESSARY LITIGATION
CAN BE AVOIDED.
AND ALREADY GAVE THEEXAMPLE
THAT PRIOR TO FILING THEIR
PETITION WE WORKED WITH THEM. TO
AVOID LITIGATING OVER YOU KNOW
PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAMS AND
PAYMENTS OF NO COMMUNITY CHOICE
ACT AGGREGATORS AND OTHER.
PROGRAMS WHERE.
PT DISS COLLECTING MONEY.
AND PASSING THOSE LIVES ON IT
BUT IT'S REALLY NOT THEIR OWN
THEIR OWN ASSETS.
WE ALSO ENGAGE REGULARLY WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES
PARTICULARLY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
IN THE BANKRUPTCY REPRESENTS
OTHER STATE AGENCIES AS
CREDITORS IN THE BANKRUPTCY AND
THEY'RE ALSO VERY MUCH --
TUNED IN TO ENFORCEMENT OF THE
STATE'S STATUTORY FRAMEWORKS OF
THOSE OTHER AGENCIES.
AND SO WE COORDINATE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE TAKE CONSISTENT
POSITIONS TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE.
ALSO --
FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THAT A
DEBTOR IN POSSESSION OPERATING
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW YOU'VE
HEARD THAT A READY [inaudible]
AND THE BANKRUPTCY CODE ALSO
PROVIDED ANY RATE CHANGE UNDER
CHAPTER ELEVEN PLAN MUST BE
APPROVED BY THE RELEVANT
REGULATORY BODY.
SO IF THERE ARE ANY RATE
INCREASES OR ANYTHING THAT
AFFECTS RATES.
THERE HAS TO BE APPROVAL BY THE
KEYS SEE.
SO IN TERMS OF OUR PROCESS FOR
REVIEW OF A REORGANIZATION PLAN
INCLUDING REVIEW OF COST
RECOVERY.
IN MOST CASES THE DEBTOR IN THIS
CASE P. JEANNIE [inaudible]
FORMULATES PROPOSES --
ITS OWN PLAN OF REORGANIZATION.
OTHER PARTIES HOWEVER MAY
PROPOSE A CHAPTER ELEVEN PLAN IF
THE DEBTORS EXCLUSIVE RIGHT TO
FILE PLAN HAS EXPIRED.
OR THERE'S A STALEMATE IN THE
PLANT CLOSE ASIANS.
AND IN CHAPTER PIGEONS FIRST
CHAPTER ELEVEN CASE WE ACTUALLY
PROPOSED OUR OWN.
COMPETING CHAPTER ELEVEN PLAN OF
REORGANIZATION.
IN MATT --
FIRST [inaudible]
BANKRUPTCY --
WE DETERMINED THAT THE COMPANY'S
PLAN WAS CONTRARY TO STATE LAW.
AND POLICY AND IN THAT CASE
PETER NEIGHBORS DURING WHAT WE
CALL THAT A REGULATORY JAILBREAK.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET OUT FROM
UNDER SI PC JURISDICTION.
AND SPIN OFF EVERY.
PART OF THEIR ORGANIZATION
EXCEPT DISTRIBUTION. TO THE
FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION.
AND SO.
WHAT ENDED UP HAPPENING IS WE
ACTUALLY LITIGATED BOTH POINT
SINCE IN BANKRUPTCY COURT?
WE HAD HEARINGS IN THE
BANKRUPTCY COURT.
AND THERE WAS.
BUT HEARINGS LASTED PROBABLY TWO
TO THREE MONTHS.
AND THE JUDGE.
ORDER ALL OF US TO GO ON TO
SETTLEMENT NEGOTIATIONS.
BECAUSE IT WAS CLEAR THEY WERE
SO MANY.
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT NEEDED TO
BE RESOLVED IN BANKRUPTCY COURT
DOES LIKE SETTLEMENTS TO THE
EXTENT THAT CAN --
BE REACHED BETWEEN THE PARTIES
[inaudible]
AND ULTIMATELY WE DID REACH A
SETTLEMENT.
WITH A PROPOSED PLAN --
WHERE WHICH KEPT --
PTV REGULATED UNDER SI PC
JURISDICTION.
AND ALSO --
RESOLVED ALL OF THE FINANCIAL
ISSUES.
AND THE BANKRUPTCY CASE --
AND SO WE HAD OUR OWN PROCESS
WITH YOU SEE WE HAVE A
BANKRUPTCY --
I ALL I THAT WE OPENED.
AND IN THAT CASE.
WE HAD THE PROPOSED SETTLEMENT --
THAT'D FOR COMMENTS FROM ALL
PARTIES.
AND ULTIMATELY THE COMMISSION
APPROVED.
A MODIFIED SOLOMON PLAN WHICH
REQUIRED P. JEANNIE TO AGREE TO
THE CHANGES THAT THE COMMISSION
IMPOSED ON ITS APPROVAL.
AND ONCE THAT WAS DONE --
THAT MODIFIED SETTLEMENT PLAN
WAS FILED IN THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT AS THE TOP PLAN OF
ORGANIZATION AND WAS ULTIMATELY.
APPROVED [inaudible]
BY.
THE BANKRUPTCY COURT AND THERE
WERE APPEALED SINCE AND WE ALSO
WERE INVOLVED IN --
SUPPORTING THE PLAN APPEAL.
SO PETER IS NOT YET FILED ITS
PLAN OF REORGANIZATION --
SO IT'S PREMATURE TO SPECULATE
WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO FILE OUR
OWN PLAN --
REALLY DEPENDS ON WHAT P.
JEANNIE DOES --
BUT I THINK.
P. GINNY'S HAS REPRESENTED TO US
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO
GET PARTY'S ONBOARD.
PRIOR TO FILING A PLAN OF
ORGANIZATION.
SO A BANKRUPTCY COURT WILL
RESOLVE ALL PRE PETITION.
BANKRUPTCY CLAIMS INCLUDING THE
WILDFIRE LIABILITY CLAIMS FOR
DAMAGES.
THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO P. GINNY
FILING [inaudible] FOR
BANKRUPTCY [inaudible]
AND AGAIN.
ALRIGHT MAKING TREATMENT.
IS HANDLED BY THE CPUC
BANKRUPTCY COURT DOES NOT ENGAGE
IN RATE MAKING --
SO ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT --
THE MEMBERS HAD WAS WHETHER THE
CPR KEY IF YOU SEE CAN SPEAK
GENERALLY ABOUT THE TUG OF WAR.
RELATED TO THE JURISDICTION OF
THE PPA IS.
THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS
FIGHT GOING ON BETWEEN --
YOU TO NAY AND FOR KIDS AND
PUBLICLY.
PJ HAS STATED THAT IT'S MADE NO
DECISION TO REJECT ANY PPH BUT
IT'S JUST PREEMPTIVELY SUED
[inaudible] FOR JUST. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE THAT OPTION
IN BANKRUPTCY.
COURT -- SO
CURRENTLY THE PPA COUNTERPARTIES
OR TRYING TO TAKE THAT.
LAWSUIT.
COLIN ADVERSARY PROCEEDING OUT
OF BANKRUPTCY COURT TO DISTRICT
COURT.
AND JUDGE BROWN TELL A JUST
RECENTLY ISSUED A RECOMMENDATION
TO THE DISTRICT COURT.
ASKING THAT HE BE ABLE TO KEEP
IT AND RESOLVE THOSE QUESTIONS
HIMSELF.
I AM YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
TESTIMONY AND I AGREE THAT.
THE CASE LAW ABOUT WHO HAS
JURISDICTION HERE AS BETWEEN THE
BANKRUPTCY COURT [inaudible]
AND FOR IF THERE'S INCONSISTENT
PRESIDENT AND THERE'S NO BINDING
AUTHORITY RIGHT NOW ON THE NIGHT
CIRCUIT ON THIS ISSUE.
BUT WHAT I THINK HAS NOT BEEN
BROUGHT.
OPT SO FAR [inaudible]
IS THAT.
THE CPUC ALSO HAS.
REGULATORY FOR THE FORTY OVER
THE PPA IS NOT JUST.
FOR AND THE PPA IS ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE CPC'S
IMPLEMENTATION IN COMPLIANCE
WITH CALIFORNIA'S STATUTORY
GOALS.
POST ENERGY CRISIS FOR CLEAN
[inaudible]
ENERGY RELIABILITY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AGAINST MARKET POWER.
PARTIES TO THESE CONTRACTS NEED
TO BE ABLE TO RELY UPON THE
CONTRACTS THAT HAVE BEEN ENTERED
INTO.
AFTER COMPLYING WITH THE STATE'S
REGULATORY PROCUREMENT PROCESS.
AND AFTER RELYING ON THOSE
CONTRACTS TO OBTAIN FINANCING
FOR THIS PROJECTS.
AND THE CPUC HAS JURISDICTION
OVER THESE CONTRACTS AND THEY
CANNOT BE ABROGATED IN
BANKRUPTCY WITHOUT OUR APPROVAL.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ABROGATION OF SUCH CONTRACTS ARE
NESS --
WOULD NOT ONLY INTERFERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
COLDS.
BUT THAT THESE CONTRACTS ARE
NECESSARY FOR THE SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY OF THE ELECTRIC
SYSTEM.
AND MOREOVER ABROGATION WOULD
UNDERMINE REGULATORY CERTAINTY
NEEDED FOR THE CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
ONGOING EFFORTS TO GROW INTO
CARBON LINES IT'S ECONOMY.
AND ONE THING I WOULD ADD.
THESE CONTRACTS ARE NOT LIKE A
CONTRACT FOR WIDGETS CONTRACT
FOR SUPPLIES THAT A CREDITOR --
YOU KNOW IS FILING FOR TO
RECEIVE RECOVERING BANKRUPTCY.
THESE GO TO THE RELIABILITY OF
OUR WHOLE ELECTRIC SYSTEM AND
OUR OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS --
SO -- I DO
HAVE OTHER RESPONSES BUT THIS
FOR I THOUGHT I WOULD TAKE A
PAUSE AND SEE.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR FOR
HOW MANY JUST.
WANTED A JUST A UNDERSTAND --
ARE YOU CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN
THE NEGOTIATIONS OR IN WHATEVER
PROCESS IS UNFOLDING NOW ARE YOU
PRIVY TO WHAT IS HAPPENING
INTERNALLY.
YES WE HAVE --
PAUL WEISS --
WHO'S OUR BANKRUPTCY COUNSEL.
AND DID ALSO REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE FIRST BANKRUPTCY.
AND THEY ARE.
EXTREMELY EXPERIENCE --
WELL RESPECTED BANKRUPTCY FIRM.
AND ALSO BECAUSE THEY
REPRESENTATIVES THE FIRST
BANKRUPTCY --
AND THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
SHEPHERDED THE ARKHAM.
COMPETING PLAN FIRST BANKRUPTCY --
YEAH.
WE'VE HAD THIS.
ALMOST TWENTY YEAR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEM THEY ALSO.
OR BOND COUNSEL FOR THE
SECURITIZATION SAID HAPPENED
AFTER -- IN
BANKRUPTCY.
ALLEN THE HELPED US WITH THE
EXIT FINANCING FOR TEACHING OUT
OF BANKRUPTCY.
THEY'VE ALSO BEEN OUR BOND
COUNSEL FOR THE D. W. CONTRACTS.
WE ALSO HAVE DO SERRA PARTNERS
WHO AS OUR FINANCIAL ADVISER.
AND PAUL WEISS TO SERRA IS
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
COMMISSION.
ALLEN'S --
AND THEY'RE WORKING VERY.
AND YOU KNOW ALL THE OTHER
PARTIES SO WE'RE VERY ACTIVE AND
WE PLAN TO BE --
ACTIVE --
BECAUSE THERE ARE TOO MANY
IMPORTANT [inaudible]
ON GOALS THAT --
IN ISSUES RELATED TO NOT ONLY
OUR OWN JURISDICTION BUT OUR
IMPLEMENTATION.
STATE LAW --
AND WHATEVER.
AS YOU'RE INVOLVED.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE BASICALLY IF.
THERE IS A AN UNDERSTANDING OR
SETTLEMENT THAT IS REACHED
THROUGH THESE NEGOTIATION
PROCESS.
YOUR GONNA BRING THAT.
PROPOSED THAT TO THE COMMISSION.
AS A BODY FOR APPROVAL SO IT'LL
BE YOUR RECOMMENDATION TO THE
COMMISSION.
WHATEVER IT IS THAT NEGOTIATED
IT'LL BE A COUPLE OF THE NORMAL
CLASS A JUDICIAL PROCESS.
YES AND IT WAS EARLY THE
COMMISSIONERS AND OUR PARTY TO
THESE NEGOTIATED SINCE THIS IS
ALL WITHIN STE THE STAFF LEVEL
[inaudible]
I'M.
WE DO HAVE.
ONGOING COMMUNICATIONS WITH WEB
COMMISSIONERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
CLIENT BUT THERE ARE NO
NEGOTIATIONS PER SE.
YET I MEAN THIS IS VERY
PRELIMINARY RIGHT NOW.
BUT IN THE FIRST BANKRUPTCY IT
WAS A STAFF PROPOSAL.
ABOUT WAS REACHED AND THEN THE
COMMISSIONERS --
HOW -- TO IF
YOU ARE PROCESS THE BANKRUPTCY
ARE I AM.
WITH THE RECORD AND PARTIES
PARTICIPATING.
AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY INTERCHANGE
THAT PROPOSAL ONE BUT AND VOTED
ON IT AND AGAIN THEY DID HAVE
SOME MODIFICATIONS. TO THE
ORIGINAL --
SETTLEMENT PROPOSAL.
WHICH PAGING ELSEWHERE GREED TO
THOSE CHANGES.
YOU CAN ONLY AGREED. TO TO
WHAT'S IN THE POWER OF THE
COMMISSION LEGISLATIVE.
EITHER OBSTACLE OR THERE COULD
BE AN LEGISLATIVE FIX.
DO YOU SEE YOURSELVES
POTENTIALLY IS A PARTY TO
PRESENT THAT TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO SEEK.
LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANCE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS [inaudible]
IT'S THERE ARE SO MANY ISSUES
INVOLVED IN THIS BANKRUPTCY.
AT YOU KNOW ARE NOT.
JUST PC RELATED.
CHARGER STICTION THAT INVOLVE
BIG POLICY PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES.
AND THAT WE THINK THE ONLY.
WAY SHE'S GOING TO GET OUT OF
BANKRUPTCIES GET INVOLVED.
A SETTLEMENT THAT INVOLVES
GOVERNOR'S.
OFFICE AND THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THESE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT.
PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES AND GO TO
THE HEARTS OF STATE LAW.
AND WHEN WE ARE I MEAN I THINK
GENERALLY WERE WERE IN AN
ATMOSPHERE [inaudible]
WHERE?
WE'RE BEGINNING TO ASSESS
LIABILITIES DIFFERENTLY.
AND AND THE WAY WE OPERATE OUR
UTILITY NOW I THINK IS GOING TO
CHANGE GOING INTO THE FUTURE
THAT IS TO SIMPLY WHAT I MY
EXPECTATION --
WHETHER YOU SHARE THAT
EXPECTATION OF HOW HOW WOULD YOU.
I MEAN.
WE HAVE BEEN CREATED IN
[inaudible]
REQUIREMENTS REGULATORY CONTROLS
OR UTILITIES THAT.
OFTEN HAVE A COST ON RATE PAYERS.
OF OFTEN THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS.
BUT GIVEN.
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
THREAT.
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND THESE WILD
FIRES AND FLOODS AND HIGH WINDS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE FUTURE.
DO YOU DO YOU EXPECT THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE PRIORITIZING --
THE THE SAFETY ELEMENT OVER.
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE HAD --
THAT CAN BE COSTLY ANY WHAT I'M
ASKING IS ARE WE GONNA WAY.
OUR PRIORITIES TO MINIMIZE THE
THE INCREASE OF RATES BECAUSE MY
MY FEAR IS THAT WE'RE JUST GONNA
TOP.
YOU KNOW PILE ON RATE INCREASES
ON TOP OF OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS
AND SAY OKAY NOW WE FIX THIS
PROBLEM AND NOT REALLY OF VALUE
WAY.
HOW WE --
HOW WE REGULATE DIGIT UTILITIES
AND HOW WE TRY?
TO YOU KNOW --
BALANCE.
YOU KNOW THE THE THE COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS OF OF I WANT TO MAKE
SOME INITIAL RESPONSE AND AND
LET --
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF RANDOLPH ALSO
RESPOND --
SO.
JUST RAISING RATES IS NOT COULD
SOLVE THE PROBLEM HERE --
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT TO GET PGP OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY.
WE'RE DEALING HERE WITH.
YOU KNOW THESE ISSUES OF SAFETY
WILDFIRE LIABILITY.
YOU KNOW CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW
THAT'S IMPACTING.
CATASTROPHIC LIABILITY AND I
THINK THE STATE HAS TO COME UP
WITH SOME.
OVER ARCHING GLOBAL SOLUTION TO
THIS AND AND I WOULD ALSO
VENTURE TO SAY.
THAT.
UTILITIES AND RATEPAYERS SHOULD
NOT BE MADE --
THE INSURER OF LAST RESORT.
BECAUSE THAT IS NOT SUSTAINABLE.
SEVERAL THE STATE ROAD IS TO
GRAPPLE WITH THESE ISSUES AND
COME UP WITH.
SOME KIND OF GLOBAL SOLUTION AND
I'D LIKE.
TO PASS THE BATON HERE
[inaudible] FOR TO ADD.
THANK YOU --
EVERGRANDE OFF --
YEAH I THINK YOU RAISE A VERY
GOOD QUESTION YOU KNOW AS WE
LOOK AT THE CALENDAR THE
CIRCUMSTANCES HERE ON ON THE
COST AND WHO PAYS FOR THOSE.
I'M IN THE CHALLENGES NOT ONLY
DO WE HAVE --
THE WILD FOR LIABILITY COST ON
YOU HAVE THE THE COST OF THE
MEDICATION PLANS --
YOU KNOW YOU'RE TO STACK IN
THERE AS WELL WE HAVE THE FIGHT
THE COST OF THE WILD FIRES IT OF
ARE YOU KURD.
YOU HAVE THE POTENTIAL LIABILITY
ACOSTA WILD FIRES IN THE FUTURE.
I'M INSIDE YOU START THE STACK
ALL THOSE UP AND FOR SOME
STATUTORY REQUIRED REPORTS THAT
ARE DUE OUT IN APRIL --
TO HOPEFULLY PROVIDE A LOT MORE
CLARITY --
AROUND HOW ALL OF THOSE COSTS
COULD STACK UP --
BUT YOU DO GET TO A POINT WHERE
YOU CAN SEE WHERE.
ON BILLS AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THE IMPORTANT THING IS A
FOCUS ON BILLS NOT RATES WHAT
PEOPLE CARE ABOUT OF WHAT THEIR
TOTAL BILL IS.
ON START TO BECOME ON AFFORDABLE --
pWE PRIORITIZE BOTH WITHIN ANY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IN A
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING BUT THEN
ALSO WITH IN TOTALITY OF OF
WHAT'S GONNA NEED TO HAPPEN
OUTSIDE OF THE BANKRUPTCY
AGREEMENT.
AND THE FINAL THING THE PLANET
FOR THE RECORD ORGANIZATION PLAN
YOU MENTIONED THERE'S A
STATUTORY DEADLINE IN MAY.
OR IS THAT SOMETHING WAS A
MARCHER [inaudible]
MICHAEL.
I'M SORRY.
OF MAY TWENTY EIGHTH IS
CURRENTLY THE LAST DAY THAT
PEACHY HAS THE EXCLUSIVE RIGHT.
TO FILE CHAPTER ELEVEN PLAN.
ALTHOUGH THEY COULD HAVE THAT
EXTENDED UP TO FOURTEEN MONTHS.
AND AND AS YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY
THEY HAVE ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
TO GET OUT OF BANKRUPTCY BUT
THAT ALSO COULD BE.
EXTENDED YOU MENTIONED THAT MADE
A STATEMENT THAT THEY WILL FILE
IT UNTIL THEY HAVE SOMEWHAT OF A
UNDERSTANDING WITH YOU.
WELL THAT'S NOT EXACTLY.
THAT THEY'VE SAID THAT THERE ARE
GOING TO WORK OUT.
YOU KNOW SOME AGREEMENT BETWEEN
PARTIES PRIOR TO FILING IT.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GONNA DO ANY
GOOD IF THEY FILE SOMETHING
THAT'S DEAD ON ARRIVAL ON ON DAY
ONE SO.
WE SHOULD ASSUME IF THEY FILE IT.
THAT THERE'S AN AGREEMENT.
WELL NOT NECESSARILY I MEAN THEY
THERE COULD BE AGREEMENT ON PART
PART OF A FRAMEWORK AND
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT.
OTHER ASPECTS OF IT.
I REALLY CAN'T SPECULATE OKAY --
WE'RE GONNA GO TO IS --
CENTER MORE LOCKED AND SERVE GOD.
BILL -- AND
JUST A REMINDER THAT MISTER
RANDOLPH ALSO HAD SOME
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
OR CAN I THINK WE'VE COVERED.
OKAY WE'LL GO TO QUESTIONS --
I'VE BEEN REMINDED --
TO MAYBE YOU'RE GONNA COMMENT ON
THIS AND I WANT TO CUT YOU OFF
BUT IF YOU'RE GONNA COMMENT ON
SERVICE I GUESS.
THE BIGGEST QUESTION IS HOW WILL
THIS AFFECT SERVICE WILL PEOPLE
BE CUT OFF WILL.
WILL THAT CHANGE THE POLICY IN
TERMS OF HOW SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED YAH I'M I'M HAPPY TO
GO INTO THAT SO --
YOU KNOW IT IN THE FEW WEEKS
BEFORE P. JEANNIE WAS IN
BANKRUPTCY THERE WAS SOME
CONCERN ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SERVICE TO I DO SOME
CASH FOR PROBLEMS THEY'VE HAD.
NOW THAT THERE IN BANKRUPTCY AND
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO ON FINANCING --
THERE IS NOT.
THERE THERE'S VERY LITTLE
CONCERN ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SERVICE BOTH BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
FINANCING THEY NEED. TO BUY AND
SELL ON THE ELECT --
ELECTRICITY NATURAL GAS IN THE
N. B. -- TO
COMPLY WITH STATE --
LAWS AND REGULATIONS ON SO AZAR
BANKRUPTCY WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
BUY AND SELL ELECTRICITY AND
NATURAL GAS.
ON THAT THEY'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO SPEND THE MONEY NECESSARY ON
WILD FOR MEDICATION AND OTHER
SEPT SAFETY MEASURES THAT
THEY'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO FUND PUBLIC PURPOSE
PROGRAMS.
AND THE CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAM
SUCH AS CARE THE LOW INCOME
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY --
AND RENEWABLE ENERGY AND STORAGE
REBATE PROGRAMS --
YEP ALSO IMPORTANTLY ON AND I
THINK IF THEY'RE CLEESE MENTION
IS A LITTLE BIT AS P. JEANNIE
WAS GOING INTO BANKRUPTCY --
WE WORK TO ENSURE THAT ON FUNDS
THAT ARE SET ASIDE FOR REPAIR
PER -- OP
PROGRAMS REPAIR PURPOSES ON
CANNOT BE USED AS COLLATERAL
AGAINST THESE LINES ARE SO FOR
EXAMPLE I'M IN THIS IS --
AN ILLUSTRATIVE LET'S NOT THE
TOTAL US BUT FOR EXAMPLE TRUST
FUND SET ASIDE FOR ON NUCLEAR
DECOMMISSIONING.
THOSE CANNOT BE USE FOR
COLLATERAL AGAINST THE LOAN
THOSE ARE SAFE TRUST FUNDS --
FUNDS COLLECTED SUPPORT --
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZE
FOR LEGISLATION OR CBC MANDATE
SO FOR EXAMPLE ON THE UTILITIES
WILL OVER COLLECTED EARLY YEAR
SOME PROGRAMS LIKE THE STUFF
GENERATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
ON AND THOSE PROGRAMS DAY SET
ASIDE FOR THAT --
LANDS THAT HAVE BEEN --
SET ASIDE ON THE PART ELEMENT
EASEMENTS THOSE CONTINUE TO BE
PROTECTED.
THERE HAVE BEEN IT'S WORTH
NOTING SOME HICK UPS EARLY ON IN
BANKRUPTCY --
THAT WE'VE HAD TO WORK WITH P.
GINNY TO RESOLVE --
P. GENIES INSTITUTED A NEW
SYSTEM OF REVIEWING INVOICES --
WHICH I THINK CAN BE A LITTLE
CUMBERSOME --
AND SO WE'VE HAD TO WORK WITH
THEM TO MAKE SURE THE CRITICAL
VENDORS ARE PAID ON TIME THAT
THIS PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE
INVOICES DOESN'T SLOW DOWN.
ON THOSE PAYMENTS --
OUT THERE --
WE'VE ALSO HAD A PROBLEM WITH --
SOME STANDARD FORM CONTRACTS
THAT EXIST FOR SMALL RENEWABLE
PROGRAMS --
RIGHT NOW THAT REALLY IMPACTS
AND SMALL RENEWABLE BIOMASS
GENERATORS --
THE STANDARD FORM CONTRACTS HAVE
A PROVISION IN THEM THAT --
REQUIRE THE UTILITY TO CERTIFY
THAT THEIR FINANCIALLY SOLVENT --
OBVIOUSLY THE UTILITY CAN'T
CERTIFY RIGHT THROUGH THE
PROCESS AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN TO
HAVE THOSE TERMS REMOVED FROM
THAT CONTRACTS AT THOSE
CONTRACTS CAN BE EXECUTED.
I'M I ANTICIPATED TO BE MORE ONE
OFF PROBLEMS LIKE THIS ALONG THE
WAY -- AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE SETTING UP TO
DEAL WITH THOSE --
PROBLEMS --
YOU KNOW THE REST OF THE
STATEMENTS --
I HAD WERE LOOKING AT THE LONG
TERM --
IMPACTS HERE ON I THINK.
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO LOOK
AT THE LONG TERM IMPACTS IS THE
PC IS NOT GONNA APPROVE A PLAN.
ON THAT'S NOT GONNA MAINTAIN
UTILITIES --
OBLIGATION TO MEET THE STATE'S
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS DOES NOT
PROVIDE CALIFORNIA WITH A
RELIABLE RELIABLE AND I THINK
CRITICALLY AFFORDABLE
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS.
I'M IN WE'VE ADDED SOME
STATEMENTS YOU'RE ABOUT THE PPA
IT'S BUT I THINK WE'VE COME.
IF YOU IF YOU'RE --
I GO ARTS ENSURE THERE THE FIRST
TIME CAN I GO OVER SOME HISTORY
BECAUSE I WAS THERE --
TO AND I HAD SOME FUN AN ORANGE
COUNTY AT THE TIME WITH THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
ACTUALLY BECAME THE CHAIR OF THE
CREDITORS COMMITTEE SO.
IT'S LIKE DEJA VU HERE --
SAY YOU'RE SAYING WE'RE NOT
GETTING OLDER WE'RE GETTING
BETTER YEAH WELL HOPEFULLY WE
LEARN THINGS --
SO HELP ME OUT AT THE TIME --
THE UTILITIES WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO BUY FUTURES CONTRACTS THEY
HAD TO BUY ON THE SPOT MARKET IN
THE SPOT MARKET START SPIKED AND
SO THE CAR GOT TO BE.
JUST ENORMOUS IN IT AT THE TIME
STATE TREASURER PHIL ANGELIDES
WAS THEN ISSUING THAT. TO HELP
PAY FOR THESE CONTRACTS.
AND IN COULD YOU REFRESH ME ON
WHOSE DEATH WAS IT WAS IT ON THE
STATE [inaudible]
BOOKS OR WAS IT ON HE GENIES
BOOKS [inaudible]
WELL.
THIS IS PART OF THE ENERGY
CRISIS HISTORY AND ON THE STATE
HAD TO STEP I TO PURCHASE
ELECTRICITY ON BEHALF OF IN
OPERATE PAIRS AND SO
[inaudible]
THEY DID.
YEAH ISSUE BONDS INTO TO RAISE
MONEY TO DO THAT MEASURE THE D.
W. OR ARE BONDS THAT --
WE'VE REFINANCE MANY TIMES NOW
IT'S INTEREST RATES HAVE GONE
DOWN [inaudible]
BET.
WHEN P. GINNY WAS IN BANKRUPTCY
P. GINNY WAS NO LONGER
PURCHASING POWER FOR THE
UTILITIES [inaudible]
ELECTRIC POWER.
SO WHO WHO'S BEEN PAYING THE W.
R. BONDS --
WE HAVE.
WE REPAIRS RATEPAYERS THERE IS --
IT'S BUILT INTO THE P. JEANNIE
RATE TODAY.
AND SO IT MOVED IN FROM THE
STATE'S BOOKS TO THE P. JEANNIE
BUT SAY ASSUMED ALL THE DAT.
THERE'S A MAJOR ARM.
ACTION NOT SURE I THINK IT'S ON
THE TO BE OURS BOX STILL ON BUT
THERE'S A PROCESS IN WHICH EVERY
YEAR D. W. R. PROVIDES THE P.
YOU SEE WITH A STATEMENT OF WHAT
IT'S GOING TO COST TO PAY.
THOSE COSTS FOR THAT YEAR ON THE
NAY SHOW UP ACTUALLY AS A LINE
ITEM ON THE UTILITY BILL RIGHT
NOW -- IN
THOSE BONDS WILL NOT BE OF THOSE
COSTS WILL NOT BE PAID OFF IN
FULL UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WITH TWO OF
RESIDUE YES.
I'M.
SO MY CONCERN IS THAT --
WELL MAYBE THE FIRST QUESTION
WOULD BE.
WHO WHO ESTABLISHED A POLICY OF
AB ACQUIRING?
ELECTRICITY AND GAS ON THE SPOT
MARKET WHAT WAS THAT AS SEAT
CPUC REGULATION OR WAS.
AB.
EIGHTEEN NINETY SOME OF YOU
[inaudible]
REMEMBER THAT.
RIGHT SO THAT WAS THE DE
REGULATION --
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY WAS PART OF
ELECTRIC RESTRUCTURING AND SET
UP THE CREATION.
AND THE POWER EXCHANGE.
SO THEN THE STATE SORT OF FOR
HELP CREATE THE AND THAT.
WELL WE'RE KIND OF INFERRING.
I THINK THAT MAY BE A SUBJECT
FOR ANOTHER DAY YEAH A LONG
HEARING A LOT OF HISTORY.
YEAH BUT THEN LET ME.
LET ME.
MAYBE FOCUS ON WHY I'M ASKING
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
TRYING TO PREVENT WILDFIRES.
LEGISLATION.
AND IT HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN IN A IN MY RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT.
THE CPUC AND CAL FIRE TAKEN TEN
YEARS.
TO BUILD NOT GET BUYER MAPS DONE --
AND I'VE GOT COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE AT RISK THAT.
SHOULD BE UNDER GROUNDINGOR
DOING SOMETHING TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND SO I I SINCE MY
EFFORTS YOU WE'VE HAD. HUNDRED
TWENTY PEOPLE DIE AND WONDERFUL
COMMUNITY SO I'M I'M REALLY
GETTING OLD CONCERNED BECAUSE
THE CPUC ISN'T DURING THE FIRE
MAPS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND WE ARE TRYING TO ELECTRIFY
THIS STATE.
WE'RE TRYING TO GET.
COMPANIES TO HAVE.
ELECTRIC POWERED TRUCKS WHICH
TAKE HOURS TO RECHARGE RATE AND
SO MUCH ENERGY WE GOT TO MOVE
ALL THIS STUFF AROUND STATE.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING.
WHERE IS THE LEADERSHIP FROM THE
CPU SITA TO ADDRESS THESE
CRITICAL ISSUES WHERE WE'VE BEEN?
AND WOULD WE HAVE EXPOSURE AS A
DEEP POCKET TO BE DRAWN INTO.
THIS [inaudible]
CHAPTER [inaudible]
ELEVEN FILE.
BUT A LOT OF QUESTIONS IN
[inaudible]
ONE MAYBE.
YES I KNOW OUR SINCE YOU'VE BEEN
THERE AND I CAN I THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET AT I THANK GOD ON THE THE
TIMING OF THE WITH THE THE WILD
FOR MAXIMUM BEGINNING ONE OF THE
THREE OF US ARE IN THE BEST
POSITION TO ANSWER THAT.
QUESTION.
ON THE ON THE QUESTION OF THE
DEEP POCKETS OF THIS IF THE
STATE CAN BE BROUGHT INTO IT NOT
NOT MUST THE STATE WANTS TO GET
BROUGHT INTO IT --
YOU KNOW AS FAR AS THE P. GINNY
BANKRUPTCY.
NOW AS FAR AS BROADER.
WILDFIRE LITIGATION I THINK
THAT'S A QUESTION.
FOR A DIFFERENT AGENCY.
SO THEN THE STATE.
BACK IN --
TWO WAS BROUGHT INTO IT.
AS MAYBE A AN AGENT FOR THE
UTILITIES TO TO TO BORROW MONEY
TO PAY FOR THAT.
ELECTRICITY TO GIVE TO THE TO
THE REPAIRS BY HAVING TO PAY A
MASSIVE INCREASE IN RATES AND
THEN IT WAS.
AMORTIZED OVER A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME AND SO THAT'S THAT'S BEEN
RESOLVED BUT IT WAS A BIG.
WE ALWAYS MEMBERS ARE COMING
BACK MYSTICAL OR I MEAN I I GRAY
DAVIS TOOK A PROBLEM TURN IT
INTO A MESS.
ANY GOT RECALLED OVER I BELIEVE
IT WAS ONE OF THE MAJOR FACTORS
OF WHY HE WAS RECALLED SO THIS
IS.
VERY SERIOUS THIS WHOLE P.
JEANNIE AND HERE WE AREAGAIN
AND I'M JUST.
I'M JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WERE HERE.
WE WE'VE LEARNED FROM TWENTY
YEARS.
INCOME FOR EVERYBODY ALL ALL THE
SAME.
SO THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS MISTER
CURRENT THANK YOU FOR AT LEAST.
VETTING BECAUSE IT WAS AN
INTERESTING TIME AND AND I HAD
FUND DEALING WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN.
THERE SEE ABOUT THE TIME IS TED
CRAVER AND THEN HE'S GAME THE C.
E. O. LATER AND WE JUST HAD A
LOT OF INTERESTING.
NOT LIKE JERRY HILL VERSUS BG
ANYWAY.
WELL I HOPE THAT THAT.
THE EXPERIENCE SERVICES WELL
THIS.
ONE I WILL GO TO CENTER DOT.
YEAH I THINK THIS CENTER HILL
CENTER STERN SO THIS IS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT BANKRUPTCY
THAN THAN WHAT THAT WAS I DON'T
THINK THE UNDERLYING FACTORS.
OF THIS BANKRUPTCY PUTS US AT
ANY RISK OF HAVING.
YOUR THIS RATE --
WELL.
POWER COST --
YOUR BIG POWER POP COST PROBLEMS
I THINK WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS
ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT
I'LL BE QUICK --
ONE YOU SAID EARLIER THAT --
CPUC WOULD HAVE.
TO APPROVE ANY RATE INCREASES
AND I'M WATER IF THAT ALSO
APPLIES TO WEAR AND ONE OF THE
UTILITIES --
IS DOWNGRADED TO LIFE'S A JUNK
BOND STATUS.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE MAY
NOT BE CORRECTED THOSE ARE BY
STATUTE PASSED THROUGH --
RATE INCREASES AND LIKE A RATE
INCREASE --
FOR PROGRAMS THAT THEY HAVE AND
THEY WANT TO FILE AT A RATE
INCREASE TO FOLLOW QUESTION.
I'M.
I WOULD SAY THE IN THE FIRST
INSTANCE THAT [inaudible]
YOU.
WE WANT OUR UTILITIES TO BE
INVESTMENT GRADE WE DON'T WANT
HIM TO BE DOWNGRADED.
BUT ONE OF THE IMPACTS OF A
DOWNGRADE THIS IT MAKES THE COST
OF CAPITAL MORE EXPENSIVE. TO
BORROW -- SO
THAT JUST MEANS THAT.
THOSE COSTS. TO RATEPAYERS ARE
HIGHER THE BORING BECAUSE
ACTUALLY SO THAT'S AN AUTOMATIC
PASSED THROUGH IS THAT WHAT WHAT
I'M TRYING TO WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET AT IS IS.
EVEN DURING BANKRUPTCY WHILE
THIS IS ALL GOING ON THE THE
ENTITY HAS TO CONTINUE TO RUN.
AND THE COSTS ARE CLEARLY GOING
UP.
WHAT I'M ASKING IS IS ARE THOSE
RATES?
C. P. YOU SEE HERE IS THAT --
AND BY THE BANKRUPTCY COURT.
IF IN A GENERAL SENSE IF THE
UTILITIES BARRING COST GOES UP --
YEAH THE P. YOU SEE IN SOME
PROCESS AND ADD IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE -- A
PRECEDING THAT HAPPENS EVERY
SEVERAL YEARS THAT WE'RE GONNA
OPEN ONE THIS YEAR IT'S TEED UP
TO DETERMINE WHAT THE COST TO
CAPITAL IT --
IN AND THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
RECOVER THAT COST OF CAPITAL AS
WE DETERMINE THAT.
A MEAT IS THEORETICAL THAT WE
COULD SIT THERE AND SAY WE ARE
GOING ALLOW YOU TO RECOVER THE
TOTAL COST OF CAPITAL BUT THEN
IF THEY CAN'T RECOVER IT THEY
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO BORROW
AND ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICE.
EXACTLY THEN IT'S NOT ONLY THE
COST OF CAPITAL IT'S ALSO THE
COST OF CONTRACTS FOR LIKE WE
NEW BULLS WHERE DID SWER.
AND SOME OF THOSE THINGS AND SO
YEAH I JUST THINK IT'S FAIR TO
HAVE THAT.
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
DURING THIS PROCESS AND ALSO
WHAT'S GOING ON IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH OUR INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES THERE.
THAT THAT'S GOING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT THE ON REPAIRS NOBODY
WANTS TO SAY IT BUT I'D YOU KNOW
THE REALITY IS IS --
YEAH WITH OR WITHOUT
INTERVENTION THERE ARE IMPACTS --
TO OUR RATE PAYERS AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED.
TO PAY ATTENTION TO ONE FINAL
QUESTION IS LAST WEEK P. JEANNIE
ISSUED A STATEMENT THAT NOT
WITHSTANDING THE FACT THAT THE
COMPANY ENTERED CHAPTER.
ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY REORGANIZATION.
THE COMPANY WAS NOW QUESTIONING
WHETHER CAN CONTINUE AS AN
ONGOING CONCERN --
THAT ALMOST SOUNDS LIKE A
REVERSE YVONNE MUST STATEMENT.
AND I'M JUST LIKE WONDERING IF
THAT COST --
ANY CONCERN OR WHAT WHAT THAT
WAS ALL ABOUT MY MY
UNDERSTANDING OF OF THAT SOUNDS
A LOT MORE ALARMING THAN MAYBE.
IT IS --
THAT HAD TO DO WITH.
AN AUDIT VETS THEIR FINANCIAL
AUDIT AND STATEMENT SAID A
FINANCIAL.
AUDITOR CAN MAKE AND SO IF
YOU'RE AUDITING THE FINANCES OF
A COMPANY WHOSE IN BANKRUPTCY.
AS AN AUDITOR YU CAT CERTIFY
THAT THEY MAKE THAT
CERTIFICATION.
ABOUT THEM CONTINUE AS AN
ONGOING CONCERN.
IT'S THE KIND OF THING WHERE THE
AUDITOR DIDN'T HAVE ANY OTHER OP.
ANY OTHER CHOICE BUT TO MAKE
THAT STATEMENT BECAUSE PIGEONS
IN BANKRUPTCY.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT I
DIDN'T GET THAT DISTINCTION THAT.
YOU WOULDN'T GET IT FROM THE
NEWSPAPER [inaudible]
YEAH.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU TO CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND AND ENGAGED IN THIS
DISCUSSION OF TWO QUICK
QUESTIONS IN IMPEACHING A P.
GENIES FIRST DAY FILINGS THEY
DISCUSS A POTENTIAL LIABILITY
COULD EXCEED.
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS HOW
LIKELY IS THIS FIGURE.
TODAY IS THAT SOMETHING THAT.
THEY HAD IT IN ME --
TO AND AND WERE THERE ANY
TRIGGERING EVENTS THAT WOULD
NECESSITATE P. JEANNIE REALIZING.
ON THE BALANCE SHEET SOONER THAN
THAT.
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT
NUMBER INCLUDED THE POTENTIAL OF
THEIR LIABILITY FOR THE TUBS
FIRE.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT.
THEIR CURRENT ASSESSMENT IS OF
WHAT THEIR OUTSTANDING LIABILITY
IS.
ALTHOUGH THEY DID TAKE RECENTLY
ELEVEN POINT [inaudible]
FIVE BILLION --
RIGHT DOWN FOR THEIR CURRENT
[inaudible]
YEAR.
THANK YOU AND THEN THE OTHER --
ONE AND IT YOU'D MENTIONED THAT --
YOU'RE THE GOING TO CONTINUE I
THINK THE REPORT PROVIDING
SERVICE IN THAT THERE ARE A THAT
THAT'S ON GOING THAT'S NOT
REALLY A QUESTION BUT I GUESS MY
CONCERN IS.
HOW DO YOU ENSURE A SAFE UTILITY
IN YOU'RE NOT JUST THROUGHOUT
THE BANKRUPTCY BUT REALLY AS WE
GO AFTER THAT --
UTG CONTINUED THEIR OPERATIONS
IT WAS TWO MILLION CHANGED ISSUE
ISSUE SAID BUT HOW CAN
OPERATIONS IN PROOF AND AND AND
HOW ARE YOU TRACKING THAT TODAY
A BAD RAP TO SOME EXTENT AND AND
I'VE.
BEEN THERE GIVING THAT BAD RAP
TO SOME EXTENT OF BUT IT --
IT IN A LOT OF THAT IS.
YOU KNOW PERTAINS TO THE
STRUGGLE THAT YOU FACE.
IN JUST.
THE STRUGGLE THAT YOU FACE IS IN
IN TERMS OF THE INTO THE HAND
CUFFS YOU HAVE ON YOUR
OPERATIONS ALL OF THE TIME AND
THE REFORMS THAT I THINK ARE
NECESSARY AT THE FOR UC TO GIVE
YOU THE AND THE THE STRATEGIC
ABILITY TO BE MORE NIMBLE AND TO
TO DO.
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE
LEGISLATION OVER THE YEARS.
OF THE CITATION AUTHORITY AND
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT KIND OF
SPEED UP THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE UTILITIES ARE SAFE BUT FROM
WHAT WE WE SEE THERE'S A A FIVE
YEAR DELAY IN SOME CASES YOU
KNOW THE PRICE.
BEFORE YOU CAN ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING --
AND SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE KNOW THEY'RE MOVING
FORWARD THEY'RE STILL OPERATING
HOW CAN WE GUARANTEE THAT THEY
WILL DO IT IN A SAFE MANNER
[inaudible]
OUR ON IN THE SHORT TERM.
NEAR THE SB NINE A ONE REQUIRED
YOU KNOW THE ADDITIONAL OFFER
MITIGATION PLANS --
THOSE HAVE BEEN FILED --
TO A VERY MUCH AN ALL HANDS ON
DECK --
PROCESS OF THE P. YOU SEE THAT
IS THE TOP PRIORITY JUDGES AND
STAFF FOR BEING MOVED TO THOSE
OF THOSE GET APPROVED --
IN THE TIME FRAME LAID OUT IN --
NINE OH ONE FROM A FUNDING
STANDPOINT BECAUSE THOSE DO COST
MONEY --
THEY CAN FIND THOSE --
PROGRAMS HERE ONCE WE AUTHORIZE
THEM.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING TO IS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN I CAN WITHIN OUR OWN
RULES TO APPROVE A REQUEST FOR
THE MEMORANDUM ACCOUNTS AND
OTHER ISSUES.
AMEND MEDLEY SOMETIMES THAT GETS
BOGGED DOWN IN OUR OWN RULES IN
THE TIME FRAME IN WHICH UTILITY
WOULD LIKE IT APPROVED VERSES
WHICH WE CAN.
BUT WE'RE STILL DOING QUICK
TURNAROUND ON ON THOSE.
I THINK LONGER TERM THE QUESTION
YOU'RE ASKING IS THE SAME
QUESTION WE WERE ASKING BEFORE
THEY WENT INTO BANKRUPTCY.
WHEN THE NEW PHASE OF THE SAFETY
CULTURE --
AYE AYE ORDER INSTITUTE
INVESTIGATION WAS OPEN --
YOU KNOW IN THE ORIGINAL --
SCOPE OF THAT OPENED UP YOU KNOW
WHITNEY OF TRY --
GENIES HAD SINCE DECEMBER AND
WHAT VERSION ON AND ASK THE
QUESTION ORGANIZATIONALLY IS P.
JEANNIE SET UP. TO PROVIDE SAFE
SERVICE I'M SO WE ANTICIPATED
AND I THINK STONE DISSIPATE THAT
THAT IS THE VENUE WHERE WE HAVE --
A VERY PUBLIC CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH PGA
AND HE YOU KNOW GOING FORWARD
GIVEN THE HISTORY AND GIVEN THE
ISSUES THAT WE JUST LAID OUT
WITH THEIR CHALLENGES IN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT --
AND I APPRECIATE HEARING THAT.
I'M KIND OF A RECOGNITION OF THE
PROBLEM --
AND YOU KNOW WE WE'VE JUST SEEN
AND WE HEARD LAST WEEK P.
JEANNIE.
IDENTIFY A TRANSMISSION TOWER
PROBLEM THAT THE TAKING SOME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR IN TERMS OF
THEIR EQUIPMENT --
BUT THEN WE LOOK AT THE
INSPECTIONS THAT P. JEANNIE
CONDUCTED OF THESE TOWERS
HISTORICALLY AND THERE SEEMS TO
BE A LACKS OF A LACK OF OF
CONTINUITY AND OF EXPERTISE DONE
WITH THAT.
AND WHAT WE FIND IS THE SELF
SELF REGULATION AND SELF
MONITORING ITSELF AUDITING AND
THE CHALLENGE WITH THAT.
I KNOW IF IF IF IF A UTILITY IS
DOING A GOOD JOB WE EXPECT THEM
TO TO MONITOR THAT AND AND DO A
GOOD JOB BUT WHEN WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE
CASE WITH P. JEANNIE --
HE AND IN THAT CALLS FOR
INSPECTING THEIR WORK IS THAT
CONTEMPLATED [inaudible]
YES.
YES -- IN
FACT I AM WORKING VERY CLOSELY
RIGHT NOW WITH MY ENFORCEMENT --
DIRECTOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR LIZ
VITA MALASHENKO ON THIS AND WE
ARE LOOKING AT IT AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE CHANGES.
BECAUSE WE ARE RELIANT ON THE
YLIDES TO DO WHAT WE'RE TELLING
THEM IN MANDATING AND REGULATING
THEM TO DO.
SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY DON'T
DO IT AND YOU FIND THEM.
AND THEN YOU FIND THEM AGAIN.
AND AGAIN.
SO WHAT DO WE HAVE SOME.
WE'VE GOT TO COME UP WITH A
DIFFERENT SOLUTION.
AND WE ARE YOU KNOW THE WILD FAR
TECHNOLOGY CONFERENCES IS
FOCUSED ON WILDFIRES BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT CAN WE DEAL FROM WITH
TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE DO I NEED TO
HIRE THREE HUNDRED INVESTIGATORS.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE ANSWER
BUT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
RIGHT NOW I HAVE [inaudible]
EIGHTEEN STATEWIDE.
WE HAVE TO MAKE CHANGES SENATORS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I
WANTED TO FOLLOW ACTUALLY FOLLOW
UP ON THE LINE OF QUESTIONING
FROM SENATOR HILL DO APPRECIATE
YOUR BEING HERE AND FOR THE DEEP
DIVE WERE TAKING --
YOU KNOW ON ON THIS QUESTION OF
OF SORT OF ENFORCEMENT CAPACITY
AND THE ABILITY TO SAY WALK AND
CHEW GUM AT THE SAME TIME
ACTUALLY SOMETHING MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT IN THIS CASE WHICH IS
TO ENSURE SAFE UTILITY.
AND NOT ABANDON ALL OF OUR
POLICIES THAT WE THAT BY THE
HEART OF CALIFORNIA'S ETHOS FOR
WITH WHO WE ARE AS A STATE.
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT --
YEAH THE PUBLIC PURPOSES OF
BEING LEFT BEHIND THROUGH THIS
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING SO FIRST
WANTED.
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR ASSERTING
STANDING WITH AGGRESSION AND AND
PUTTING FOR THE STATE'S CASE
REALLY PARTICIPATING EARLY ON
AND FOR THE THE THE THE ABILITY
TO GET THE STAYS ON ON OUR
PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAMS I THINK
THAT.
I WOULD'VE BEEN VERY DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT --
SO WE'LL BE KEEPING AN EYE ON
THAT BUT WE APPRECIATE THAT OR I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
POSITION --
BUT IN TERMS OF THIS QUESTION OF
HE DID.
ADEQUATELY CONTINUE TO PUSH
ENFORCEMENT WHILE YOU'RE DEALING
WITH NINE OH ONE REVIEWS WHILE
YOU'VE GOT.
A GENERAL RATE CASE IT'S BEEN
SITTING THERE --
FOR I DON'T KNOW HOW HOW LONG
EDISON'S CASES BEEN BEFORE THE
COMMISSION BUT A WHILE --
HI I KNOW THAT THIS IS SOMEWHAT
OF A BUDGET COM QUESTION BECAUSE
BCP'S HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED AND
YOU ARE ASKING FOR STAFF
CAPACITY BUT IN SOME OF IT GETS
DOWN.
TO DRINK YOUR QUESTIONS OF LAW
LIKE I MEAN THERE'S A THERE'S A
PIPELINE THAT SEPARATE HADN'T
UPGRADED.
FOR I THINK OVER A YEAR SINCE IT
RUPTURED THAT NAY WAS NO REMOTE
SENSING CAPABILITY FOR IT --
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO
EVEN IF YOU HAD --
IN ALL THE NEW TECH IN THE WORLD
LIKE THAT OLD PIPE UNDERGROUND
IS PRETTY TOUGH TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S WRONG UNTIL IT SOMETHING
GOES REALLY BAD --
AND THERE ARE NONE OF THE REMOTE
SENSING PICKED IT UP AND YET NOW
HOSTS SEVEN CALIFORNIA'S.
ELECTRIC RATE FACE IS GONNA TAKE
A HIT FOR THAT FOR HAVING SUPPLY
CONSTRAINTS IN THAT BASIN.
SO.
HOW DO YOU?
WHAT IS THE NEW PIECE IN THE
HANDS OF NEWS HANDS ON SORT OF
APPROACH LOOK LIKE IN YOUR MIND
ME WHAT?
IS IT JUST ABOUT BODIES OR IS IT
ABOUT SOME OTHER.
SORT OF AUTHORITY THAT THAT'S
NEEDED TO TO GO DO THIS JOB IN A
IN A WAY THAT [inaudible]
YES.
THIS IS A LITTLE INHERENTLY
SKEPTICAL I GUESS AT THIS POINT.
WE WOULD APPRECIATE THAT THAT
SKEPTICISM ON BEHALF ALL THE
REPAIRS ARE CONSTITUENTS.
YEAH I WILL SAY THAT --
WE ARE LOOKING AT ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING TO HELP
WITH THAT SITUATION WE ARE OPEN
TO YOUR IDEAS. TO BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID WE ARE LOOKING AT
TECHNOLOGY BUT AS YOU SAID IT
DOESN'T SOLVE EVERYTHING YOU
KNOW JUST THINK THIS TAKE
TELEPHONE POLES FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY POLLS ARE
THERE HOW MANY MILLIONS OF POLES
ARE THERE IN CALIFORNIA.
HOW MANY IGNITION SOURCES IS
THAT?
AND WHO OWNS THOSE POLLS THE
UTILITIES AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
CA TELECOMS WHO HAVE A PIECE OF
THE POLE AND AND THEN YOU GOT
FIVE G. COMING ON WHO'S GOING.
TO CREATE THIS GIANT.
IS TO PUT ON THE POLE AND WHAT
DOES THAT DO AND AND HOW DOES
THAT IMPACT SAFETY BECAUSE NOW
YOU HAVE MORE ON THAT POLE SO WE
ARE I MEAN THIS IS THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL IN THE THINGS THAT WE'RELOOKING AT BECAUSE WE HAVE.
TO AND THAT ELECTRIC THAT'S GAS
DON'T FORGET WE REGULATE UBER
AND LIFT AND TOUR BUSES AND
WATER RATES AND RAIL FOR
CALIFORNIA I MEAN THIS ISN'T
JUST ONE AREA.
YOU SEE WE DO A LOT SO WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT ALL OF THOSE AREA
FROM A SAFETY PERSPECTIVE.
SO YEAH I MEAN AND I'M I'M
ABSOLUTELY OPEN BUT YOU'RE RIGHT
THROWING RESOURCES IN MORE
POSITIONS ISN'T NECESSARILY THE
ANSWER.
OKAY WELL I I'LL LOOK FOR A
POINT THAT THREAD VIEW ALL AND
BUDGET SUB ESPECIALLY IN STARTED
AGAIN THERE --
LAST QUESTION IS IS ABOUT YET IF
SENATOR DODD BROUGHT IT UP BUT
SORT OF THE THIS COST TO CAPITAL
QUESTION --
HAVE YOU GUYS DONE ANY INITIAL
ASSESSMENT --
SORT OF ESTIMATES ABOUT WHAT
IMPACT.
COSTA BORROWINGS HAVING.
A MEMBER COULD HAVE YEAH NOT.
NOT YET --
YOURTHERE IS YOUR WE HAVE A
PROCEEDING THAT THE ALL THE
UTILITIES ARE REQUIRED TO FILE.
THIS YEAR ACTUALLY I THINK IN
MARCH THIS MONTH --
APPLICATIONS FOR A NEW ROUND OF
COST OF CAPITAL REVIEW --
IN THE WAY THAT WORKS
PROCEDURALLY IS.
SIMILAR ANY OTHER PROCEEDING WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE PARTIES TO
THE PROCEEDINGS TO GO THROUGH
AND LOOK AT WHAT THE COST OF
CAPITAL IS.
ON FILE NOTE ON HERE TWO YEARS
AGO -- THE
UTILITIES CAME IN WITH A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WITH A LOT
OF PARTIES AND SAID LET'S LEAVE
THE COST OF CAPITAL THE SAME --
WITH A SLIGHT BUMP DOWN --
IN DELAY A FULL REVIEW ON FOR
THREE YEARS IN THE COMMISSION
SAID WE'LL DO A TWO YEAR DELAY
BECAUSE WE WERE ANXIOUS TO GET
AND AND GO THROUGH THE COST OF
CAPITAL BECAUSE WE QUITE FRANKLY
WE THOUGHT WAS TOO HIGH.
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN WE'RE GONNA
GO INTO THIS IN A VERY DIFFERENT
SITUATION HAN WE THOUGHT BUT
THAT IS ANOTHER.
CHALLENGES ACTUALLY PUT ON THE
P. UC'S PLATE YOU KNOW STARTING
RIGHT NOW TIMING ON THAT
PRECEDING ESTIMATE DOES IT
STARTS IN MARCH YEAH THEY FILE
IN MARCH SO I MEAN YOU'RE YOU'RE
WHERE IS ANYBODY ON TIME FOR OF
OUR PROCEEDINGS THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S A YEAR TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS --
MAKE IT MORE COMPLICATED THIS
TIME AROUND BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT WE ONE OF THE UTILITIES IS
INSOLVENT --
I DON'T NOT I HAD CAN'T WRAP MY
HEAD EXACTLY HOW WE'RE GONNA
WORK THROUGH THIS RIGHT NOW IS
TO ADD TO THE PLATE OF SORT OF
DO THINGS FASTERBETTER ALL THE
TIME -- IT
SEEMS HARD TO HAVE ACOSTA
CAPITAL PROCEEDING IS GONNA WRAP
UP AFTER.
THIS EXCLUSIVITY PERIOD ENDS
WITH P. JEANNIE AROUND THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING WHERE WE
REALLY.
WE DON'T GO IN BLIND IN OTHER
WORDS TO THAT RESOLUTION AROUND
FEASIBILITY WITHOUT KNOWING.
WHAT IS THE RATE BASE GONNA HIT
SO?
MAYBE THAT'S A DEATH FOR I'M
FUTURE CONVERSATION JUST HOW TO
ALIGN.
THE STARTED THESE OTHER
REGULATORY PROCESSES WITH THE
TIMING IN BANKRUPTCY IN MACOMB
CO HERE SO WE CAN.
WE CAN MAKE GOOD DECISIONS
OURSELVES IN AND WE ARE AND IT'S
NOT JUST US IT'S PROCEEDING
FORGETS THE COURT PROCEEDINGS
OUGHT. TO TRYING TO GET CHART
ALL OF THIS OUT RIGHT NOW CARE A
LOT OF MOVING PARTS GOOD INNER
BRADFORD.
HE WAS GERMAN.
I IT JUST REAL QUICK I'M PRETTY
SURE YOU'VE WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
REPAIRS SO JUST CURIOUS ON WHAT
ASSURANCES WILL P. C. ALKA TO
BEFORE PROVING.
OUR SHOULD I SEE IMPACTING --
THE BANKRUPTCIES COURT DECISION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FEAR AND
REASONABLE --
PLAN THAT DOESN'T IMPACT REPAIRS
WHAT IMPACT WILL YOU GUYS OUR
INVOLVEMENT SHOULD I SEE WHAT
YOU HAVE IN THAT [inaudible]
SO.
PART OF THE SHEEP UC'S CHARGE IS.
TO ADDRESS THE INTERESTS OF
RATEPAYERS AND THEN YOU KNOW WE
ARE QUITE ASIDE A JUDICIAL
AGENCY.
AND ANY.
BANKRUPTCY PLAN.
THAT THE CPUC.
WHAT APPROVED WOULD BE IN ONE OF
OUR PROCEEDINGS THAT WOULD HAVE
THE PARTICIPATION?
OF REPAIR ADVOCATES AND IN THOSE
PROCEEDINGS TO GIVE THEIR VIEWS
I'M SURE YOU'LL HEAR FROM TURN
THEIR HERE TODAY --
AND WE RELY ON YOU KNOW ALL OF
THE PARTIES TO OUR PROCEEDINGS
TO GIVE US INFORMATION AND AND
ADVOCATE FOR THE POLICIES THAT
YOU KNOW WE NEED. TO TO REVIEW
BEFORE ADOPTING.
BEYOND REPAIR INTERESTS AND
AFFORDABILITY ARE VERY IMPORTANT --
INTERESTED THAT ARMED WE ARE
LOOKING AT IN OUR PARTICIPATION
IN THE BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS.
WHAT I AND A AND A THAT AND WE
CONCERTATO BUT REPAIRS BUT AS WE
SAW TWENTY YEARS AGO REPAIRS
PAID FOR THIS?
I AS WE SAW ON SAINT BRUNO
REPAIRS PAID FOR THIS AND
SHAREHOLDERS NEVER TAKE A HIT.
ON ANY OF THESE INCIDENTS SO AT
WHAT POINT REALLY DO YOU START
LOOKING AFTER THE REPAIRS BUT WE
CAN SAY THAT FOR ANOTHER.
IN COULD I COULD SEE ON THE SAN
BRUNO SHAREHOLDERS TO TAKE A HIT
ON THAT.
AND AND AND SOME OF THE FINES
ADDED TO SO.
VERY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND OF
COURSE -- AS
USUAL YOU HAVE YOUR WORK CUT OUT
FOR YOU.
THEN THANK YOU.
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO COME OUT
HERE [inaudible]
WE'RE GONNA.
FOLLOW UP WITH --
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMMUNITY
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE AFFECTED BY
ALL THIS.
AND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THIS
BANKRUPTCY HAS A STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE --
THESE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE NOT --
PARTIES TO THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE BUT THEY ARE AFFECTED
BY PEOPLE THAT ARE IN STATE
CALLED HOLDER COMMITTEE AND
REPRESENTED BY SOME OF THE
MEMBERS OF THAT ARE STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE.
BUT WE WANT TO HEAR.
FROM THEM --
WE'RE WORK FOR PURCHASE WANT TO
RESPECT PEOPLE'S CALENDARS.
AND AS WERE LOONIES LOSING
MEMBERS I WANT TO I SAID AS YOU
COME FORWARD IT IF YOU CAN.
MAKE YOUR COMMENTS AND TRY TO BE
BRIEF BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A LONG
LIST OF OF OF INDIVIDUALS ON
THIS LIST BEGINNING WITH.
UP MAYOR JODY JONES FROM THE
TOWN OF PARADISE.
MARK TONY.
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
TOM DAZZLED THE BUSINESS MANAGER
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS.
A LOCAL --
TWELVE FORTY FIVE WE HAVE
CATHERINE ELLIOTT SHE IS --
COUNSEL TO MEN MENDOCINO COUNTY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
AND BETH ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE CHOICE ASSOCIATION.
AND ONCE MORE WE HAVE WITH US.
GEN SMITH AND JONES HE'S THE
WITH THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS WELCOME EVERYBODY
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH --
MAYOR JERRY JONES WELCOME.
AND AND AND IF YOU CAN TURN ON
YOUR MIND [inaudible]
ONCE AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
HI I AM JODY JONES THE MAYOR OF
PARADISE IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PARADISE SUFFERED
HISTORICAL DEVASTATION AS A
RESULT OF THE CAMPFIRE.
THE DEADLIEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE UTILITY CAUSED
WILDFIRE IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
IT BURNED OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND ACRES AND
DESTROYED NEARLY EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND BUILDINGS INCLUDING
FOURTEEN THOUSAND HOMES.
THE CAMPFIRE TRAGICALLY KILLED
EIGHTY SIX PEOPLE. TO BE SURE
THE TOWN OF PARADISE HAS
SUFFERED HISTORICAL DEVASTATION
THAT NO COMMUNITY SHOULD EVER
EXPERIENCE OR INDOOR.
THE LASTING EFFECTS ON FAMILIES
CHILDREN AND THOSE WHO LOST
THEIR LOVED ONES WILL LINGER-THROUGHOUT ENTIRE LIFETIMES.
AND SOME SCHOLARS MAY NEVER BE
HEALED.
DESPITE THE PAIN SUFFERING AND
DESTRUCTION THE TOWN A PARADISE
RESULTS TO REBUILD.
THE TOWN AND ITS CITIZENS HAVE
EMBARKED ON THIS JOURNEY TOWARD
RECOVERY AND IN THE MIDDLE OF
OUR RECOVERY IT WAS TERRIBLY
DISHEARTENING TO LEARN OF P.
GENIES CHOICE TO VOLUNTEER
TERRIBLY FILE FOR CHAPTER ELEVEN
BANKRUPTCY.
OUR SUCCESSFUL RECOVERY REQUIRES
IMPART THE IMMEDIATE AND
PROFESSIONAL ATTENTION OF P.
GINNY.
ON IMPORTANT SAFETY AND HAZARD
MITIGATION PROJECTS IN THE WAKE
OF THE WILDFIRE.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE
REMOVAL OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
TREES THAT ARE DEAD OR DYING.
MONITORING IN SECURING PUBLIC
UTILITIES SUCH AS GAS AND
ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS.
AND REBUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
SUCH AS UTILITY POLES THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
P. GENIES CHOICE TO FILE
BANKRUPTCY CALLS INTO QUESTION
THE PRIORITIES OF THIS MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR FOR PROFIT
CORPORATION.
RPG NEEDS TOP PRIORITY SAFETY
HAZARD MITIGATION AND WILDFIRE
RECOVERY OR IS THEIR TOP
PRIORITY FINANCIAL RESTRUCTURING
TO PROTECT PROFITS AND MARKET
VALUE FOR WALL STREET INVESTORS.
WHAT THEY DO IN THIS VOLUNTARY
BANKRUPTCY WILL SPEAK VOLUMES AS
TO ITS INTENTIONS AND WHETHER IT
PLANS TO COMPENSATE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED TO REBUILD?
ARE THEY FOCUSED ON RECOVERY AND
MAKING COMMUNITIES HOLE OR WILL
THEY FORCE VICTIMS INTO MY MULTI
YEAR CLAIMS PROCESS THAT DIFFERS
AND DELAYS ARE RECOVERY.
MORE THAN THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WERE RENDERED HOMELESS BY THE
CAMPFIRE. FOR MONTHS LATER MANY
ARE STILL LIVING IN RV'S OR
MOTEL ROOMS OR FRIENDS EXTRA
BEDROOMS.
AS RECOVERY IS DELAYED
HOMELESSNESS LINGERS AND HOUSING
CRISIS CONTINUES AND FAMILIES
CONTINUE TO LIVE WITHOUT THE DO
DIGNITY OF THEM.
P. GENIES ACTIONS IN THE
UPCOMING WEEKS AND MONTHS WILL
HAVE A RIPPLE EFFECT IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR YEARS TO COME.
A DELAYED RECOVERY PERIOD WILL
HAVE COMPOUNDED DEFECTS AS
DELAYED TAX REVENUES.
MEANS INCREASINGLY DELAYED
RECOVERY.
PARADISE NORMALLY ISSUES ABOUT
THIRTY BUILDING PERMITS PER YEAR.
FOR FIRE RECOVERY WITH AN
AGGRESSIVE REBUILD RATE OF FOUR
HUNDRED HOMES PER YEAR IT WILL
TAKE ABOUT TWENTY FOUR YEARS FOR
THE TOWN TO REGAIN ITS TAX BASE.
OUR ROUGH ESTIMATE.
SHOW THAT THE TELL WILL LOSE
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION IN REVENUES.
THAT'S A TOWN THAT HAS THE
GENERAL FUND BUDGET ANNUALLY OF
ABOUT TWELVE MILLION.
EVERY MAJOR FUNDING SOURCE OF
THE TOWN IS COMPROMISED JUST THE
FIRST YEAR ALONE.
WILL LOSE FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN PROPERTY TAXES THAT
ARE 41% OF OUR GENERAL FUND
BUDGET.
WILL LOSE TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN SALES AND USE TAX TWO
POINT ONE MILLION.
IN MOTOR VEHICLE IN LIEU TAX.
AND ONE POINT TWO MILLION IN
FRANCHISE FEES AND T. O. T.
TAXES.
AND NOT PART OF OUR GENERAL FUND
BUT A REALLY IMPORTANT THING IS
OUR ROADS ARE --
DETERIORATING BECAUSE OF THE
FIRE AND ALL OF THE TRUCKS USING
THEM.
WILL LOSE ONE POINT TWO MILLION
OF OUR GAS TAXES.
SO FOR THE COMMUNITY OF PARADISE
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED.
DELAYING THROUGH BANKRUPTCY THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR RECOVERY
IS LIKE KICKING A COMMUNITY THAT
P. GENIES ALREADY KNOCKED DOWN.
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY OF PARADISE
HOPES THAT P. JEANNIE USES THIS
BANKRUPTCY AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPEDITE.
NOT DELAY OUR COMMUNITIES
RECOVERY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE [inaudible]
MARK TURNED.
I MARK TONY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF TURN THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK THANK YOU FOR INVITING
US TO SPEAK.
IN THE TWO THOUSAND AND ONE P.
JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY.
RATE PAYERS WERE HIT FOR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN COUGH --
P. JEANNIE CUSTOMERS WERE FORCED
TO PAY. SIX POINT TWO BILLION.
EIGHT POINT TWO BILLION.
IN ABOVE PRICES. FOR A PERIOD OF
EIGHT YEARS TOTAL.
THAT RESULTED IN BILL INCREASES
OF ONE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. TO ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS AVERAGE PER
CUSTOMER OVER EIGHT YEARS.
WELL P. JEANNIE STOCK HAD DIED
TO LEFT AND SEVEN DOLLARS PER
SHARE AFTER THE BANKRUPTCY
FILING.
IT RECOVERED TO TWENTY NINE
DOLLARS PER SHARE ONE WEEK AFTER
THE COURT RESOLUTION OF
BANKRUPTCY.
THE STOCK REBOUND PERMITTED P.
JEANNIE TO DISTRIBUTE EIGHTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN BONUSES
TO SEVENTEEN CURRENT AND FORMER
EXECUTIVES FOR STICKING WITH
THEM THROUGH THE BANKRUPTCY
[inaudible]
SO.
THE OTHER THING THAT HAPPENED IS
THAT THE ACTUAL COST OF
BANKRUPTCY WITH ENORMOUS.
THE P. GINNY SPENT FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN LEGAL AND PROFESSIONAL
EXPENSIVE LAST TIME AROUND.
NOW ACCORDING TO THE EIGHT K.
THAT P. JEANNIE FILED JEFF
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH.
LAST WEEK.
THERE ESTIMATED COSTS FOR LEGAL
FEES FOR THE BANKRUPTCY THIS
TIME AROUND. FOR THE YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN A LOAN.
IS FOUR HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
PHOTO JEFF ADD THAT BY.
TIME THAT BY THREE WHICH IS HOW
LONG IT TOOK LAST TIME THE
ACTUAL COST AND THERE'S NO LIMIT
BY THE WAY THE BANKRUPTCY COURT
SETS NO LIMIT TO HOW MUCH THE
COST FAR. FOR REPAIRS ARE GOING
TO BE.
WHAT TURN HAS REQUESTED IN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS REQUESTED IS THAT
THERE BE A RATE PAYER COMMITTEE?
AS PART OF THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDING.
AT A RECOGNITION OF AN OFFICIAL
A GREAT PICK CAM AND THE REASON
THAT IS SO CRITICAL.
IS BECAUSE THE PROPOSAL THAT P.
GENIE IS GOING TO BRING FORWARD.
MONEY THAT'S PRESUMED IN THAT.
ACTUALLY TIES THE CPU FREES
HANDS OKAY ONCE THEY GET FOR
THEM.
THE WHAT THEY CAN DO IS
CONSTRAINED THAT'S WHY WE NEED A
RATE PAYER COMMITTEE.
AND WE HAVE A REQUEST THAT'S%
BEEN SIGNED BY THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE AT THE P..
A A RP CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU SIERRA CLUB GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE WE HAVE ALL
REQUESTED.
THAT A RATE PAYER COMMITTEE BE
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZED FOR A WEEK
CAN BE PART OF THE NEGOTIATION.
OF THE PROPOSAL THAT P. G. AND
HE PUTS OUT THERE BECAUSE WE
THINK HAT WE WILL HAVE MORE
IMPACT AT LIMITING RATE PAYER
COST.
EARLY IN THE PROCESS THEN
WAITING TILL THE END OF THE
PROCESS AFTER IT'S ALREADY
GOTTEN TO THE CPC AFTER THERE
ARE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ALL
READY [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
BAKED IN TO THE SETTLEMENT PLAN.
SO WE WOULD APPRECIATE THE
SENATE --
ENERGY UTILITIES --
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE
CONSIDER SUBMITTING A LETTER OF
SUPPORT.
AND ASKING THE CPU FEE TO SUBMIT
A LETTER OF SUPPORT THANK YOU.
COME OUT ALSO.
HI.
MY NAME IS TOM BILLS ALL I AM
THE BUSINESS MANAGER OF IBEW
LOCAL TO PRESENT ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND OF P. GENIES --
EMPLOYEES.
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND CONTRACTOR
LINEMEN WORKING AT PGA ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND THREE MINE
CLEARANCE TREE TRIMMERS WORKING
AT P. GINNY FOR CONTRACTORS --
WE WERE HERE I WAS HERE IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE WITH THAT
BANKRUPTCY IN.
I THINK THE ONLY REAL SIMILARITY
IS DRIVEN BY POLICY --
THAT WAS DRIVEN BY.
DE REGULATION WHERE.
EACH IN THE COULD ONLY CHARGE SO
MUCH FOR WHAT THEY WERE SELLING
ACTUALLY ALL UTILITIES.
AND BECAUSE OF THE REGULATION
AND RON IN THE CITY OF READING
AND W. P. WE'RE ALL GAMING THE
SYSTEM SO THEY WERE BUYING HERE
BUYING HI SELLING LOW.
THAT WAS A POLICY FAILURE ON
THEIR SOME POLICY FAILURES HERE --
YOUR HONOR ON THE ONE HAND IT'S
COMPLICATED I PREPARED AS A
VISUAL AID FOR OUR MEMBERS --
MAN.
WE WE COULD DO THAT JUST AS WELL
AS WELL.
THE FIRST ROUND [inaudible]
PRETTY -- SO
IN THE CENTER ARE THE ESSENTIAL
CLAIMS -- IN
SUCH AS THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CLAIMS EIGHTEEN CLAIMS.
ARE THE IN THE IN THE ISSUES IN
PLAY.
THE ORANGE CIRCLE ARE THE PLACES
WHERE IT'S BEING FOUGHT.
ALTHOUGH WHEN I MADE THIS WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE SIXTY DAY STRIKE
FORCE BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND THEN ON THE OUTSIDE OR THE
MAJOR INTERESTED PARTIES.
AND THIS JUST SHOWS HOW
INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED IT IS.
AND THE MATHEMATICIANS HERE CAN
FIGURE OUT.
HOW MANY DIFFERENT COMBINATIONS
OF THIS THERE ARE --
IT'S VERY VERY COMPLEX WE WE WE
HEARD THAT FROM.
FROM --
PROFESSOR AND NOT FROM HASTINGS.
ON THE ON THE OTHER HAND IT'S
IT'S FAIRLY PART OF IT'S VERY
SIMPLE.
AND THAT IS FOR FOR P. JEANNIE
TO EMERGE FROM BANKRUPTCY.
THE PLAYGROUND CAN'T BE THE SAME
THE THE PLAYING FIELD CANNOT BE
THE SAME THERE HAS TO BE A
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE OR TWO THERE.
HAVE TO BE CHANGES IN P. JEANNIE.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A CHANGE
EITHER IN LIABILITY OR IN.
THE FUNDING AND AGREE AGREE THE
STAKEHOLDERS IS LET'S NOT FOCUS
ON INVERSE.
AND STRICT LIABILITY LET'S FOCUS
ON ON A RISK POOLS SUCH AS BUT
FLORIDA DOES WITH HURRICANES.
ARE SO IT'S HOW WE PAY --
RATHER THAN WHAT THE BAR IS TO
PAY.
NOTE IT CLEARLY HAS TO BE A
SOLUTION THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF ALMOST EVERY
MAJOR PARTIES NOT EVERY MAJOR
PARTY -- BUT
IT OCCURS TO ME THAT UTILITIES
ARE RISK AVERSE BY BY DEFINITION.
AND I THINK THAT THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN RISK AVERSE AND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN RISK
AVERSE.
AND IF WE'RE GONNA GET OUT OF
THIS JAM THAT WERE AND HAS NOT
JUST P. JEANNIE IT'S NOT JUST
INVESTOR OWNS THE PUBLIC ON
PUBLIC LOAN UTILITIES.
ARE IN THE SAME SPOT.
MEAN SMART READING PALO ALTO
THEY'RE ALL THERE --
WHERE?
I MEAN IF THE CAR FIRE HAD BEEN
STARTED BY THE CITY OF READING.
RATHER THAN A SPARK OFTEN AXLE
CITY READING OF THE BANKRUPT
TODAY.
SO -- WE
NEED WE NEED TO WE NEED TO SOLVE
THAT NOW I'LL JUST MAKE ONE
OBSERVATION --
ABOUT WHAT BANKRUPTCY HAS DONE
AND IT HAS.
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE ROLE
OF HEDGE FUNDS AND CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES --
YEAH I THINK THAT TWO YEARS AGO
AT THIS POINT.
HEDGE FUNDS OWN 2% OF P. GENIES
STOCK.
TODAY DOWN 52%.
AND I THINK THAT --
THERE ARE NEGOTIATIONS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
GINNY'S THOUGHT THAT THEY'D SWAP
OUT MEMBERS THE BOARD RECORD
HIGH THAT'S OUT THE WINDOW THEY
ALL LIVE IN A GOING TO BE NEW.
AND PROBABLY KNEW BY THE END OF
THIS WEEK.
AND THE HEDGE FUNDS ARE ARE
JOCKEYING.
HEAD TURNS PLAY A USEFUL ROLE
BUT WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THE ONLY
FOCUSES FINANCIAL --
SAFETY OPERATIONAL ISSUES ARE
REALLY CRITICAL FOR SAVE FOR
SAFETY AND FOR AND FOR FOR
RATEPAYERS.
SOME SIMPLE COMPLICATED --
THANK YOU TAKES A RISK.
WILL MOVE ON TO CATHERINE
ELLIOTT.
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR SO IN
REMAINING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CATHERINE L. IT COUNTY COUNCIL
MENDOCINO COUNTY ON BEHALF OF
THE SOCK --
IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN P. JEANNIE NORTH BAY
FIRES TORE THROUGH.
THE COMMUNITIES IN AT LEAST
SEVEN DIFFERENT COUNTIES
INCLUDING MENDOCINO CINEMA NAPA
LAKE YUBA NEVADA AND BUTTE SO
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
PARTICULARLY IN THE FIRE
COUNTIES BUT I'VE SPOKEN TO MANY
OF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES IN THE
OTHER COUNTIES TO BRING TO THIS
INFORMATION TO YOU.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE FIRE AND
I SHOULD SAY YOU ASKED WHAT
COULD THIS COMMITTEE.
TO THIS IS A GOOD START SO I DO
APPRECIATE THIS.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE FIRE
LAWLER COMMUNITIES WERE TRYING
TO RECOVER P. JEANNIE ACTUALLY
FILED CLAIMS AGAINST THE PUBLIC
ENTITIES.
THEY FILED COSTLY PUBLIC RECORD
TERMS OF THEIR ONE REAL REMEDY
WHICH WAS INVERSE CONDEMNATION
AMONG OTHER BAIL UP.
OPTIONS HERE IN MEN AND
SACRAMENTO.
PRIOR TO FILING THE CHAPTER
ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY P. JEANNIE
CHOSE NOT TO COMPENSATE.
THE VICTIMS AND COMMUNITIES
FIRST.
P. JEANNIE NOW AND CHOICE THE
PROTECTION OF CHAPTER ELEVEN YET
STILL IS NOT PAID FOR THE
DEVASTATING TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FIRES. TO QUOTE
SENATOR HUESO REGARDING THIS
BANKRUPTCY IT'S DISHEARTENING
THAT IT HAS COME TO THIS.
THE IMPACT TO P. GENIES
BANKRUPTCY FILING INCLUDES THEIR
LITIGATION PROTECTION TO THE
DETRIMENT OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
FIRE VICTIMS. TO BE CLEAR P.
GENIES DECISION TO FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY HALTED ALL STATE
COURT LITIGATION AS YOU'VE HEARD
INCLUDING THE DISCOVERY OF FACTS
IN TRIAL BY JURY WHICH OFTEN
ENCOURAGES RESOLUTION.
THEY CHOSE FEDERAL BANKRUPTCY
COURT ESSES LEGAL FORUM WHICH
LEAVES LOCAL COMMUNITIES ASKING
WHY.
AND HOW LONG IS THIS GOING TO
TAKE AND WHILE I REALLY
APPRECIATED THE ACADEMIC
DISCUSSION IN TERMS OF WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE IT LOOKS VERY
DIFFERENT WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
GROUND.
WHAT P. GENIES INTENTION WHAT
WAS P. GENIES INTENTION OF
FILING THIS BANKRUPTCY WAS IT TO
PREVENT THE TRIAL BY JURY?
OR TO AVOID DISCOVERY OF
IMPORTANT FACTS AND INFORMATION
OR WAS IT JUST TO DELAY THE
COMPENSATION TO VICTIMS AND
COMMUNITIES.
MY COUNTY CHOSE TO FILE A
LAWSUIT AGAINST PGA ANY IN PART
TO SHOW UNITY WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL FIRE VICTIMS.
IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FAMILIES INSURANCE BENEFITS WILL
COME TO AN END AT THE CURRENT
PACE IT SEEMS UNLIKELY AND FROM
WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
THE P. JEANNIE WILL BE ABLE TO
COMPENSATE OUR COMMUNITIES BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR.
WHICH MEANS FAMILIES INSURANCE
BENEFITS WILL CEASE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL CONTINUE TO
DELAY PUBLIC WORKS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS INP.
JEANNIE WILL GET THROUGH ANOTHER
YEAR WITHOUT PAYING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IT OWES TO FIRE VICTIMS.
BANKRUPTCY ITSELF CAN BE USED
POSITIVELY.
AS A TOOL TO RESOLVE THESE
CLAIMS NOW OR IT CAN BE MISUSED
AS A LEGAL FORUM.
AND THE ABDICATION OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY THEREFORE IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT WE HAVE THE STATE'S
SUPPORT YOUR SUPPORT. TO ENSURE
THAT WE PROTECT THE RATE PAYERS
THAT WILDFIRE VICTIMS ARE
TREATED FAIRLY AND RECEIVE JUST
COMPENSATION FOR THEIR LOSSES.
IT IS LIKELY THAT P. GENIE IS
ALREADY APPROACHED MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATIVE REGULATORY.
OR ADMINISTRATIVE BAIL OUT
OPTIONS JUST LIKE THEY DID IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE HOWEVER IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE ENORMOUS
COSTS WERE POT PASSED ALONG TO
BECAUSE CUSTOMERS.
BUT THERE WAS NO REAL INCREASE
IN SAFETY OUT PUBLIC SAFETY AT
THAT TIME P. JEANNIE ASKED MANY
COUNTIES. TO WAIVE THEIR
PROPERTY TAX PENALTIES AND
INTEREST IN EXCHANGE FOR P.
JEANNIE GOING TO BANKRUPTCY
COURT WITH A MOTION TO ALLOW
THEM TO PAY THEIR TAXES. FOR
COUNTIES THAT TEETER THEIR TAXES
THIS CAUSES YOU HAD ANOTHER
BURDEN ON ALREADY STRESSED
ASSETS.
P. GENIES BANKRUPTCY AFFECTS
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS.
PROPERTY TAXES UTILITY TAXES
FRANCHISE FEES AND UNITARY TAXES
MANY COUNTIES HAVE AN ALLOCATION.
OF RULE TWENTY EIGHTY FUNDS THAT
CAN BE USED FOR UNDER GROUNDING
LINES SINCE THIS IS A
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM THE LOCAL
AGENCY PAYS THE UNDERGROUND IN
COST.
AND THEN MUST WAIT FOR PAYMENT
FROM PT ANY.
OBVIOUSLY UNDER GROUNDING OF
WILL HINES IMPROVES WHILE FIRE
SAFETY.
AND SHOULD BE SUPPORTED.
ALL REIMBURSEMENTS HAVE SEIZED
AT THE START.
ANOTHER LOSS TO COUNTIES TO
STREW P. GENIES GRANT PROGRAM
THEY PROVIDE OVER TOWARD THE
LAST YEAR THEY PROVIDED OVER
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION.
IN GRANTS YET IN SPITE OF THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE TERRIBLE
PROGRAM IS NOT SUBJECT TO REVIEW
AS PART OF THE REORGANIZATION.
THEY HAVE OPTED TO PUT THIS ON
HOLD AS WELL.
THERE ARE ALSO THE MANY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS SUCH AS
THE ORPHANED POTTER VALLEY
PROJECT IN MENDOCINO COUNTY
WHICH THEY ABANDONED TO FOR JUST
BEFORE --
THE INDEED INDICATIVE PROPOSED
JUST BEFORE FILING BANKRUPTCY.
AFTER WE HAVE SPENT SUBSTANTIAL
TIME AND MONEY THROUGHOUT --
MENDOCINO COUNTY CINEMA COUNTY
AND MARIN THE UNCERTAINTY AND
EXPENSE OF THE LICENSING PROCESS
THROUGH FOR IS OVERWHELMING AND
THE FUTURE EXTREMELY UNCERTAIN.
FOR WATER IN THOSE AIR AND THOSE
COUNTIES.
DUE TO P. GENIES FIRES COSTS
HAVE GONE UP.
REVENUES HAVE GONE DOWN
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN DIVERTED AND
PRODUCTIVE ASSETS HAVE BEEN LOST.
ROADS BRIDGES WATER SOIL PARKS
TREES BUILDINGS FACILITIES TAXES
FEES PERSONNEL.
AND OUR FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
SOME OF THE COST.
OF THAT WE HAVE PAID BY THESE
FIRES.
P. GENIES CHOICE TO FILE
BANKRUPTCY LEAVES ARE ALREADY
RAVAGED COMMUNITIES WONDERING.
HOW WILL WE EVER RECOVER MANY OF
A THE SAME COMMUNITIES HAVE JUST
DECLARED YET ANOTHER EMERGENCY
BECAUSE OF THE FLOODS WE ARE
RUNNING?
OUT OF MONEY AND TIME. TO
PARAPHRASE MY SENATOR SENATOR
REQUIRE P. JEANNIE EXECUTIVE OR
STOCK SPECULATORS SHOULD NOT
PROFIT WHILEREPAIRS.
TAXPAYERS AND EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS ARE FOREVER
IMPACTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS BOTH BOND [inaudible]
THREE JIM --
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
MY NAME'S BETH VAUGHN AND I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION --
HEALTHY CA WE REPRESENT
COMMITTEE CHOICE AGGREGATORS
THAT ARE OPERATING IN SERVING
CUSTOMERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT ARE EXPLORING THE
OPPORTUNITIES OF COMMUNITY
CHOICE.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NINETEEN
CCA'S AN OPERATION EXPECTED TO
SERVE AN ANNUAL LOAD OF
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND GIGAWATT HOURS.
IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN OXLEY 25% OF THE
LOAD OF ALL THREE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES WILL BE SERVED BY
CCA'S AND TWENTY NINETEEN IN P.
GINNY SERVICE TERRITORY THERE
ARE.
TWELVE COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS SERVING
CUSTOMERS TOGETHER THE CCA SERVE
APPROXIMATELY 46% OF P. GENIES.
MODE.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO SPEAK TO THE
IMPACT OF P. G.'S BANKRUPTCY
FILING ON CCA'S.
BUT BEFORE I DO THAT HOWEVER I'D
JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT --
THE EMERGENCE OF CCA'S IN THE
ENABLING LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED CCA'S WAS A RESULT OF
THE LOS BANKRUPTCY.
ON THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
NOTE IS THAT.
COUNT THAT THE CCA'S THROUGH CAL
CCA HAVE BEEN COORDINATING AND
PLANNING AHEAD FOR POTENTIAL P.
JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY LONG IN
ADVANCE OF THE JANUARY TWENTY
NINTH FILING.
AS A RESULT WE WERE NOT CAUGHT
FLAT FOOTED AND WE'RE READY TO
COORDINATE WITH PJ NEED A FLAG
AND ADDRESS PUT POTENTIAL
IMPACTS. TO STATE REGULATORS
REGULATORS IN THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT AS A RESULT PRACTICAL
IMPACTS WERE MINIMIZED THOUGH
NOT ALL TOGETHER ELIMINATED.
WELL THERE ARE SEVERAL AREAS OF
POTENTIAL CONCERN AND
UNCERTAINTY FOR CUSTOMERS OF
CCA'S WE BELIEVE IN THE
AGGREGATE.
THE BANKRUPTCY WILL NOT ACUTELY
IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE RELIABLE.
CLEAN ELECTRICITY TO HER
CUSTOMERS.
I'M JUST GONNA TOUCH ON FIVE
POINTS --
THE THE BED THE BANKRUPTCY GIVES
RISE TO UNCERTAINTY FOR US.
THE FIRST P. GENIES REQUIRED TO
PERFORM BUNDLE BILLING FOR CCA
CUSTOMERS THIS MEANS THE BILL
INCLUDES THE CHARGE.
THE CHARGES FOR BOTH P. GENIES
WIRE SERVICES AND THE CCA
PROCUREMENT SERVICES.
CONSEQUENTLY CONSEQUENTLY CC IS
RELY ON P. JEANNIE TO COLLECT
ALSO YOU SAY REVENUES.
ENTRANCE THOSE REVENUES TO THE
CCA.
THESE ARE ACTUALLY DALY
TRANSFERS.
WELL THIS FLOW THROUGH PAYMENTS
WAS AT RISK AS A RESULT OF THE
BANKRUPTCY FILING THE
INTERMISSION WAS GRANTED AND WE
EXPECT A FINAL AUTHORIZATION OF
THIS ARRANGEMENT ON MARCH
TWELFTH.
SECOND IN THE CONTEXT OF BILLING
RELATIONSHIPS HE SEES HOLD
EXECUTORY SERVICE AGREEMENTS
WITHP. JEANNIE AS REQUIRED BY
P. GENIES TERROR OF RULE TWENTY
THREE REQUIREMENTS.
TOGETHER REAL TWENTY THREE IN CC
SERVICE AGREEMENTS DEFINE THE
TERMS AND CONDITIONS OF
INTERFACE BETWEEN PITCHING.
GENIE SCCA.
DURING THE COURSE OF PDAS
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING IT MUST
EITHER ASSUME OR REJECT THESE
CONTRACTS.
WHAT WOULD MAKE LITTLE SENSE FOR
P. JEANNIE TO REJECT THE
CONTRACTS THE UNCERTAINTY
REMAINS?
ONGOING PURCHASES OF SUPPLY IN
THE WHOLESALE MARKET FROM PGA
ANY.
THE BECAUSE P. GENIES LOTUS
MIGRATING CCA'S.
THEIR BUNDER BUNDLE PORTFOLIO
HOLDS ACCESS RESOURCE ADEQUACY
AND RENEWABLE PORTS FOR
PORTFOLIO STANDARD PRODUCTS.
THESES CONTRACT WITH P. JEANNIE
TO PROCURE THESE RESOURCES. TO
MEET THEIR OWN LOAD REQUIREMENTS.
SINCE ALL EXECUTORY CONTRACTS
SEEM TO REJECTED IN BANKRUPTCY
THERE IS AT LEAST A THEORETICAL
RISK THAT P. JEANNIE COULD
REJECT THESE CONTRACTS.
LEADING TO NON COMPLIANCE BY
RELIANT CCA'S.
THIS RISK REMAINS UNADDRESSED.
ADDITIONAL RISK FOR CCA'S IS
THAT OF CONTINUE NEED TO
CONTINUING TO CONTRACT FOR THESE
PRODUCTS WITH A COUNTER PARTY
HIS CREDIT RATING IS NOW BELOW
INVESTMENT GRADE. FOR EXAMPLE
THIS MUD HE TRANSAXLE ON BEHALF
OF VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY HOW TO
ADJUST ITS ENERGY RISK POLICY TO
CONTINUE TO TRANSACT WITH P.
JEANNIE.
FOURTH P. GINNY MUST ALSO LACKED
IN THE BANKRUPTCY TO ASSUME OR
REJECT THE AGREEMENTS WITH
GENERATORS.
WHICH UNDERLIE THE CECE'S
WHOLESALE MARKET PURCHASES FROM
P. JEANNIE.
IF THE CONTRACT UNDERLINED THE
RESALE BY P. GENIE IS REJECTED
IT COULD AGAIN PLEASE THE CCA.
I SUSPECT OTHER OTHER LSTS AT
RISK OF COMPLIANCE THE THREE
MINUTES HE'S.
AND THEN FIFTH ON I DON'T NEED
TO GO INTO THIS --
BECAUSE OTHERS SPEAKERS SPOKE TO
THESE --
PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAM FUNDING.
SUCH AS ENERGY EFFICIENCY --
THE CC IS ALSO HAVE THOSE AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THE ORDER.
AUTHORIZING P. JEANNIE TO
CONTINUE THESE PROGRAMS WILL BE --
FINALIZED THE AUTHORIZATION
MARCH THIRTEENTH.
BEYOND THESE IMMEDIATE CONCERNS
ANY RESTRUCTURING IN BANKRUPTCY
THAT AFFECTS P. GENIES PORTFOLIO
OR ITS RETAIL SUPPLY BUSINESS
WILL AFFECT BOTH CC CUSTOMERS
AND BOTTLE REPAIRS. FOR EXAMPLE.
A FAVORITE TODAY'S EXIT FEE FOR
CCA CUSTOMERS THE POWER CHARGING
DIFFERENCE ADJUSTMENT OR P. CIA.
IS DERIVED FROM P. GENIES
PORTFOLIO COST CONSEQUENTLY ANY
CHANGES IN THE PORTFOLIO WILL
AFFECT THE LEVEL OF THE PC I A
IT WILL DRIVE A CHANGE IN THE
EXIT FEW CALCULATION AND WILL
IMPACT THE SECOND PHASE.
OF THE PROCEEDING OUT THE PC
WHERE THE QUESTION OF REAL HOW
DO WE REALIGN SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
OF THE ENERGY PORTAL IS OF ALL
THREE I USE IS BEING CONSIDERED.
INTERESTINGLY THE SCHEDULE FOR
THAT.
IS IN TERMS OF THE PORTFOLIO
OPTIMIZATION TECHNICAL WORKING
GROUP TO REPORT OUT AND HAVE A
FINAL DECISION BY MID TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH LISTENING TO
PRESS REALIZES ALSO.
THE DATE BY WHICH ON THE
REORGANIZATION PROPOSAL --
FOR BY TEACHING YOU WOULD BE
PERCENT.
ABSOLUTELY --
FROM A BROADER --
IT LANDS WE RECOGNIZE THE
BANKRUPTCY PRESENTS SIGNIFICANT
RISKS AND UNCERTAINTY FOR OTHER
SECTORS CRUCIAL TO OUR SUCCESS
AS PROVIDERS OF CLEAN ENERGY.
SPECIFICALLY RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
ABILITY TO TRANSFORM INTO
CARBONIZED CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
SYSTEM RELIES ON FUNCTIONAL
FINANCIAL AND AFFORDABLE
ELECTRICITY INFRASTRUCTURE.
LIKEWISE OUR ABILITY TO
AGGRESSIVELY DEVELOP RENEWABLE
ENERGY PROJECTS RELIES ON REAL
RENEWABLE DEVELOPERS AD FIND
ANSWERS.
CONTINUING ENTHUSIASM FOR DOING
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER CHAIRMAN CHANCE BUT THE
JONES --
WITH THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS --
AND I'LL TRY TO KEEP THIS UNDER
FORTY FIVE MINUTES HI Là THAT
YOU HAVE TO BE SPECTACULAR YOU
THE LIST OKAY.
I'LL B I'LL TRY --
BUT I DID KNOW YOU HAD IT IN YOU
BUT I THE I TOO WAS HERE LAST
TIME AROUND --
AND I WON'T SAY BRETT BRINGS
BACK FOND MEMORIES BUT THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
WILL COME UP THAT ARE DIRECTLY
IN THE PURVIEW OF THIS --
THIS INSTITUTION --
AND THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS --
THAT SAID MY TO I THINK THIS WAS
AGOOD VERY GOOD A GOOD USE OF
EVERYONE'S TIME SO EVERYONE HAS
SORT OF THE SAME BASELINE
INFORMATION ABOUT --
WHAT WHAT THE IMPACTS HERE ARE
OF GOING FORWARD --
WILL AND WHEN I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
SPEAK TO TODAY WHERE THESE
CONTRACTS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT -- A
COMING OUT OF THE ENERGY A A
SYSTEM THAT LARGELY PREDICATED
AYE CONTRACTS WE WE INSTITUTED
AB.
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH CREATED A
WHOLE WAY A MECHANISM FOR US TO
COME UP WITH PLANS PRE APPROVE --
THAT HAVE COMPETITIVE AUCTIONS
PRE APPROVE THAT --
AND THAT WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
ATTRACTING A LARGE AMOUNT OF
CAPITAL THAT HAS MODERNIZED --
ARE ARE GREEDY OUR OUR
GENERATION --
AND IT HAS LED TO SOME --
PRETTY --
IMPRESSIVE --
PROGRESS IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING
GREENHOUSE GAS --
OBVIOUSLY THE CAUSE OF THIS
BANKRUPTCY IS NOT THEIR
GENERATION PORTFOLIO OR
PROCUREMENT IT'S OBVIOUSLY THE
FIRE LIABILITY YOU HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THAT EARLIER --
AND I THINK THAT THE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR DEEP UC AND HIS
OCULAR DID A GREAT JOB OF SORT
OF LAYING THE GROUNDWORK OF HOW
THESE CONTRACTS.
ARE ACTUALLY TIED TO CALIFORNIA
LAWS SO THIS WAS A DAY MISS THE
BIG THE THEY GUESSED WRONG ON
BUYING PENCILS OR TRUCKS OR
ANYTHING ELSE.
THESE WERE IN RESPONSE TO
SPECIFIC LAW --
ELEVEN THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
WHICH IS --
BASICALLY THREE EIGHTY SO THESE
ARE LAWS THAT HAVE BEEN --
INSTITUTED THERE'S ALMOST A
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF P. GINNY
CONTRACTS RELATED TO THE R. P.
S. --
THERE'S ANOTHER --
FIVE THOUSAND THAT ARE RESOURC
ADEQUACY THIS DEALS WITH GAS
PLANTS AND OTHER TYPES OF
RESOURCES INCLUDING --
THERE'S ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED OF
ENERGY STORAGE THESE ARE ALL THE
ADDRESS THERE THAT TO ADDRESS
EITHER OUR PS OR KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON SO THEY'RE THEY'RE
VERY IMPORTANT.
THE ESTIMATED VALUE OF THIS OVER
TO YOU KNOW THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS OR WHATEVER COULD BE A
SIZE FORTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ACCORDING TO PGD DARKNESS THEY
FILED SO IT'S NOT AN
INCONSEQUENTIAL NUMBER.
BUT THESE ARE PASSED THROUGH
COSTS SO --
TERMINATING THESE CONTRACTS
DOESN'T ADD ANY MONEY TO THE
POOL OF MONEY THAT P. JEANNIE
COULD PAY OTHER PEOPLE IN FACT
OBVIOUSLY I HAVE CONCERNS
REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE THE
COUNTERPART IS THOSE CONTRACTS
IS PRETTY OBVIOUS.
BUT WHY SHOULD YOU BE CONCERNED
WELL ASSUMING THEY REJECT
CONTRACTS THAT'S NOT THE END OF
THE STORY --
BASICALLY THE REJECTED CONTRACTS --
BASICALLY HAVE VARIOUS DAMAGES
CLAY THE POOL A LUNCH THE FIRE
VERY ELSE THIS IS THESE ARE
NUMBERS I'M JUST MAKING UP IF
I'M SMART NEW SOLAR.
AND BY CONTRACT HAS BEEN
TERMINATED --
THEY ARE A BIG SHOULD BE
REJECTED IS IS THE ACTUAL WORD
THAT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GOES INTO THIS POOL RIGHT IT
EVEN IF THEY'RE ONLY PAYING
FIFTY SET AT FENCE FIFTY CENTS
ON A DOLLAR.
OR THIRTY FIVE CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR THAT'S LESS MONEY FOR THE
FIRE VICTIMS AND EVERYBODY ELSE
THERE SO THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A BIG
PROBLEM IS SOMETHING THAT.
PEOPLE WANT TO CONSIDER THE
SECOND PIECE IS IMPORTANT IN AND
THIS WAS SORT OF SUGGESTED
EARLIER --
IS THE WHOLE WORLD WATCHING HOW
WE DEAL WITH THIS AND SO
BASICALLY OF A LOT OF MONEY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS GAME HERE TO
BUILD THIS INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND AND IF IN FACT WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS WE START
TERMINATING CONTRACTS IN THE IN
A BASED ON THOSE INVESTMENTS --
IN TERMS OF MODERNIZING IT WHAT
IS THAT SAVE FOR THE FUTURE OKAY
AND I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
BILLS ARE FLOAT AROUND THAT WE
HAVE EVEN MORE INTERESTING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES COMING.
THAT TODAY ARE GOING TO BE MUCH
HIGHER COSTS THAN THEY ARE TEN
YEARS FROM NOW BUT IF WE GET THE
REPUTATION OF THAT BASICALLY
BEING ABLE TO KEEP OUR CONTRACTS.
THAT'S GONNA HAVE A NEGATIVE
EFFECT ON OUR ABILITY TO ATTRACT
FUTURE CAPITAL FOR ALL THE OTHER
WONDERFUL THINGS WE WANT TO DO --
SO I THINK THAT --
THAT THAT'S REALLY KIND OF AT
THE KEY TO IT THE KEY OF WHAT WE
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT TODAY IS
THE IMPACTS OF THAT.
ON A BROADER RANGE.
HAVING SAID THAT IT'S OBVIOUSLY
VERY FOCUSED I TRIED TO MAKE
SURE -- WE
MINIMIZE THE FIRE DAMAGE --
THIS ADULTS ALL TALKED ABOUT YOU
KNOW INSURANCE POOLS OTHER KINDS
OF THINGS I MAY THINK YOU HEARD
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF THIS ON THEIR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE TO KIND OF
WEEK THAT KIND OF FIX IS WE HAVE
TO FIX THIS.
AGAIN ABOUT A BROADER THINGS AND
I THINK THAT WE'RE ALL GOING TO
BE VERY BUSY ON THINGS THAT ARE
NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
BANKRUPTCY IN TERMS OF ALL THE
INTERESTING.
MACHINATIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
THERE AND HAVING TO DRESS THAT
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE IN THE REST
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR.
WELL I THINK IT'S BEEN VERY --
VERY HELPFUL IN TERMS OF A MOVIE
HIS STRIKING FORWARD AND I THINK
GATHERED THAT THIS THE FIRST
STEPS THAT WERE TAKEN LAST YEAR
AND SB.
NOT A ONE THE COMMITTEE THAT
COMMITTEES MET AYE I THINK IT'S
SENDING SIGNALS THAT.
EVERYONE'S TAKING IS VERY
SERIOUS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANNA
THANK OF THAT THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY VERY NICE CLOSING
THANK YOU JOHN --
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU AS WELL I THINK --
THIS BANKRUPTCY WHAT CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION IN TERMS OF THIS
BANKRUPTCY AND THAT THE
TIMELINESS OF IT IN JUST A
MOMENT WAS FILED.
IS THAT IT SEEMS THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY WE HAVE A UTILITY --
DECLARING BANKRUPTCY TO GET OUT
OF AN OBLIGATION OF MAKING.
VICTIMS HOLE AND THAT THAT WOULD
BE ON PRESS AND IT WOULD.
DEFINITELY.
CREATE -- OF
A NEW.
WHICH TO THIS --
IT WOULD IT WOULD A CREATE A
PRECEDENT BUT I THINK IT'S VERY
DANGEROUS FOR OUR STATE'S FUTURE.
IF IN THE FUTURE OUR UTILITIES
GOING TO BE USING BANKRUPTCY TO
GET OUT OF MAKING VICTIMS --
HOLE AND AND MY CONDOLENCES TO
THE ENTIRE TOWN OF PARADISE THAT
IS DEFINITELY BEEN COMPLETELY
DESTROYED.
FROM THIS AND AND WE SHOULDN'T
AT ALL -- UP
[inaudible]
CONTINUE.
TO SUSTAIN POLICIES THAT WILL DO
THAT TO OTHER PARTS AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE.
THAT WILL DEFINITELY JUST LEAD
TO A GRADUAL DESTRUCTION OF OUR
ENTIRE STATE WE DO HAVE TO FIX
THIS I AGREE WITH YOU.
AND THAT THAT SOLUTION IS IS.
VERY TENUOUS I MEAN AND TERMS OF
WILL WE MOVE THIS WRECK XIN WE
AFFECTS INSURANCE WHIM OF THIS
DIRECTION WE AFFECT --
IN -- OF
VESTER AS WE MOVE THIS TO THE
DIRECTION WE WE AFFECT THE
VICTIMS THERE'S VERY LITTLE ROOM
FOR US TO MANEUVER.
THROUGH THIS CORRECTIVE PROCESS
BUT I THINK THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN DO WHATEVER WILL WE
DO.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL FOCUS ON ON ON
MAKE IN --
FUTURE VICTIMS HOLE THE CURRENT
VICTIMS HOLE IN THIS PROCESS.
AND AND A AT LEAST SOME
ENCOURAGE THAT WE HAVE THE P. UC
INVOLVED IN THIS WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SOME ROLE IN
THIS.
IF NOT IS AS MUCH AS ANYONE ELSE
TO BE TO BE FRANK WITH YOU WE
HAVE A GOOD GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THAT HOPEFULLY CAN COULD
WORK TOGETHER WE NEED TO WORK-TOGETHER TO THIS PROCESS AND
THERE'S A LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION.
WE'RE HERE AND WILLING TO TO DO
THE HEAVY LIFTING IN WHATEVER WE
DO PROBABLY WON'T BE.
YOUR ULTIMATELY I I HOPE WE COME
UP WITH THIS WONDERFUL SOLUTION
THAT EVERYBODY AGREES.
TO BUT IN MY EXPERIENCE IN THIS
BUILDING THAT IS.
THE VERY EXTREMELY RARE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I ALSO LIKE.
TO OF OPEN MIKE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS IF WE HAVE. ONE OR TWO
AND ALSO JUST IN THIS PROCESS
THANK OUR OUR STAFF CARRIER SHE
DONE IT NEED ABOUT THESE THE
SERVICE METHOD. FOR HELP IN
PUTTING PUT THIS TOGETHER AND
THE WEEKLY BASIS FOR THIS --
COMMITTEE.
CERTAIN STATE.
SENATOR HUESO PATRICK MCCALLUM
REPRESENTING UP FROM THE ASHES.
WE'RE A GROUP THAT REPRESENTS
THE BOTH THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FIRE A MUD SLIDE
VICTIMS THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN VICTIMS I'M ALSO A MY
WIFE AND I ARE COULD FIRE
VICTIMS --
THERE ARE TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS AND BUSINESSES BUT
LOST THEIR HOMES IN SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN OF THOSE. EIGHT
THOUSAND WILL PROBABLY LOSE
THEIR A. L. THE AILEY'S
INSURANCE STUFF THE PAGER STOP.
IN FIVE MONTHS.
WE NEED IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
TRY TO COME AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WHO IS SOLUTION FOR
THOSE VICTIMS.
RATE PAYERS AND ASAP SAY FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU THE LEGISLATURE COULD
PLAY A ROLE IN THIS WE ALSO
REPRESENT THE ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING THE VICTIMS.
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR A
YEAR TO TRY TO COME TO A
SETTLEMENT.
OF THE BANKRUPTCY THROUGH IT OFF
AN EX CREATING DIFFERENT REGULAR --
NEGOTIATIONS GOING AT EVERYBODY
IN CALIFORNIA IS GONNA BE BETTER
OFF WITH A QUICKER SOLUTION
EXCEPT. FOR BANKRUPTCY LAWYERS.
SO WHAT FIRST OF ALL.
WE NEED YOUR HELP I WOULD ASK
THE GOVERNOR'S OFICE TO SPEED
UP WHAT GOD CALLS THE GRUB TEST.
THIS DRUG TEST FOR THE STRESS
TEST WE NEED THAT DONE QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE CBC'S BEEN VERY SLOW
AND DOING THAT.
WHAT'S THAT DONE WE KNOW THE P.
JEANNIE NUMBER SETTLEMENTS GOING
TO BE DONE VERY QUICKLY.
SECOND IS THERE'S A DIFFERENT
PART OF THIS THAT'S GOING ON IN
JUDGE ELSE UP COURT YOU'RE
READING WHAT'S GOING ON THERE.
HE'S BEEN INVOLVED WITH SENATOR
HILL AND SAN BRUNO HE KNOWS P.
JEANNIE HE KNOWS ARE TERRIBLE
HISTORY ON SAFETY WHICH IS
ADEQUATE.
HE'S COMING UP WITH SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS BOTH FOR P.
JEANNIE THE CITY YOU SEE SOME OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS CAN BE
ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THE SENATOR HILL AND EVERYBODY
HERE AND WE CALIFORNIA'S COULD
BE FEEL MORE CONFIDENT ON A
SAFER GRID AND A SAFER
REORGANIZATION WITH P. JEANNIE.
THERE MAY BE SOME LEGISLATIVE
ACTION AND THAT AS PART OF IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BIRD.
MULLIN RADICAL ON THIS IS IN
REACH THIS AGREEMENT YOU PRODUCE
BY IBEW IT'S BEEN PUBLIC.
WE NEED TO FILL A PART OF NINE A
ONE THAT WASN'T DONE AND THAT IS
THIS DISASTER.
FIVE SO WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
FRIENDS AND INSURANCE GROUPS AND
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO MAKE
A RECOMMENDATION THIS WE'RE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
THIS WILL PROBABLY REQUIRE A
SPECIAL ACTION THE QUICKER
ACTION TO DO ONCETHOSE TWO
THINGS ARE DONE WE CAN REACH WE
WAIT.
TO SEE YEAR YOUR PROPOAL THANK
YOU.
AFTER GOD FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITIES ASSOCIATION JUST
THAT LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW
THERE'S OVER A DOZEN NOT FOR
PROFIT A PUBLIC AND UTILITIES
THAT ARE IN P. JEANNIE SERVICE
TERRITORY.
AT THAT ARE CLOSELY MONITORING
THE BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING.
HAVE FROM OF VARIETY OF
VIEWPOINTS THIS ISSUE AS IT
COMES TO THE LEGISLATURE AND AS
THE GOVERNOR GETS INVOLVED IS
ALSO LIKELY TO TOUCH ON BROADER
POLICY ISSUES THAT COULD AFFECT
THE ENTIRE GRID.
AND AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU --
AS THE PROCESS UNFOLDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE IN OUR
WE AND OUR ADJOURNED